WOULD LIKE TO CALL THE MATTER TO
ORDER AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM CAN
WE CALL THE ROLL.
MY CASKEY HERE JONES.
MCGUIRE.
MINING [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
AS WELCOME ONCE AGAIN --
I WANT TO WELCOME TO MY NEW
COLLEAGUES ALTHOUGH MR CENTER
MUNNINGS NOT HERE YET BUT WE
HAVE CENTER --
JONES WELCOME TO THE WELCOME TO
THE SENATE WELCOME TO THE SUB.
TO THIS IS IT WE HAVE A NEW
CHAPTER THAT WE'RE GONNA START
WITH NEW GOVERNOR WE HAVE A NEW
RESOURCES SECRETARY HERE.
AND WE HAVE A SOME NEW AND SOME
OLD ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS --
WITH OUR WITH THE NEW CAST WE
HAVE HERE ON THE BE SURE
EVERYBODY AND REMIND THEM THAT
OUR ROLE AS MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IS TO ASK SOME
TOUGH QUESTIONS OF THE DIRECTORS
AND THE SECRETARIES THAT ARE
HERE.
THAT'S OUR CHARGE WE WERE TO
SCRUTINIZE --
THE BUDGET --
CHANGE ORDERS TO BE CPC COM EVEN
IF. HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR LOOK
LIKE ONE WE'VE THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO DRILL DOWN AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE EXPENDITURES ARE
JUSTIFIED.
IN THE CONSTITUTION EFFECTIVE
USE OF THE STATE'S FISCAL --
RESOURCES ARE ROLES THE
LEGISLATURE'S DUTIES TO EXPRESS
OUR VISION --
TO I TAKE THE ROLE SERIOUSLY I
SOME EVERYBODY ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TAKES IT SERIOUSLY
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
IN TO UTILIZE THEM WISELY AND
EFFICIENTLY WE HAVE EXPECTATIONS
NOT ONLY FROM OUR DISTRICTS THAT
ONLY FROM THE STATE BUT THE
WORLD LOOKS AT MANY THINGS AT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DOING.
IN THIS SUBCOMMITTEE --
OUR PROVIDING LEADERSHIP FOR THE
FOR THE WORLD THE MOST.
ARENA THE ENERGY ARENA ARE
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES AND JUST
PROTECTING THE NATURAL RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE.
HERE'S THE PROCESS WILL GO TO BE
FOLLOWING TODAY FIRST WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY THEM WILL GO IN ORDER OF
THE AGENDA AND ASK THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND AS FISH AND WILDLIFE --
TO PRESENT THEM WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE WATER DEPARTMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES --
WHO MAKE PRESENTATION ON THE
COMBINED BCP REGARDING MAKING
WATER CONSERVATION A CALIFORNIA
WAY OF LIFE?
LASTLY WILL HERE --
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES ON THEIR PROPOSAL.
AND FIND OUT ABOUT THESE RODENTS
OF UNUSUAL SIZE THAT THEY'RE
GOING -- TO
REMIND US OF LAST --
SO SO WITH THAT LET'S
[inaudible]
SEVEN LET'S.
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
MOTION ON WE HAVE. FOUR OF VOTE
ONLY MATTERS ISSUES NUMBER ONE
TWO THREE AND FOUR I'D LIKE TO
HAVE A MOTION ON ALL FOR THOSE.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY COUNTY HI.
JONES I'VE [inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MY DURING [inaudible]
I OKAY WILL LEAD TO KEEP THAT
MATTER OPENED --
FOR MEMBERS TO TO ADD ON
SECRETARY MOOSE LET'S START OFF.
THIS IS THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
CONGRATULATIONS ONCE AGAIN IN
YOUR POST.
THINK HOW MUCH GERMAN WHITE
HOUSE KEY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'VE IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
THIS IS MY FIRST BUDGET PROCESS
IN THIS ROLE AND OBVIOUSLY MY
FIRST OUT MEETING OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND AND YOU I'M VERY EXCITED TO
BEGIN THIS WORK --
AT THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
AND WE'RE PROUD TO PRESENT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET HERE
TODAY.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO FOR JUST A
FEW MINUTES AS PROVIDE SORT OF A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW?
OF OF THE APPROACH THAT I'M
BRINGING --
TO LEADING THEAGENCY --
AND AS IT RELATES TO THIS BUDGET
IF I COULD --
YOU KNOW FOR MY PERSPECTIVE THE
NOT TO RESOURCE AGENCY IN THE
STATE FACES A NUMBER OF GROWING
CHALLENGES --
DROUGHT FLOODS WILDFIRE ARE
WORSENING ARE DRIVEN IN PART BY
CLIMATE CHANGE --
SEA LEVEL RISE IS IMPACTING
COASTAL COMMUNITIES AND
THREATENING CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE --
ECONOMIC AND POPULATION GROWTH --
WHICH OF COURSE WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE OUR PUT
NEW DEMANDS ON OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MOMENT.
IN TIME. FOR THE NATURIST OR HIS
AGENCY AT THE SAME TIME WE THINK
THE OPORTUNITIES ARE GREAT
ACTUALLY JUST A CHALLENGES --
WE HAVE NEW RESOURCES PROVIDED
BY THE VOTERS MOST RECENTLY
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT PASSED
IN JUNE WHICH WILL TALK ABOUT
TODAY.
WE HAVE LEADERSHIP FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE ON
CRITICAL ISSUES --
LIKE OUT WILD FIRE SAFETY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO MANY OTHER
ISSUES [inaudible]
I'M.
WE HAVE A POPULOUS ACTUALLY
UNDERSTANDS THE NEED TO BALANCE
OUR ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
PRESERVATION OF PROTECTION OF
NATURAL RESOURCES.
I AND THEN WE HAVE A TALENTED
WORKFORCE THE NATIONAL RESOURCES
AGENCY I THE EASIEST JOB HERE
TODAY I COULD TAKE IT TO STAND
UP OR SIT UP HERE AND AND GIVE A
HIGH LEVEL VISION BUT THAT WOMEN
AND MEN BEHIND ME ARE THE ONES
THAT PUT TOGETHER THE BUDGET.
AND SO WE HAVE I JUST A A WHOLE
SET OF TALENTED LEADERS THE
NATURIST ARSES AGENCY.
SO.
WHAT I LIKE TO DO IS JUST
HIGHLIGHTED THOUGHT AT HIGHEST
LEVEL THE THE APPROACH IN THE
PRIORITIES THAT I RING TO THE
NATURIST ARSES AGENCY --
SO FIRST OF ALL A NEW ISSUE NEAR
AND DEAR TO YOUR HEART SHERMAN.
IS OUR OUR EFFORT OUR COMMITMENT
TO A REALLY ALIGNED THIS ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET OF THE
AGENCY TO BUILD.
OUR RESILIENCE NOT TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES OF THE STATE FROM
THESE THREATS.
ARE WILD FIRE DROUGHT FLOOD
ETCETERA --
IN SPECIFICALLY I IN THE IN THE
IMMEDIATE TERM AS IT RELATES TO
WILD FIRE PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST WILDFIRE RISKS --
AND THREATS AS EARLY AS THIS
SUMMER.
NOW YOU YOU PROBABLY KNOW THAT
CAL FIRE --
PUBLICLY RELEASED ITS SO CALLED
FORTY FIVE DAY REPORT I'M IN
RESPONSE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
GOVERNOR NEW SOME ISSUE THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDERS FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE --
I'D DIRECTING CAL FIRE TO
IDENTIFY RECOMMENDED ACTIONS TO
PROTECT VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AS EARLY --
IMMEDIATELY FOR THE COMING FIRE
SEASON.
CALIFORNIA --
WORK WITH OTHER AGENCIES TO
DEVELOP A METHODOLOGY TO
PRIORITIZE THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
BY PHYSICAL WILD FIRE RISK BUT
USE LIKE TRANSPORTATION INGRESS
AND EGRESS I AND DEMOGRAPHIC
FACTORS LIKE AGE.
OUR CAR OWNERSHIP BASICALLY
MOBILITY.
ARE AND SO WE'RE FOCUSED --
IN COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS ARE
ON THE OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY
PROJECTS AND WORK TO PROTECT
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES --
UNDERSTANDING OF COURSE THE
DEVASTATION AND TRAGEDY OF THE
CAMPFIRE AND THE IMPACT ON THE
TOWN OF PARADISE.
SHIFTING GEARS A BUT STILL HONOR
THAT FRAME OF RESILIENCE IS
MODERNIZING OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I AND WATER MANAGEMENT I TO
ADDRESS MORE VARIABLE HYDROLOGY
ARE DRIES WILL BECOME DRIER ARE
WET PERIODS WILL BECOME WETTER.
AND TO TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
AGAIN A GROWING STATE.
AND THE NEED TO ENSURE ENOUGH
WATER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT SO
WILD FIRE AND WATER KEY --
FOUNDATIONS OF OUR WORK ON ON
RESILIENCE.
ANOTHER BIG PRIORITY FOR ME AND
I THINK THE AGENCY IS
STRENGTHENING THE CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE
NATURAL RESOURCES --
SO GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT IS
EXPANDING ACCESS TO OUR PARKS --
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN IN.
COMMUNITIES ARE WITHOUT ARE
SIGNIFICANT ACCESS TO PARKS --
AND THEN LASTLY IS JUST
RECRUITING AND AND MAINTAINING A
TALENTED WORKFORCE AT THE
RESOURCES AGENCY.
ARE YOU KNOW WE VERY MUCH OF
YOURSELVES IMPLEMENTERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S OUR DIRECTOR OF
POLICY DIRECTION OF COURSE THE
GOVERNOR'S AS WELL.
AND SO OUR ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT
IS ONLY AS OF OUR STAFF I AND SO
THAT'S A THAT'S AN AREA OF KEY
PRIORITY FOR ME.
WHAT YOU HEAR ABOUT TODAY IS A
PROPOSED BUDGET --
THAT PRIORITIZES.
THOSE PRINCIPLES THAT I JUST
ARTICULATED.
I DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
PROPOSED OFF FOUR HUNDRED PLUS
MILLION DOLLARS OF NEW FUNDING --
TO ENHANCE OUR ABILITY TO
PROTECT COMMUNITIES FROM
WILDFIRE AND MANAGE FORESTS.
AND THEN I'M ALSO A PARTICULARLY
EXCITED WITH OUR BUDGET
INVESTMENTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS.
WHICH IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM ON MANY LEVELS --
pTHE CORE MEMBERS MANY OF WHOM
WERE ACTUALLY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
YESTERDAY ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDING --
CRITICAL **** CONTRIBUTION TO
THE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS ON
WILDFIRE AND AND MOST RECENTLY I
THIS WEEK UP IN GLENN COUNTY
WITH FLOODING.
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO I AGAIN
YOUR OVERSIGHT OF OUR BUDGET AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE OTHER IS
A LITTLE BIT OF TENSION BETWEEN --
BEING FISCALLY PRUDENT BECAUSE
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE THE
PREVIOUS GOVERNORS HIS POUND THE
DEAD IN TESTS AND THEN BEING.
AMBITIOUS FOR THE CLIMATE
CHANGES THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
HAPPEN HI YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT IT.
EVEN THE LA --
SUGGEST THAT WE LEAVE SOME MONEY
THIS FOR SO THAT WE DON'T.
FOR IN THE OUT YEARS BUT THERE'S
A TENSION THAT SAYS WELL IF WE
START DOING HEALTHY SOILS
SERVERS.
WERE SEQUESTRATION OR OTHER
OTHER CHANGES IMMEDIATELY WE MAY
NOT ONLY --
REAP THE BENEFITS OF REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES AND START
TURNING BENDING ARE --
EMISSIONS BUT ALSO REPAIR THE
FOREST IN AND AND HAVE THAT DO
YOU CAN YOU.
WAX ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THAT FOR A
MINUTE HERE FOR WHAT AWAK WAX
CAREFULLY ABOUT THAT.
AND JUST SAY YOU KNOW MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU KNOW
PROJECTING THOSE REVENUES FROM
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND IS A COMPLEX EXERCISE.
I IN A LOW AND DIFFERENT EXPERTS
HAVE DIFFERENT PROJECTIONS --
SO THERE'S OBVIOUSLY AS YOU SAY
SOME SORT OF TENSION OR SOMETIME
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION AROUND --
YOU KNOW WHAT REVENUES WE SHOULD
ANTICIPATE --
MY GOAL IS NOT TO NOT TO ENGAGE
IN THAT COMPLEX PROCESS BECAUSE
FRANKLY --
IT'S NOT AN EXPERTISE THAT I
HAVE BUT TO ENSURE THAT THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE IDENTIFIED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
GOVERNOR WHILE UTILIZED --
SO I AM.
LOOKING FORWARD TO ENSURING THAT
THE RE OR COOLEY GO TOWARD
STRENGTHENING OUR RESILIENCE.
YEAH BECAUSE WE'VE WE'VE SPEND
SOMETIME IN THIS CASE --
SUBCOMMITTEE ON TRYING TO GET
THE BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR BUCK
YEAH AND AND WE REALIZE THAT WE
HAVE MEMBERS REQUEST ON ON THAT --
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES WE
UNDERSTAND ON PROP SIXTY EIGHT
THAT THE BOND REQUIRES US TO DO
YOU KNOW IS THERE CERTAIN
CATEGORIES THAT WERE SPENDING
BUT WITHIN THOSE SUBCATEGORIES --
HOW?
HOW CAN WE TIME TO SPENDING
BECAUSE WE WHEN WE'RE UNDER NO?
LIMITATIONS ON HOW MUCH MONEY WE
SPEND THIS YEAR OR NEXT YEAR BUT
DID YOU WOULD IN CATEGORIES THAT
WE THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
THOSE LONG TERMS AND AN
IMMEDIATE OF A FAX --
QUESTIONS OF THE SECRETARY. FIVE
CENTER MONEY GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
WELCOME MR SECRETARY --
JUST FOR PRESS SPOTLIGHT ON YEAR
HIGHLIGHTING OF SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS --
THAT PROGRAM PROVED INSTRUMENTAL
WHEN WE SUFFERED.
FLOOD DAMAGE LOSS OF A BRIDGE IN
THE BIG SUR AREA COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO THE FIVE FOR BRIDGE.
IN THE IN RECORD TIME HELPED
CONSTRUCT WITH THE SUPPORT OF
PARKS -- AN
EMERGENCY.
A TRAIL FOR RESIDENTS AND WORK
FORCE IN THAT AREA.
BUT MY QUESTION GOES.
TO WITH OUR EXTENDED FIRE SEASON
REALLY VIRTUALLY ALMOST YEAR
ROUND FIRE SEASON.
CAL FIRE PLANNING IS THERE ANY
PIPELINE THAT HELPS MOVE.
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE.
WORKED THROUGH CONSERVATION
CORPS. TO BE CONSIDERED FOR JOBS
WITHIN CAL FIRE.
IN WHILE EXPANDING BUDGETS FOR
CALIFORNIA --
FOR YEAR ROUND READING THIS --
OPEN THE DOOR FOR SOME A PATHWAY
FOR SOME OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
IF YOU KNOW AND MAY BE BETTER
DIRECTED --
TO TO SEE SEE SEE BENT IF YOU
KNOW YEAH IT'S A GREAT QUESTION
AND I WOULD DEFER.
TO THE CORE REPRESENTATIVES HERE
TODAY TO EXPLAIN IT IN DETAIL
BUT I THINK WE HAVE --
TO WE HAVE TO DEVELOP THAT
CONNECTION AND THAT NEXUS --
IMPORTANTLY BECAUSE WE NEED TO
BUILD A PIPELINE OF FIREFIGHTERS --
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN RANKS AND IT
ONLY MAKES SENSE I MEAN THESE
CORE MEMBERS ARE ACTUALLY.
GAINING EXPERIENCE AND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT --
ESSENTIALLY WILD FIRE SAFETY
PROJECTS SO --
I'LL BE INTERESTED IN IN ADD
THEIR RESPONSE TODAY.
THANK YOU IN I SHOULD'VE LED BY
TO CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
FORGET TO OTHER MEMBERS I DID
FORGET YOU KNOW ONE OF THE A
CONTINUING THEMES THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE RESOURCE AGENCIES THAT
WE'VE WE'VE.
FOCUSED SO MUCH AND WE'VE
STRUCTURED YEAR ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET A SPECIAL FUNDS
YOU KNOW WILL END AND WE REALIZE
WILL HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM.
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND THAT WE
ARE NEVER GOING TO HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY FOR THAT THE
SERVICES THAT WE EXPECT THEM
WANTING YOUR PRONGS IS BRINGING
PEOPLE INTO THE PARKS IN INTO
THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT SAID THE
THE ENJOY IT.
PUTTING ASIDE ALL THE FIRE
HARDENING AND ALL THAT WORK HAS
BEEN DONE WE HAD WE COULD SPEND
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS JUST ON
THE REPAIRS OF THE TH OF THE
EXISTING.
PARK FOOTPRINTS THAT WE HAVE --
IN THIS SAID MINUSCULE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUNDS SUGGESTED IN THIS
BUDGET CAN YOU.
GIVE US SOME IDEA OF YOUR
PHILOSOPHY --
HOW WE YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE CAN
ASK WE COULD WE'VE ALREADY TRIED?
INCREASING THE COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN'S OFFICIAL PERSONS
LICENSE BY 2000% THAT DIDN'T
THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY BUT WE WE CANNOT
THINK OF ALL T. --
THE SERVICES THAT ARE IN THESE
AREAS SOMETIMES THEY CAN'T PAY
FOR THE WELL THE NEED THAT THEY
HAVE YEAH.
I MEAN THE NOW TO RESOURCES
AGENCY STEWARDS IT'S FOR THE
STATE SO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
STATE PARKS IN YOUR DISTRICTS --
AND REALLY ANY MANNER OF OF LAND
OR PROPERTY OR FACILITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE HAVE FRANKLY IS I ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE FUNDS TO OPERATE
AND MAINTAIN THOSE ASSETS.
OUR STATE VOTERS HAVE BEEN VERY
GENEROUS IN APPROVING GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS --
AGAIN MOST RECENTLY LAST JUNE
PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT AND AND THOSE BOND
PROVIDE CRITICAL CAPITAL FUNDING
BY THE CAPITAL FUNDING IS ONE
TIME IN NATURE --
INTO ONE AREA OF FOCUS A
PRIORITY WE HAVE IS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT WE CAN OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN THOSE --
THOSE FACILITIES THAT WERE
INVESTING IN --
SO I THINK IT'S A CHALLENGE
MOVING FORWARD AND ONE THAT WE
WANT WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU ON
A ALSO MENTION ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES OF OUR BUDGET AND IN
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS IS.
CURRENTLY I THINK THIS YEAR ARE
WE ARE WE WLL BE SPENDING OVER
A BILLION DOLLARS --
ON THE INTERESTS PAYING BACK THE
INTEREST OF THOSE BONDS THAT
SERVICE --
AND SO --
WHILE BONDS HELP FOR THE
NATURIST ARSES AGENCY --
FIGURING OUT A SUSTAIN SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL.
IT JUST SEEMS THAT YOU KNOW
FORTY FIVE MILLION ON DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WITH THE SIXTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BILL LISTA LOOK
RATHER PUNY YOU KNOW IS IS THAT
TO DRESS THE THE PROBLEM AFFORD.
IF WE'RE GONNA INVITE MORE
PEOPLE TO GO TO THE PARKS WORE.
THOSE TAHOE AREA WHEREVER
WHEREVER THEY'RE GOING SAID
THAT'S THAT'S A CONCERN AGAIN I
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE ON A LEAN AND
MEAN.
A TEAM HERE AS FAR AS PENNY
PENSION BUT BUT SOMETIMES YOU
HAVE TO PAY AS YOU GO I MEAN
THAT'S IT AND ANOTHER THING.
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SECURING THE MORNING --
AND GOOD MORNING MR KERRY KRATZ.
REALLY GLAD THAT YOU'RE THERE.
I'M JUST A FEW ITEMS INTO SOME
COMMENTS AND LOOK TO YOUR
REACTION IN SOME OF THESE ITEMS
WE TALKED.
ABOUT AS WELL BUT I'D LIKE TO GO
TO START OUT.
IN ANOTHER CHAIR IS GOING TO DO
A DEEP DIVE ON ALL ISSUES A PROP
SIXTY EIGHT HERE NOT JUST A BIT
ALL THIS AGING ERIC LEE --
I THINK AT LEAST FOR MYSELF.
THE LEGISLATION IS BE TO DO A
DEEPER DIVE ON WHAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED HERE TODAY.
AND I THINK THAT --
UNDERSTANDING WHERE YOU WANT TO
BE ABLE TO GO IN I GUESS
EXPEDITE BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THOUGH -- WE
NEED TO TAKE SOME TIME TO PAY TO
INSURE THAT WE ARE.
INVESTING ACCURATELY IN
STRATEGICALLY ENDING.
AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
SAYING IT'S HOLD THIS BUT AS
THESE LARGE EXPENDITURES COME
FORWARD A BILLION DOLLARS.
NEEDING TO BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN AS
SOME ADDITIONAL TIME TOGETHER --
BUT DEMONSTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO FLUSH THAT
OUT NOW TO SAY THAT --
UNDER THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT VIEW
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
CONTINUED FOCUS ON FIRE WE ARE A
LONG WAY TO GO I APPRECIATE
RECOVERING MISSION HAS BEEN --
AND I STILL HAVE SOME DEEP
CONCERN THAT WERE NOT UP TO MADE
SEVEN NINETEEN SEVENTY STAFFING
LEVELS AND I THINK THAT'S A
ANOTHER ITEM THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO CONTINUE.
TO TALK ABOUT THIS YEAR
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE NOT
TALKING CAL FOR CALIFORNIA HERE
TODAY.
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO HAVE YET
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
EXPANDING ACCESS TO STATE PARKS --
BAND I THINK THE WORLD OF MISMA
GIRK WHO'S HERE TODAY SHE DOES A
FANTASTIC JOB AND UNFORTUNATELY
ALWAYS TAKE SO MANY PHONE CALLS.
ON AND BUT WHAT I'LL SAY IS.
WE WE HAVE A BOTTOM LINE TO BE
ABLE TO HIT.
BUT FOR US TO EVER THINK THAT
STATE PARKS IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO BREAK EVEN.
IS LUDICROUS BUT STATE PARKS
OFFERS A STRONGER AND BIGGER
BENEFIT TO THE VOTERS OF THE
STATE AND CANDIDLY SOME OF THE
BEST RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE IN%
THE WEST.
I AND HOW WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
MAKE OUR ANNUAL PASS CHEAPER
LONGER TERM WE ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE ANNUAL PASSES.
HERE IN THE NATION ARE AND HOW
WE'RE GONNA BE OUR TO GET
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN THE
STATE PARKS.
I KNOW IN ONE AS WE DISCUSSED AT
THE SINCE NUMBER COUNTY OUR
REGIONAL PARK SYSTEM --
AND THAT TARGETS THOSE KIDS FROM
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS OUR REGIONAL PARKS AND
HOW WE CAN LOOK AT A PILOT
PROJECT SOMETHING LIKE THAT --
AGAIN BLATANT ISSUE READING I
GET THEM IN A LIBRARY AND TO BE
A TO GET THEM OUT JUST TRYING TO
LOOK AT PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE
IS AN INNOVATIVE IDEAS.
BECAUSE WHERE I HAVE FELT SOME
FRUSTRATION IS WE HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY BOTTOM LINE DRIVEN.
BY STATE PARKS IN --
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN SO BOTTOM
LINE DRIVEN WE ARE A CURTAIN
WHAT WE SAY WE SAY WE WANT
EXPAND ACCESS THE MORE EXPENSIVE
WE MAKE IT.
OUT TO BE A TO GET INTO A STATE
PARK MORE CHALLENGING IT'S GOING
TO BE FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND SENIORS AND COMMITTEES A
COLOR TO BE ABLE TO GET IN. TO
WHAT WE SAY WE NEED TO EXPAND --
AND LONG TERM WE NEED TO BE ABLE
DEVELOP ALL UP A SUSTAINABLE
REVENUE SOURCE FOR OPERATIONS IN
THE BILL TO IMPLEMENT THESE.
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS YOU JUST
WOULD LIKE YOU TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON POINT TAKEN.
YOU KNOW PART OF ACCESSIBILITY
IS AFFORDABILITY.
AND TO YOUR POINT IF IT IS ON
AFFORDABLE ARE FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY TO ACTUALLY ACCESS
OUR STATE PARKS THAT'S THAT THE
CHALLENGE NOT THE PROBLEM --
STATE PARKS HAS COME A LONG WAY
OUR TOWARDS.
AB STRENGTHENING ITS BUDGET AND
THAT HAS MEANT THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT REVENUE IDEAS
ON THE TABLE BUT I HEAR YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT.
AT SOME POINT --
THE NEED TO GENERATE REVENUE HAS
TO BE BALANCED WITH THE ARE.
IMPERATIVE TO KEEP PARKS
AFFORDABLE.
AND I THINK THAT.
pSHOULD BE THE MOST POPULAR
DEPARTMENT WITHIN --
ALL DEPARTMENTS HERE IN THE
STATE.
AND THAT THERE IS A GREATER
VALUE THAN JUST THE BOTTOM LINE
WHEN IT COMES TO STATE PARKS I
ALSO LOOK AT IT IS ESPECIALLY IN
MY NECK OF THE WOODS.
SOME OF THE MOST IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE THEY'RE
HUGE ECONOMIC DRIVERS FOR
COMMUNITIES AND WE ALSO NEED
TAKE THAT ACCOUNT.
AND PREACHING THE CHOIR HERE NOT
AT ALL TRYING TO LECTURE NINE I
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH YOU SIR
THANK YOU THANKS [inaudible]
STERN.
YOU MISTER CHAIR --
WELCOME THE SECRETARY.
GOT A BIG THE YEAH BIG PLATE
HERE IN FRONT OF YOU IT'S IT'S
NOT GONNA BE EASY THIS COMING
YEAR AND JUST APPRECIATE THE
MAGNITUDE THE TASK IN.
SAID TO HAVE YOU BACK IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION TWO IN A ROW --
IT'S GOOD --
AT THE RESILIENCY PERSPECTIVE I
LOOK A LOT OF US HERE FIND TO BE
CENTRAL BADLANDS HAVING GONE
THROUGH.
THE CATASTROPHES WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH --
TO APPRECIATE THAT SORT OF
CENTRAL FOCUS.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A SEPARATE
HEARINGS ON WITH CAL FIRE IN
SORT OF DIGGING DEEPER INTO BUT
I DID APPRECIATE IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS TALK ABOUT.
GETTING DOLLARS AN ACTION GOING
RIGHT NOW THE FORTY FIVE AIRPORT
JUST DROP I THINK THAT'S A
POSITIVE STEP.
TO JUST GET MOVING --
I I DID WANT TO SORT OF RAISE
THIS ISSUE AROUND --
NOT S. R. AREAS RIGHT AND THAT
THE COMPLEXITIES THAT WE HAVE IT
JUST TO GET YOUR GENERAL TAKE ON
SORT OF THE CHALLENGE FROM THE
GOVERNMENT'S PERSPECTIVE WE
MIGHT HAVE OF WE'RE GONNA PUT.
CERTAIN FUNDS ASIDE TO GO TAKE
ON FUEL REDUCTION AND OTHER SORT
OF BROAD RESOURCES RESILIENCY
PROJECTS.
BUT HOW HOW DO YOU SEE THAT
PARTNERSHIP WORKING WITH SAY
COUNTIES MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS --
OTHER THAT YOU KNOW COULD GO
CONSERVANCY'S TO OTHERS ARE
LOCAL PARTNERS HOW DO YOU LOOK
AT THAT RELATIONSHIP WHEN YOU'RE
SORT OF STRATEGICALLY ASSESSING.
THE BUDGET IN THIS RESILIENCE
HERE WHILE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
IN THOSE PARTNERSHIPS ARE
ESSENTIAL SO --
DURING THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION --
I HELP TO STAND UP THE TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE AND IF YOU
RECALL A FEW YEARS AGO.
I WAS REALLY WE STARTED TO
UNDERSTAND THIS EPIDEMIC OF ART.
DYING TREES ACROSS THE SIERRA
AND LITERALLY TREES WERE FALLING --
IN THE IN THE ROADS AND ON
BUILDINGS ACROSS THE SIERRA
NEVADA.
WE QUICKLY REALIZED ENDING UP
THAT TASK FORCE.
IS LOCAL PARTICIPATION WAS
ESSENTIAL.
BECAUSE THESE LOCAL LEADERS IN
THEIR AGENCIES ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE GROUND THEY CAN DEPLOY
RESOURCES MORE QUICKLY AND
FRANKLY MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY.
SOMETIMES IN STATE GOVERNMENT --
CAN THING THAT I'M REALLY
EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
GOVERNOR EARLIER THIS WEEK --
APPOINTED A NEW DIRECTOR OF HIS
GOVERNOR'S A FORCE MANAGEMENT
TASK FORCE A WOMAN NAMED
JENNIFER MONTGOMERY WHO'S BEEN A
PLASTER COUNTY SUPERVISOR FOR
THELAST TEN YEARS.
WHO HAS BEEN LIVING AND WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE --
IN HER COMMUNITY I AND I THINK
THAT APPOINTMENT WAS MADE IN
PART RECOGNIZING THAT THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF BRINGING --
LOCAL TO THE TABLE ESSENTIAL
PARTNERS --
AND NOT AS SUBSIDIARIES ABOUT
TRULY CENTRAL PARTNER SO I THINK
IT'S ESSENTIAL MOVING FORWARD IN
THE WE WE WANT THEM TO PARTNERS
TO YOU I MEAN MY MY CONCERN IS
IF IF. ONE PARTICULAR LOCALITY
DRAG THEIR HEELS DOESN'T WANT TO
SPEND FUNDS WE'RE GOING IN THE
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREAS DO IN
OUR WORK.
AND THEN YOU KNOW MAYBE WERE
CONTRACTING WITH THEM BUT THAT'S
NOT OCCURRING I JUST WONDER HOW
TO BUILD EITHER MORE INCENTIVES
FOR YOU KNOW MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
FRANKLY TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THIS RESILIENCY HAVE PUSHES
BEINGS ARE UNIFIED ACROSS ALL
THERE'S GOVERNMENT SO IT'S NOT
THAT I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
ALL ON TO WHICH IS.
TO SEEMS LIKE A CRITICAL PIECE
BECAUSE EVEN GOING THROUGH CAL
FIRES PRIOR TO MAPS RIGHT LIKE
THERE'S THE FIRE ZONES ARE IT'S
PATCHWORK YEAH AND GETTING
THROUGH THOSE JURISDICTIONAL
PATCHWORK YEAH I MEAN I THINK
YOU RAISE AN IMPORTANT POINT IN
IT'S COMPLICATED AND AND I THINK
THAT.
THE YOU KNOW WHERE WE UNPACK
SOME OF THE COMPLEXITY IS ON
THAT TASK FORCE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
DIRECTLY. EIGHT ONE OTHER
QUESTION IF YOU DON'T MIND LET
ME FOLLOW UP ON THE INJURY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME
WHO WOULD ARGUE THAT BY
SUSPENDING THE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLAR FEE.
THE PEOPLE BELOW LOCAL FOLKS
DON'T HAVE ANY SKIN IN THE GAME
ANYMORE WE'RE BACK FEELING
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
THERE'S A VARIETY REQUEST HERE
THAT ON IT JUST IN THE FIRE
COMING FORGET IF WE WE HAVE A
CAP AND TRADE.
THAT THAT'S AN ARGUMENT THAT
SAYING THIS IS A BIGGER PROBLEM
THAN WE ANTICIPATED AND IT WAS A
EXPEDIENCY THAT WAS YOU KNOW --
WE'D WE DID THAT WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON WELL I WILL WAX
CAREFULLY --
YET AGAIN ON THIS --
YEAH THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT --
YOU KNOW POLICY DISCUSSION ON
THE ONE HAND THERE WAS A REVENUE
STREAM THAT COULD.
THAT COULD GENERATE RESOURCES
FOR CAL FIRE IN THOSE AREAS
WHERE IT IS WORKING BUT THEY'RE
ALSO REAL AFFORDABILITY CONCERNS
IN THOSE RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND WE SOMETIMES WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE WE THINK ABOUT
URBAN COMMUNITIES BUT ACTUALLY A
LOT OF THESE SMALLER --
COMMUNITIES IN THAT WILD LAND
URBAN INTERFACE UP TO GO IN THE
MOUNTAINS ARE DISADVANTAGED --
SO AGAIN IT'S HIS BALANCE
QUESTION MAYBE NOT A SATISFYING
ANSWER FOR YOU BUT WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO BALANCE THE NEED TO
GENERATE RESOURCES FOR CAL FIRE.
AND THEN AVOIDING.
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I GO
BACK TO THE THEME OF HAVING SOME
SKIN IN THE GAME WHO HAD --
AND IN WE'RE IN A NEW DIMENSION
RIGHT NOW ABOUT WE'RE RETHINKING
THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT ABOUT.
FIVE YEARS AGO WAS GIVEN THE
CATASTROPHES THAT WE HAVE WE
HAVE TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT IT
SENATOR I'M SORRY PLEASE
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION AND I
WOULD SAY JUST BUILDING ON THAT.
ALL LACKS LESS CAREFULLY AND
MAYBE NOT PARTICULAR POETICALLY
EITHER BUT TRYING TO THINK
CREATIVELY ABOUT.
THE COMMUNITIES THEY CAN'T
AFFORD IT WHAT IS SKIN IN THE
GAME LOOK LIKE RIGHT LIKE I I
KNOW THAT --
PARADISES DIFFERENT AMOUNT.
AND I KNOW THE MALIBU WANTS TO
STEP UP AND WHAT AND WANTS TO
PUSH AND IS WILLING TO TAKE --
COST ON TO DO SO AND WANTS TO
REBUILD RESILIENCY PRESENTLY BUT
SO HOW HOW DO WE SORT OF THAT
GOOD WILL THAT WE'VE GOT FROM
SOME IMPACTED AREAS THEY CAN'T
AFFORD IT VERSUS THOSE THAT
CAN'T AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
NECESSARILY IN THAT SAME OLD
FRAMEWORK EITHER IT'S JUST.
SOME OF THE PUZZLE ON AS WE GO
FORWARD IN THIS I THINK IT'S A
GREAT POINT ONE SIZE DOES NOT
FIT ALL THESE ARE VERY DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES --
I WILL JUST MENTION BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF THE SO
CALLED HOME HARDENING YES --
AND REALLY WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES TO YOU KNOW PART OF
THIS IS REALLY REDUCING THE FIRE
THREAT AS IT APPROACHES A
COMMUNITY BUT PART OF THIS IS
ACTUALLY PROTECTING THE HOMES IN
THE COMMUNITY.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN A LOT OF
THESE FIRES ARE INCREASINGLY
WIND DRIVEN WE HAVE EMBERS
LEADING --
THE FIRE SO IN IN SOME OF THESE
IT'S A DAY --
CHALLENGES IS HOW DO YOU HELP
THOSE ARE RESIDENTS ACTUALLY --
PROTECT THEIR HOMES YOU KNOW ON
THEIR OWN PROPERTY THAT'S RIGHT
AND THAT THAT DEFENSIBLE SPACE
IN THE SORT OF BASIC GUIDELINES
ARE A CRITICAL AND AND CENTER
MCGUIRE AND I ARE ACTUALLY DOING.
TO A HEARING JOINTLY WITH THE S.
AND NATURAL RESOURCES AND AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AT THAT YOUR AGENCY MAYBE WANTED
A TENDER OR AT LEAST OBSERVER AT
PARTICIPATE IN I I KNOW WE'RE
HAVING A VARIETY TESTIMONY ON
THAT TOPIC --
AND TRYING TO SORT ASK SOME OF
THOSE HARD QUESTIONS ONE OTHER
TOPIC IF I MIGHT RAISE IT --
WELL WE GOT YOU HERE IS IN THE
PROP SIXTY EIGHT CATEGORY WHICH
I KNOW DOVE TAILS HERE BECAUSE
YOU ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO ALIGN
FOCUS.
IN MITIGATING SOME OF THESE
CLIMATE RISKS WE'VE GOT BUT I I
WOULD SECOND THE THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES JUST IN TERMS
OF IT'S A LITTLE TOUGH GETTING
THROUGH IT JUST BECAUSE THE
NATURE OF HOW YOUR PC P. WAS
STRUCTURED RIGHT SO IT'S ONE BIG.
CHUNK AND I APPRECIATE WE SORT
OF STARTED TO TRY TO BREAK
THINGS OUT IN THE ISSUES BUT
JUST AS A GENERAL MATTER I KNOW
WE WANTED TO WORK THROUGH IT
BECAUSE WE GET THAT SORT OF
FOCUS ON A SORT OF STREAMLINED
PROPOSAL BUT IT.
IT'S HARDER TO ANALYZE.
EACH ITEM WHEN IT'S SORT OF NOT
BROKEN OUT BUT FROM WHAT I COULD
GLEAN FROM IT I DO I JUST WANTED.
TO I GUESS --
ASK SPECIFICALLY IN IN THIS SORT
OF THERE'S THERE'S STORMWATER
URBAN STREAMS.
AND MULTI BENEFITS STORM WATER
CATEGORIES THAT ALL KIND OF
OVERLAP OR HAVE SORT OF
DIFFERENT PURPOSES BUT LA RIVER
IS IT IS A HUGE ISSUE FOR US IN
THE ENTIRE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION --
IT'S BOTH A LIABILITY AND AN
ASSET --
COUNTIES REALLY SEEM TO STEP UP
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
WITH THE STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THEY THEY SEEM
TO REALLY --
BE WILLING TO PUT THEIR SKIN IN
THE GAME UP FRONT PASSED A
MEASURE LOCALLY I THINK THAT
COULD HELP --
I WE APPRECIATE SOME OF THE THE
FUNDS BOTH GOING THROUGH THE
CONSERVANCY AS WELL AS THROUGH
THESE MULTI BENEFITS STORM WATER
PROJECTS.
I JUST WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE.
THE THESE MULTI BENEFIT PROJECTS
ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN JUST
THE STRAIGHT FLOOD PROTECTION
PROJECTS.
AND I GET THE PUBLIC SAFETY
RISKS AROUND CERTAIN PARTS SAY
OF THAT WHOLE.
FLOOD CONTROL CHANNEL THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO SHORE UP BUT I'M
WONDERING IF YOU THINK.
YOU KNOW IS THERE GOING TO BE
ENOUGH TO KIND OF REALIZE THAT
BIGGER PICTURE VISION BECAUSE WE
DON'T JUST WANT TO SHORE UP LA
IS A MATTER OF FLOOD PROTECTION
I THINK WE CAN SOLVE THAT THAT
CHALLENGE.
BUT WE WANTED TO TRULY BE A
LIVING BREATHING --
PLACE FOR RECREATION AND AND TO
IT REALLY DOES SLICE RIGHT
THROUGH THE THE PLACES WHERE YOU
KNOW CAN OF THE PARK IS THE LOS
INCOME PART OF THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT WE GOT NOW THE FORTY
FIVE MINUTES AWAY.
THESE KIDS NEVER SEEN A BEACH IN
THEIR LIFE LOOKS LIKE --
THERE SAID RIGHT AT THE FOOT
HILLS THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
BUT THEY DON'T DON'T GET THERE
LIKE THEY'RE BUSY SCRAPING
THROUGH AND SO.
THAT LA RIVER SITTING RIGHT
THERE IN IN THEIR HOME AND HE
MAY BE THE CLOSEST THING THAT
KIND OF COMMUNITY GETS.
TO GETTING OUT PARK POVERTY
GETTING THE FEELING OF YOU KNOW
WHAT IS TO BE OUT THERE SO.
JUST GENERAL SENSE ON THIS IN
THIS LA RIVER ISSUE AND AND HOW
I'D EAT IT HE DOES HAVE A SORT
OF REGIONAL DIMENSION.
BUT WE THINK IT'S A UNIQUE
PROJECT ACROSS THE DELEGATION IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA JUST AS A
SOMETHING THAT IS COHERENT
UNSOLVABLE BUT I DON'T KNOW JUST.
YES WELL TO SHARE MAYBE A COUPLE
OF OF A HIGH LEVEL TO THE
PHILSOPHICAL TALKS AND THEN
SPECIFICALLY SPEAK THE LA RIVER --
AS CHAIRMAN WHITE HOUSE HE SAID
YOU KNOW OUR NEEDS OUT SHIP OUR
RESOURCES.
ACROSS THE BOARD AND SO THAT
THAT WOULD THE PROMISE OF MULTI
BENEFIT PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS IS
WERE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW --
GETTING.
I WAS GONNA SAY KILLING TWO
BIRDS WITH ONE STONE BUT
PROBABLY NOT AN APPROPRIATE
METAPHOR FOR THAT.
OUR RESOURCES SECRETARY BUT BUT
IN ANY EVENT --
IN ANY EVENT WE WE WE NEED IF WE
NEED TO PURSUE THESE PROJECTS
THAT ACTUALLY GET MORE.
ADDRESS MANY OF OUR PRIORITIES
AT ONCE SO --
FLOOD IS A PERFECT ONE WOULD BE
YEAR YOU RAISE AN EXAMPLE OF AN
URBAN PROJECT THAT ACTUALLY CAN
HAVE SO MANY MORE BENEFITS
BEYOND FLOOD CONTROL.
IN THE ROLE CONTACTS BOB IN DOWN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EXPANDING SO
FLOOD PLAINS.
IS NOT ONLY A COST EFFECTIVE WAY
I'M FLOOD THREATS IT ALSO
PROVIDES HABITAT TO ENDANGERED
SALMON AND IN MANY CASES ALLOWS
FOR GROUNDWATER RECHARGE AT
CIGNA COMES INTO A FACT.
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THAT HAS
TO BE ONE OF OUR ORGANIZING
PRINCIPLES OF INVESTMENTS IS
MULTI BENEFIT.
SECONDLY I THINK AS IT RELATES
TO YOU KNOW A BIG PROJECT LIKE
THE LA RIVER --
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES YOU KNOW --
WE HAVE WITH BONDS ARE YOU KNOW
THEY'RE OFTEN CAREFULLY WRITTEN
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF YOU KNOW
SEPARATE THEIR SEPARATE OP
CHAPTERS OR PRINT OUT OR
SECTIONS THAT HAVE THEIR OWN
FUNDING POOLS.
THE ONE WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
MULTI BENEFIT PROJECTS CAN
COMPETE --
FOR FOR A MULTIPLE STREAMS BUT I
WOULD SAY MORE BROADLY --
WE HAVE TO UPDATE OUR OUR
FUNDING APPROACH FOR THESE MULTI
BENEFIT PROJECTS IN OTHER WORDS
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD TRADITIONAL --
DIVISIONS BETWEEN FLOOD WATER
SUPPLY FOR EXAMPLE WELL WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE HAVE A PROJECT
DOES BOTH RIGHT WE HAVE TO
UPDATE THAT.
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO TALK TO DOT
DIRECTOR NEED MATH ARE WHO LEADS
THAT APARTMENT WATER RESOURCES
HE'S DONE SOME REALLY EXCITING
WORK ACTUALLY DOING SOME
RESTRUCTURING AND HER DEPARTMENT
TO REALLY --
ELEVATE THIS THIS CONCEPT OF
MULTI BENEFIT.
I AND SO WE JUST NEED TO ENSURE
THAT OUR INVESTMENTS IN OUR
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS KEEP UP
WITH THAT.
OF OUR FOLLOW UP.
I'LL MAKE IT.
REALLY QUICK --
AND I I JUST DON'T WANT TO LEAVE
THE S. R. A DISCUSSION.
WITH OUT IN BEING ONE OF THE FEW
RULE AREA ABOUT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT BUDGET
DEAL THAT WAS STRUCK OUT
BIPARTISAN DO I MIGHT ADD.
ON THE S. R. A FEE AND WHAT WE
SIGNED MANY RURAL COMMUNITIES IS
THAT BECAUSE OF THAT HUNDRED
NINETEEN HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
DOLLAR FEE.
AND YOU HAVE A LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENT VOLUNTEER FIRE
COMPANY FIRE DISTRICT THEY
DESPERATELY NEEDED REVENUE THEY
COULDN'T PASS IT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE S. OR A FEE ON THEIR
HOME.
AND CAL FIRED ANYMORE TO RESPOND
WHEN THERE IS A FIRE OR MEDICAL
EMERGENCY BUT THE LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENT DID.
SO THERE ARE MANY RAMIFICATIONS
IF WE WERE TO PUT THAT BACK IN --
I WOULD SAY IS I THINK WE NEED
TO TREAD VERY CAREFULLY --
ON THAT SUBJECT FOR BUT I KNOW
THAT'S FOR DIFFERENT.
THAT EVERYBODY ALSO KNOWS THAT.
THEY ARE WAIVED IN THE SENSE OF
EMERGENCY RIGHT SO THE FEES
THERE THERE'S THAT BACKSTOPS
THAT.
BUT I I APPRECIATE THE
UNFAIRNESS OF HAVING SOMEBODY
PAY TWICE FOR LOCAL AND A STATE
AND OTHERS JUST SAYING OKAY LET.
THE FOR SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IME AND WE
WILL THIS.
ON THE ON THE STRUCTURE OF THE
THE BUDGET WE WILL BE USING THE
THE LA DOES BREAK DOWN OF ON THE
PROP SIXTY EIGHT WE WORKING WITH
YOUR STAFF AND FINANCE.
THAT WE HAVE YOU KNOW --
CLARITY ABOUT WHAT WOULD IT IS
WERE ASKING FOR AND ONE OF THE
CATEGORIES BECAUSE WE WE
UNDERSTAND LIMITATIONS IS YOU'VE
YOU'VE HIGHLIGHTED BUT THERE IS
SOME.
WIGGLE ROOM HERE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW SOME FOLKS TO BE ADVOCATES
FOR THE UPPER LOS AT AT LOS
ANGELES REVERSES THE DOWNSTREAM
LOZENGES RIVERTON IN.
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST IN CENTRAL COAST SO
WE'RE WE HAVE A BALANCING ACT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME LOOK FOR
TO WORKING WITH YOU.
AND WITH THAT LET'S.
GO TO OUR BRIEFING ON A PROP
SIXTY EIGHT AND BRING UP THE
ALEJO.
MISS ACT [inaudible]
L. [inaudible]
SELLERS [inaudible]
EHLERS.
ANYWAYS GUESS SCREWED UP.
M..
THANK YOU.
FOR A WONDERFUL CHART AND SOME
CLARITY THAT THAT HE'D.
YEAH AND ON THIS TONIGHT LE
PORCHER PRESENTATION WE HAVE OUR
HANDS OUT FROM
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING RETAILERS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
SO THE SERGEANT HAS PASSED A
HAND OUT IT IS ALSO AVAILABLE
ONLINE ON OUR WEBSITE --
AND I'VE BEEN ASKED TO GIVE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW IT KIND OF FROM
THE HIGH LEVEL AND THEN I THINK
YOU'LL DIVE INTO A FEW OF THE
ISSUES --
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT. THIRTEEN
PAGE ONE PROPOSITION SIXTY IT
WAS PUT ON THE BALLOT BY THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH SB FIVE LAST
YEAR IN APPROVED BY VOTERS IN
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
PROVIDING FOUR POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS.
IT DOES HAVE A NUMBER OF VERY
SPECIFIC CATEGORIES OVER SEVENTY
FIVE DISCRETE --
CATEGORIES FOR THE MOST PART
IT'S KIND OF CATEGORIES FOR
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THERE AREN'T
A LOT OF APPROPRIATIONS FOR VERY
SPECIFIC PROJECTS MOST OF THE
CATEGORIES ARE FOR A DEPARTMENTS
TO RUN COMPETITIVE GRANTS NOT
ALL OF THEM.
SOME OF THEM CAN BE USED FOR
STATE INITIATED ACTIVITIES BUT
MOST MOSTLY FOR COMPETITIVE
GRANTS --
THERE ARE PROVISIONS IN THE BOND
TO DIRECTING FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
CERTAIN PERCENTAGES OF THE
FUNDING.
AND THEY'RE ALSO PROVISIONS THAT
FOR EXAMPLE WOULD WAIVE LOCAL
COST SHARE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THOSE TYPES OF COMMUNITIES.
EVEN THOUGH THE BOND WAS JUST
APPROVED BY VOTERS LAST JUNE
THERE WAS OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
PROVIDED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET BY THE LEGISLATURE TO GET
PROJECTS GOING.
MOST OF THOSE APPROPRIATIONS
LAST YEAR WHEN THE CURRENT YEAR
WERE FOUR CATEGORIES OF
ACTIVITIES IN PROGRAMS THAT WERE
ALREADY THE STATE WAS ALREADY
RUNNING SO THEY WERE READY TO
HIT THE GROUND IMMEDIATELY.
AND THEN SOME FUNDING PROVIDED
FOR IT STATE AGENCIES TO GET
READY TO INITIATE NEW PROGRAMS --
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO WE'VE
GOT A SUMMARY HERE OF THE EACH
CATEGORY WE WE DID SOME
CONSOLIDATING WE DIDN'T SHOW ALL
SEVENTY FIVE I THINK THOSE ARE
ALL BROKEN OUT IN YOUR AGENDA
BUT THIS IS A LITTLE BIT --
MORE CONSOLIDATED SEE HOW MUCH
THE BOND PROVIDES HOW MUCH WAS
PROVIDED IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
THEN THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
GOVERNOR IN THE FINAL COLUMN
THAT IS BEFORE YOU FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR.
I'LL HIGHLIGHT A FEW THINGS YOU
CAN SEE AND THE RIGHT HAND
COLUMN THERE ARE SEVERAL
CATEGORIES I HAVE VERY SMALL
AMOUNTS OF MONEY PROPOSED FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND THAT'S USUALLY BECAUSE IN
MOST CASES BECAUSE LARGER
AMOUNTS WERE PROVIDED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR --
THERE ARE FEW AREAS WHERE NO
FUNDING IS PROVIDED ARE VERY
SMALL ACROSS THE TWO YEARS AND
THAT'S GENERALLY BECAUSE EITHER
A DEPARTMENTS ARE STILL GETTING
READY TO RUN THOSE PROGRAMS --
AND ARE READY TO SPEND THE FUNDS
YET -- OR
THEY HAVE BOND FUNDING FROM
PREVIOUS BONDS THAT ARE STILL
AVAILABLE SO WE'RE KIND OF
HOLDING OFF ON THE PROPOSITION.
SIXTY EIGHT A HIGHLIGHT A FEW
FOR YOU AND THAT RIGHT HAND
COLUMN THAT I THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO DISCUSS AND SUB IN THE NEXT
PIECES OF THE AGENDA.
SPECIFICALLY THE THIRD ITEM DOWN
SEVENTY MILLION FOR VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS THAT'S THE NEW EFFORT
BY THE STATE THAT --
YOU'VE GOT DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS
HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT --
AND THEN DOWN IN THE BOTTOM
CATEGORY UNDER WATER QUITE A BIT
OF FUNDING FOR FLOOD IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS ACROSS A FEW DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES. HUNDRED AND TWELVE
MILLION FOR SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT THERE WAS
FUNDING FOR THAT PROVIDED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUT THE CURRENT
YOUR FUNDING IS PRIMARILY FOR
PLANNING.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME OR
PROVIDING MONEY FOR IMPLEMENTING
PROJECTS ASSOCIATED WITH SIGMA.
AND THEN THE MULTI BENEFIT STORM
WATER PROGRAMS NINETY THREE
MILLION THAT'S A NEW ANOTHER NEW
PROGRAM THE STATE IS INITIATING --
THE CHILL TALK ABOUT TODAY SO IF
YOU.
ADOPT ALL THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD AVAILABLE
FOR FUTURE YEARS.
I KNOW YOU PROBABLY GOT SOME
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS BUT A MOVE TO
ARC --
OVERALL COMMENTS HERE ON PAGE.
THREE SO AB OVERALL THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SEEM
CONSISTENT WITH THE BOND
LANGUAGE AND VOTER INTENT WE
DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING WILD AND
CRAZY IN OUR LOOK AT WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING.
BUT AS HAS ALREADY BEEN NOTED BY
A FEW OF YOU ON THE DíAS THERE
WAS A LACK OF DETAIL IN THE
PRESENTATION FROM FROM THE
GOVERNOR ON THESE PROPOSALS THAT
MADE IT DIFFICULT. TO TO DIVE
DEEP INTO UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THAT THAT SOME OF THE PROPOSALS
REALLY ARE FOR SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE HAS BEEN
RUNNING FOR MANY YEARS THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT LESS CONCERNING. FOR
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BRAND NEW THIS YEAR IT REALLY.
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS
MORE DETAIL ON HOW WELL THE
FUNDING BE SPENT WHY IS THIS
AMOUNT THE AMOUNT THAT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR THIS YEAR. FOR
NEW STAFF THERE FIFTEEN NEW
STAFF PROPOSED WAY WHY ARE THEY
NECESSARY WHAT WHAT ACTIVITIES
WILL THEY BE UNDERTAKING --
SO I WILL WANT TO GIVE THEN
MINISTRATION CREDIT THEY'VE BEEN
VERY RESPONSIVE TO ALL OF OUR%
QUESTIONS AND REQUESTS FOR
INFORMATION BUT OF COURSE.
THAT INFORMATION IS NOT AS
EASILY ACCESSIBLE FROM THE
PUBLIC AS IT WOULD BE HAD IT
BEEN PROVIDED IN A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL SO THEY'VE BEEN VERY
RECEPTIVE ABOUT THIS FEEDBACK
AND I THINK.
WILL IMPROVE THE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD BUT IT DOES THAT PUT A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF THE ONUS ON
YOU TO GET THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU NEED TO FEEL COMFORTABLE
APPROVING THESE PROPOSALS.
SO WE THINK THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD STARTING PLACE FOR YOU BUT
IT'S NOT THE ONLY WAY TO PROCEED --
THERE YOU COULD CHOOSE TO PUT
MORE FUNDING IN THE BUDGET FOR
CERTAIN CATEGORIES OR LESS
FUNDING FOR CERTAIN CATEGORIES
SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO USE.
THE SPRING BUDGET PROCESS TO
REALLY GET FEET HOLDERS FROM
IMPLEMENTING DEPARTMENTS THERE
MAY BE CERTAIN CASES WHERE THE
GOVERNOR HASN'T PROPOSED FUNDING
WHERE THERE IS DEMAND READY TO
GO NOW AND PROJECTS READY TO
APPLY NOW WERE YOU MIGHT WANT TO
PUT SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN.
THERE COULD ALSO BE CATEGORIES
WHERE YOU LEARNED THAT THERE IS
QUITE A BIT OF PREVIOUS BOND
FUNDING THAT'S GONE UNSPENT AND
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT READY FOR THIS
AMOUNT OF PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT FUNDING IN THE BUDGET YEAR
YET SO -- AS
ALWAYS WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
YOU ADOPT A PACKAGE THAT
REFLECTS YOUR PRIORITIES BUT WE
DO THINK THIS IS A DECENT
STARTING PLACE.
SOMEONE THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
HAVE BECAUSE THINGS SEEM TO BE
HIDDEN IS THAT YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR WE FIRST HAD THE PROP SIXTY
EIGHT WE SAW SOME.
ARE PROJECTS OF JUST PICK ON
HEALTHY SOILS THAT WERE BEING
USE OF THAT WERE BEING FUNDED BY
CAP AND TRADE FUNDS THAT ALL OF
A SUDDEN.
THE CAP AND TRADE FUNDS DRIED UP
IN AND WE HAVE NINE MILLION.
BROUGHT IN HERE --
FOR UNDER A PROP SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH IS ALMOST 90% OF WHAT THE
FUNDS WERE SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THIS SEEMS TO BE ONE
OF THOSE.
IMPORTANT GROWING PROGRAMS RIGHT
AND AND I GUESS THE THE
CHALLENGES ON RECONCILING THOSE
THINGS SO THAT WE'RE THE STATE
AS A WHOLE IS.
IS --
GETTING THE JOB DONE.
I AM.
HOW CAN YOU HELP US OUT ON THAT
YEAH I THINK OUR ADVICE WOULD BE
TO LOOK AT THE BUDGET AS A
PACKAGE WITH ALL OF YOUR
DIFFERENT RESOURCES IDENTIFY
WHAT YOUR PRIORITIES ARE AND
THEN FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY TO
FIND THEM SO DON'T LOOK AT PROP
IS INTERESTED?
IN SIXTY EIGHT AT IN A SILO AS A
VACUUM DON'T LOOK AT D. G. R. F.
FUNDS IN A VACUUM BUT KIND OF
IDENTIFY YOUR PRIORITIES AND
THEN LOOK ACROSS FUNDING SOURCES
OF THE BEST WAY INVEST
COMBINATION TO FUND THEM
[inaudible]
CENTER MONNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION.
ON YOUR SHIRT PAGE TWO UNDER THE
WATER SAFE DRINKING WATER.
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION --
IN MY CORRECT IN MONEY
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THAT CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
CAPITAL PROJECTS NOT FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
THAT'S CORRECT THIS IS THE
ESTABLISHED PROGRAM --
THAT THE WATER BOARD RUNS I
THINK THAT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE ARE SOME LOANS AND SOME
GRANTS BUT IT'S THE IT'S
ESTABLISH PROGRAM THEY THEY
BLEND IT WITH --
FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL AND YEAH
THIS IS ONE TIME MONEY SO IT'S
TYPICALLY IS FOR THOSE ONE TIME
PROJECTS THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT CLARIFICATION I THINK THE
GOVERNOR.
HIGHLIGHTED THIS IN HIS
INTRODUCTION OF THE BUDGET --
BUT IMPORTANT WITH ARE SAFE
DRINKING WATER CHALLENGES.
THIS HELPS BUT DOESN'T ADDRESS
THE THE ONGOING NANCE ON GOING
NEEDS THANK YOU.
AND ONLY ON THE PARKS BUDGET
BECAUSE IT IS YOU KNOW AGAIN IF
BASED ON THE BILLION DOLLARS
WERE OVER THE HALFWAY PART.
IN IT IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THE
LOWER.
COST COASTAL ACCOMMODATIONS IS
FLAT LINING AT ZERO WITHIN SPEND
ANY MONEY LAST TIME AND THEN
THERE MAY BE AN EXPLANATION SOME
OF THE OTHER CATEGORIES --
YOU KNOW IMPROVE AND EXPAND
STATE PARKS THERE'S LOCAL PARK
SEEMS WE WERE SPENDING THE MONEY
WE JUST HAD A INTERESTING
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE NEED AND
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND ALL
THAT [inaudible]
THE SERVER.
DID YOU WERE YOU ABLE TO UNCOVER
WHY THERE WOULDN'T WHAT WE
WOULDN'T BE SPENDING SAY EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON IMPROVING.
THAT THE STATE PARKS YEAH SO.
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT ON THE
LOWER COST COASTAL
ACCOMMODATIONS THIS IS TO
IMPLEMENT A BILL THAT PASSED
THAT FIRST REQUIRED AN
ASSESSMENT TO BE DONE OF WHAT
THE EXISTING ACCOMMODATIONS ARE
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY WAS
UNDERTAKING THEY CAME OUT WITH
THE DRAFT AND DECEMBER I THINK
AND ARE IN THE PROCESS.
OF FINALIZING SO I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS WAITING FOR
THE ASSESSMENT BEFORE I'M
PUTTING FORTH THE FUNDING SO WE
MAY SEE SOME OF THAT IN APRIL OR
MAY AS THAT ASSESSMENT IS DONE
TO GUIDE HOW THAT FUNDING SHOULD
BE SPENT.
AND THERE'S THIRTY MILLION FOR
PARKS AND THIRTY MILLION FOR THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY IN THAT
CATEGORY --
FOR THE OTHER.
CATEGORIES A PARKS I'M I WILL
HAVE TO DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT
ON ON WHY.
THEY TOOK THE APPROACH THEY DID
MY MY PRESUMPTION WOULD BE THAT
THERE'S QUITE QUITE A LOT IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
YOU KNOW NEARLY HALF OF THAT
APPROPRIATION --
FOR IMPROVING AND EXPANDING
LOCAL PARK SO MAYBE THAT THEY'RE
WAITING FOR THAT MANY TO KIND OF
PERCOLATE DOWN AND AND THEN ROLL
OUT THE NEXT BUT AGAIN I'LL
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT I'M SURE
I KNOW THEY'RE HERE.
ALL I GET THAT I GET IT ON THE
LOCAL PARK TICKETS THE STATE
PARKS THE STATE PARK SEEMS TO BE
RATHER DRY FINANCE WITH THE WE
DO HAVE A THE BRING CASH FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY WE
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE HERE FROM
THE THE DEPARTMENT STATE PARKS
WOULD BE.
FINANCES I MEAN WE'RE GOOD.
I JUST WITHIN WITHIN THE PROPS
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING SO.
IT'S HOW COME YOU'RE NOT ASKING
ME FOR MORE MONEY.
THE BRAIN DO WE STATE PARKS --
THE BUDGET --
GOVERNOR WAS INCLUDES A TOTAL OF
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS IN --
A COMBINATION OF GENERAL FUND
AND PROP SIXTY EIGHT THE PROP
SIXTY EIGHT PORTION FOR FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS --
OVER A FOUR YEAR PERIOD SO OVER
OVER FOUR YEARS SO IT'S A TOTAL
OF FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS OUT
OF PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT THAT THE THE
PROJECTS THAT WE WE FUND --
TAKE TIME TO PERMIT THE DESIGN --
TO TO THE BED AND THEN
CONSTRUCTED SO --
ALTHOUGH WE'D LIKE TO GET THE
PROJECTS OUT IMMEDIATELY --
WE DO NEED SOME TIME TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND AND AND
AND AND BECAUSE OF HIS PROJECTS.
BUT I MEAN THIS IS MY THIRD YEAR
IN THIS BUT AND THIS PREVIOUSLY
WE'VE TOLD JUST ON THE TOILETS
THIS ON THE BATHROOM CENTER IN
DISREPAIR CLOSE YOU CAN DO THAT
MAY NOT BE THE OTHER PART OF IT.
THE TRAIL PARKER THE RIVER
PARKWAY OR THE OTHER PARTS OF
THE PARK BUT THERE JUST SEEMS AT
SIXTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS YOU
COULD COME UP WITH A HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION I MEAN IT'S JUST.
NOT EVEN A HUNDRED OF WHAT THE
NEED IS.
I I I I GUESS I WOULD ASK THAT
WE GO BACK BECAUSE I'M SURE I
CAN GET SOME INPUT FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON WHERE THE PARK
NEED IS IS THAT SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT MAY BE READY TO GO --
THAT MAY HAVE BECAUSE WHEN THE
TENANTS OF THE SECRETARY IS TO
HAVE MORE ACCESS TO THE TO THE
PARKS SO IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
AGAIN IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WE DO IT EARLIER.
PEOPLE.
GET MORE BENEFIT AND AND THAT
THEY IMPROVEMENTS OCCUR SO --
THE JUST WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES AND IN LESS
I MEAN I GET SALTON SEA I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S NOT READY
AND SOME OF THE OTHERS BUT IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE SOME OF THESE
CATEGORIES.
THEY SHOULD BE POINT WEAKENED
BECAUSE WILL SQUABBLE OVER IF WE
AGREE WITH YOU.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
NO I I I I COMPLETELY AGREE OF
BEING ABLE I DON'T KNOW AND AND
YOU DON'T NEED AN ANSWER HERE
TODAY THAT OUT.
WHEN STATE PARKS --
ADVANCES JUST LOOKING AT WHAT
THE PLAN MAY BE RIGHT SO --
CAN HAVE A GREATER DISCUSSION
WITH ADDITIONAL DETAIL AND I
WOULD ALSO SAY THE SAME THING
WITH THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY.
UP WE GOT SIXTY THREE MILLION --
THERE WITH THE CALLS CONSERVANCY.
AND NOTHING THAT WOULD BE SPENT.
THERE MAY BE FUNDS FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS AT THE STILL USING BUT I
THERE'S A LOT A NEED ON THE
GROUND SO JUST.
SAME ISSUE THAT YOU HAVE AS YOU
CHAIR ON A STATE PARKS I WOULD
SEND THE CALLS CONSERVANCY.
YEAH AND I WOULD HIGHLIGHT THE
WAY YOUR AGENDA STRUCTURE YOUR
DIVING DEEP INTO SOME OF THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT PROGRAMS
TODAY THAT ARE RUN BY THAT
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE ON YOUR
AGENDA TODAY SO THAT MAY BE A
GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR THE DAY YOU
DO PARKS IN THE DAY YOU.
DO ACOSTA ISSUES TO DIVE A
LITTLE DEEPER BUT THE TIPPER
HANDS HERE.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
A CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER --
BIGGEST QUESTION FOR LA --
AND FOR PARMA FINANCE --
LONG ONGOING INTENTION OR AND
RESOURCES FUNDING WORK CAPITAL
VERSUS -- M.
AND THE CONSTRAINTS YOU'VE GOT
ON CAPITAL EXPENDITURES AND THE
HUGE NEEDS WE'VE GOT ON THE
SERVICES SIDE OF THINGS.
PERSPECTIVES ON SORT OF THE
BALLOT STRUCK HERE.
WHAT WHAT IS IT?
SCOPING THE GAP OR SORT OF DOING
THAT WHAT IS THAT BROADER NEEDS
ASSESSMENT LOOK LIKE IN THIS THE
SUBJECT MATTER AREA AND HOW TO
MEASURE A HOW HOW MUCH WE'RE
FEELING THAT GAP I GUESS JUST TO
GIVE A SISTER A GENERAL SENSE OF
A METRIC LIKE.
WE ARE WE TACKLING YEAH MINUTE
THE GETS INTO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BUT IT ALSO GETS AND
OTHER ISSUES TO REGULATE WE CAN
TALK ABOUT LOW COST BECAUSE
ACCOMMODATIONS IN THE CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NEEDED BUT
IT'S ALSO ABOUT.
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES RIGHT I
MEAN THAT'S LIKE A LOT OF THIS
IS ABOUT GETTING KIDS TO THE
BEACH BECAUSE THEY LITERALLY
CAN'T TAKE A THREE HOUR BUS LIKE
THEY'VE GOT.
TO FIND A WAY TO GET THEIR WAR
WHO'S GONNA BE THE COUNSELOR
WHEN THEY'RE THERE AND
ACCOMMODATING THEM TO MAKE THE
LOW COST ACCOMMODATION.
ACCOMMODATING YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE
PEOPLE AND NO ONE AND SO ANYWAY
JUST A LITTLE THOUGHT ON THAT I
KNOW MR CASH WE'VE BEEN.
DOING THIS WORK FOR YEARS WITH
THE SAME AMOUNT CONSERVING FOR
EVEN TRYING TO SORT OF FIND THAT
SWEET SPOT BUT JUST LITTLE
PERSPECTIVE.
I CAN GO FIRST.
YOU WANNA GO.
FOR IT IN THE THANK COMMITTEE
CAN BE DEDICATED FROM EACH POT
FOR ACTUALLY COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROJECTS.
SO WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON ON HOW
THAT MONEY CAN ACTUALLY BE SPENT
TO GET PEOPLE OUT TO THE PARKS
SO TO BRING PEOPLE FROM
COMMUNITIES.
WHO DON'T NORMALLY GET TO COME
OUT TO STAY PARKS LIKE YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT?
YOU KNOW DON'T NORMALLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THEIR THERE
IS 5% IN EACH POT IS DEDICATED
TO THAT COMMUNITY ACCESS SO WERE
WERE WORKING WITH FINANCE ON
ACTUALLY FIGURING ON ON WHAT WE
CAN SPEND THAT MONEY ON IN ORDER
TO INCREASE ACCESS.
ACROSS THE BOARD.
YEAH AND I WOULD JUST ADD.
THE FUNDS TYPICALLY I FROM WE
SHOULD BE THOUGHT OF FOR KIND OF
LARGE ONE TIME ACTIVITIES FOR
SEVERAL REASONS ONE BECAUSE
LEGALLY.
HAVE FOR THAT'S THAT'S TYPICALLY
HOW THEY HAVE TO BE USED TO
BECAUSE IT IS ONE TIME MONEY SO
IF YOU BUILD UP AN ONGOING
SERVICE AND THEN THE FUNDS
AREN'T THERE THAT LEADS TO A LOT
OF PROBLEMS.
AND DISAPPOINTMENT AND THIRD
BECAUSE IT AS THE SECRETARY
NOTED THAT IT'S NOT FREE MONEY
IS NOT CHEAP MONEY IT'S KIND OF
EXPENSIVE MONEY --
BECAUSE OF THAT THE DEBT SERVICE
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SO REALLY
FOCUSING ON THOSE LARGE PROJECTS
THAT NEED AN UP FRONT INFUSION
HAVE.
FUNDING --
AND AND THAT MAKES THE TRADE OFF
FOR THAT THE FACT THAT FUTURE
GENERATIONS WILL HAVE TO BE
PAYING IT OFF.
IN AND SO IN TERMS OF MY
QUESTION ABOUT.
ASSESSING NEED AND SORT OF
MEASURING OUR SUCCESS TOWARDS AT
LEAST SOME BASIC GOALS.
WE RECOGNIZE.
RESOURCES A TOUGH PLACE TO TO
HAVE REALLY CONCRETE METRICS OF
WHAT WHAT IS A RESILIENT
CALIFORNIA LOOK LIKE LIKE HOW DO
WE DEFINE WHAT IS ACT LIKE WHAT
IS FULL LACKS ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL ACTUALLY LOOK
LIKE.
IT'S A ROUGH FART IT'S NOT PURE
SCIENCE ALWAYS.
BUT IS THERE I GUESS START WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION IS WHAT ANY
THINKING ABOUT GOAL SETTING IN
THAT WAY EASIER WAYS TO SORT OF
MEASURE PROGRESS OVER TIME ONE
GOOD EXAMPLE IS THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY I SERVE ON THE COAST
GUARD SERVANTS HE BOARD FOR THE
THE SECRETARY AND THEY HAVE.
A STRATEGIC PLAN WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY MAY FOR THE FIVE YEARS
AT A TIME TO FIGURE OUT OKAY HOW.
HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE DO WE WANT
TO GET ACCESS TO THE COAST --
HOW MUCH MORE LAND DO WE WANT TO
PURCHASE?
HOW MANY MORE PROJECTS ARE WE
GONNA FUND THAT ACTUALLY GIVE
PEOPLE ACCESS --
TO BEACHES TO THE COASTAL AREAS
ON HOW MANY MILES A TRAIL THE
COASTAL TRAILER WE GOING TO
PRODUCE SO.
THOSE METRICS REALLY HELP THEM
AND HELP US AS A BOARD DECIDE
WHERE WE WANT TO INVEST THE
MONEY.
AND SO DO YOU THINK THERE'S A
CHANCE TO APPLY THAT SAME KIND
OF SYSTEMATIC APPROACH MORE
BROADLY AROUND THIS SORT OF
RESILIENCY --
PUSH THAT SEEMS LIKE THE CENTRAL
DRIVING.
THEME MORE AT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE DO TO IS IF THERE ARE
STATEWIDE THEMES WE WORK WITH
OUR GRANT PROGRAMS TO ACTUALLY
INCLUDE THAT INFORMATION IN
THEIR GUIDELINES.
SO IT SPREAD ACROSS THE WHOLE
AGENCY SO IF THERE'S SOMETHING
WE REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE.
WE CAN DO THAT THROUGHOUT ALL
THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
I I GUESS WHAT I'M I'M SORT OF
GETTING THAT MAYBE IS EMILIO YOU
CAN HELP JUST GIVE US SOME
ADVICE ON ON GOING BASED ON IS.
WE'RE GONNA SPEND ALL THIS THE
BOND IN GENERAL FUND ANOTHER
DOLLARS.
ON TRY TO MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
RESILIENT MEANWHILE GOT A A
MAJOR WILDFIRE LIABILITY ISSUE
THAT WE'RE WRESTLING WITH IS A
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
REDUCE RISK RIGHT HAD THAT SORT
OF REDUCE THAT COST IT'S GOING
TO BE BORNE BY SOMEONE FROM.
THESE CLIMATE CATASTROPHES.
AND SO I THINK WHEN YOU KNOW
YOU'VE GOT.
THE MARKET SORT OF LOOKING SAID
OUR UTILITY SECTOR IN SAYING
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING A VERY
NARROW KIND OF RISK ANALYSIS IF
WE'RE ABLE TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER.
AND HAVE LESS RISK TO SAY
HOMEOWNERS AT THE END OF THE
LINE WHO.
NOT NECESSARILY JUST FROM A PURE
GREED PERSPECTIVE BUT FROM ALL
THIS OTHER SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING
ALL THIS THE REST IS LIKE HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY.
QUANTIFY RISK REDUCTION EARLY
SET UP SOME SELF EVALUATION
FRAMEWORK TO TO KIND OF IS THAT
IS THAT TO ABSTRACT OR IS IT IS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT POSSIBLE I I
THINK IT IS AN IT IS NEW ARE THE
WAY WE HAVE TRADITIONALLY DONE
IT IS.
THROUGH GRAY INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S
PRETTY.
STRAIGHTFORWARD WE WANT TO
PROVIDE WATER FOR THE THE BILL
THE WATER TREATMENT PLANT THAT'S
GONNA PROVIDE WATER FOR THIS
MANY PEOPLE.
THE WAY THE STATE HAS
TRADITIONALLY HELD GRANTEES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR BOND PROJECTS IS
OKAY IN YOUR APPLICATION YOU
SAID YOU WERE GOING TO DO THIS
PROJECT THAT CREATED.
X. NUMBER OF ACRES OF WETLAND
OKAY YOU CREATED X. NUMBER OF
ACRES GREAT YOU'VE DONE YOUR JOB
BUT THAT BUT THAT ISN'T GETTING
IT KIND OF THIS NEXT LEVEL OF IS
IT ACHIEVING THE GOALS WE WANTED
BEYOND.
THE CONCRETE MEASURES SO I THINK
WHEN AGENCY THAT'S THAT'S REALLY
BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS IS A
SIERRA NEVADA CONSERVANCY AND I
THINK YOU'VE GOT THEM ON OF
SUBSEQUENT PANEL THEY ARE
WORKING ON DEVELOPING AT DASH
BOARD OF RESILIENCE FOR SOME OF
THEIR FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS
THAT'S NOT JUST OKAY.
WE REMOVED --
AT EXCESS VEGETATION AN EX
NUMBER OF ACRES BUT WHAT DID
THAT YIELD US WHAT ARE WE WHAT
ARE WE ANTICIPATING IT'S GOING
TO BE.
FOR YOU KNOW WATER YIELD FROM
THE FOREST AND WILDLIFE BENEFITS
AND SO IT'S CERTAINLY MORE.
CAN A SQUISHY THAN THAN SOME OF
THE HARD.
CONCRETE ANSWERS BUT ITHINK IT
CAN BE GROUNDED IN SCIENCE AND
AND IF IT IS THEN IT CAN BE
MEANINGFUL SO THAT MAY BE --
IN A FUTURE AGENDA SOMETHING YOU
WANT TO PURSUE AND AND HEAR
ABOUT SOME OF THE METRICS
THEY'RE USING AND SEE WHETHER
THAT COULD BE USED ACROSS ACROSS
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE IT'S IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION OF
BEYOND.
DID YOU DO WHAT WE YOU SAID YOU
WERE GONNA DO BUT DID YOU DO
WHAT WE WANT YOU TO DO.
I THINK DE THE CHALLENGES HIS
HOUSE AFFECTS THE COMMUNITY AT
THE LARGER BECAUSE WE'VE GOT IN
ON THE STREET.
OF WETLAND INSTREAM REPAIR I
MEAN WE COULD SPEND A TON OF
MONEY ON THE DAMAGE HAS OCCURRED
FROM JUST.
HUMANS ACTIVITY OR THE PREVIOUS
LUMBAR RAT ACTIVITIES OR THE
RECENT STORMS AND WE LOOK IN AND
WE SAY OKAY HOW DO WE REPAIR
THOSE.
WE DO DEAL FASHION WAY OR WE
COULD TRY TO TO DO IT IN SUCH A
WAY THAT IT THAT IT BENEFITS THE
FOR THE FLOW OF WATER SO THE
SENTIMENTS THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
NATURALLY FLOW OUT INTO THE
DELTA OR TO THE BAY.
IMPROPER OCCUR RIGHT TO HOW HOW
WE USING THE BEST ENGINEERING
NOT THE NINETEEN FIFTIES WAY BUT
IN A IN A A RESILIENT HUESO WERE
SAYING HOW DO WE INTERACT ANDY
THAN DOING DAMAGE CORRECTION BUT
ALSO IMPROVEMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE OTHER THE OTHER
BENEFITS THAT WOULD OCCUR TO THE
YOU KNOW THE ECOSYSTEM IT AT
LARGE AND THAT'S A BIGGER
CHALLENGE.
AND AND I THINK ONE PIECE TO ADD
IS IF WE WANTED.
TO PURSUE THIS IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE SOME MORE FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL YEARS OF MONITORING
AND SEEING KIND OF DOING THE
SCIENTIFIC FOLLOW UP ON HOW IS
THE WETLAND PERFORMING IN IS IS
IS IS THE WATER.
FLOWING THROUGH OR IS IT GETTING
SILTED UP AFTER FIVE YEARS YOU
KNOW THOSE THOSE TYPES OF
ONGOING.
MONITORING AND AND ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES THAT MAY HAPPEN AND
THAT ISN'T TRADITIONALLY HOW WE
HAVE.
USED AT LEAST BOND FUNDING FOR
PROJECTS THAT'S BEEN ONE PLOP
AND AND WE'RE DONE SECTOR. ONE
THING THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE DID LAST
YEAR WAS WE STARTED A UNIT AT
THE AGENCY TO ACTUALLY.
DO THIS TYPE OF THING TO DO
MONITORING AND TO FIGURE OUT
BEST PRACTICES I THINK YOU
REMEMBER WAS PASSED LAST YEAR IN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THEY'RE WORKING ON METRIC AT
THE USE WERE THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
AND THEY'LL BE SPREADING THAT
INFORMATION ALL THROUGHOUT OUR
DEPARTMENTS.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE GOT --
DESIRE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE IS ALSO.
ARE WORKING WITH ALL THE FLOOD
CONTROL AGENCIES AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT LOCALITIES THAT ARE
THERE AND YOU KNOW THE
CONSERVANCY'S IS ALSO WERE ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE MEAN WE WANT TO
HAVE.
I'M.
DELIGHTED TO HEAR THAT THE CALLS
CONSERVANCY IS IS IS LOOKING AT
THESE EXPAND EXPANSION VERSES
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
AGENCIES SIMPLY BY LAND IN THE
WORD OF PRESERVATION BUT THEY'RE
NOT.
THE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
MORE THING ELSE TO MANAGE IT OR
TO DO ANYTHING AND WE'VE GOT
WE'VE GOT A MALL IN OUR DISTRICT
AND ALL ALL IN THE REGION AND
THAT HAS SORT OF BEEN THE THE
MENTALITY IS THAT WE JUST GOT
PROTECT.
PROTECT IS A JUST CHOIR VERSES
BECAUSE WE THINK SOME OTHER
ACTIVITIES AGREE CONVERSES
PROTECT AS A BE.
A THE STEWARD OF THE PRICE OF
THE PROPERTY AND NOT JUST
HOLDING IT SO.
HI THIS. ONE ONE FINAL POINT IN
THE IN THE METRICS THAT YOU'RE
DISCUSSING MR CASH MOST YEAR.
IS RESILIENCY A PART OF THOSE
METRICS WHEN YOU'RE DOING I
BELIEVE IT IS GUIDELINES YOU ALL
DEVELOPED PURSUANT TO THE BUDGET
ACTION I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS ACTUALLY --
FOR FOR STAFF PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON TRACKING ALL
THE BOND PROJECTS AND THEN.
WORKING ON FIGURING OUT WHAT
WHAT THE STATE ACTUALLY GOT FOR
THEIR THEIR DOLLARS AND THEN
WHAT ARE THE BEST PRACTICES
ENSURING THOSE THROUGHOUT THE
PROJECT.
OKAY WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
THAT THANK GOD.
LET'S CALL UP OUR LEARN MORE
ABOUT THESE FALL TERRY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS WE HAVE A
DIRECTOR BONHAM AND I UNDERSTAND
THE MISS MESSER FLIGHT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES WILL.
HELP JOINT.
SECRETARY CASH CASH.
IF I COULD JUST ADD --
WE AGREE WITH THE LA DOES
ASSESSMENT.
AND WHAT THE MEMBERS OF SAID
ABOUT PROVIDING MORE INFORMATION.
AND WE HAVE A MEETING SET UP
NEXT WEEK WITH THE LA --
WITH FINANCING WITH STAFF TAX IN
THE FUTURE WHAT WE WANT THINGS
TO LOOK LIKE HOW MUCH
INFORMATION DO WE NEED TO
PROVIDE BECAUSE WE REALLY WANT
TO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU NEED.
THE PUBLIC NEEDS. TO TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES PERFECT
[inaudible] THIRTY WHO GOES
FIRST THIRTY BOTTOM PLACE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME'S CHUCK BOND AMONG THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
STILL I THINK THE GREATEST JOB
IN THE WORLD.
AND I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE THIS
ITEM AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE DEPUTY DIRECTOR MESSER
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK.
AS OUR LAST PIECE AND ANSWER THE
STAFF QUESTIONS THAT APPEAR ON
THE AGENDA I BELIEVE PAGE.
FOURTEEN SO WHAT IS A VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT.
THERE ARE THREE THINGS I'D LIKE
TO IMPRESS UPON.
FIRST.
WATER DEFINES CALIFORNIA.
EITHER BECAUSE OF ITS SCARCITY
OR BECAUSE OF ITS ABUNDANCE.
WE HAVE FOUGHT ABOUT IT FOREVER.
WE ARE LIKELY TO FIGHT ABOUT IT
IN THE FUTURE HOLLYWOOD IS MADE
MOVIES ABOUT THOSE FIGHTS
[inaudible]
SECOND.
IF YOU CAN IMAGINE A MAP OF
CALIFORNIA IN YOUR HEAD RIGHT
NOW.
WE HAVE WATERSHEDS IN RIVERS.
ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE.
AT THE SAME TIME IN ANY GIVEN
DAY.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
REGULATORY.
ENDEAVORS OR PROCEEDINGS OR
AUTHORITIES STATE AND FEDERAL.
IN ANY GIVEN WATERSHED ABOUT THE
USE OF WATER.
THE MANAGEMENT OF LAND THE
PROTECTION OF SPECIES.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IN MOST
THOSE WATERSHEDS.
THEIR VIBRANT ENDEAVORS TO
COLLABORATE. TO PRODUCE DURABLE
RESULTS QUICKLY.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY THIRD
POINT.
OUR PRIME MANAGER OF WATER IN
CALIFORNIA OUR OUR COLLEAGUES AT
OUR STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
THEY HAVE A STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITY. TO DEFINE WATER
QUALITY OBJECTIVES [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE THINKING ABOUT THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER AND ITS
TRIBUTARIES.
AS WELL AS THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
IMAGINE READING DOWN TO HEAR.
AND THE TRIBUTARIES TO IT AND
THE DELTA. TO UPDATE THE WATER
QUALITY OBJECTIVES IMPORTANT
WORK.
THE IDEA OF A VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT IS OUR TWO DEPARTMENTS
WORKING WITH WATER USERS AND
CONSERVATION GROUPS.
CAN DESIGN A COLLABORATIVE
PACKAGE.
OF RESTORATION MEASURES.
AND FLOW IMPROVEMENTS.
AND BRING IT TO THE WATER BOARD
THEY CAN OF VALUE WAITED
TRANSPARENTLY. TO DETERMINE IF
AS THE SCIENTIFIC AND LEGAL
SUFFICIENCY.
THE BECOME THE WAY WE ACHIEVE
THOSE WATER QUALITY OBJECTIVES.
THAT'S THE IDEA.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE EASY --
LET ME TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO GIVE.
THAT INSTITUTIONS VIEW ON THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF THIS
APPROACH.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR BONHAM AND
GOOD MORNING --
FIRST OFF LET ME EXPRESS
DIRECTOR NAME ITS REGRETS SHE
WAS HERE EARLIER SHE HAD TO
LEAVE SO I SHOOTING IN AND
HOPEFULLY I'LL DO THIS LITTLE
JUSTICE --
BUT TO JUST VERY QUICKLY FOLLOW
UP ON THE DIRECTOR'S COMMENTS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES WE ARE VERY EAGER TO
ENGAGE IN THIS VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS PROCESS.
IS NOT ONLY DOES IT PROMISED
BENEFITS FOR WATER SUPPLY BUT
ALSO WATER QUALITY AND IT ALSO
ENTAILS HABITAT RESTORATION
PROJECTS THAT.
HELP TO PROTECT OUR WATERSHEDS
AND HELP TO CREATE.
CONDITIONS THAT ARE BETTER FOR
NATIVE FISH SPECIES SO FOR US
IT'S KIND OF THE THE WHOLE
PACKAGE IF YOU WILL --
OF BENEFITS THAT WE WE SEEM.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS THERE'S A
GREAT DEAL OF TRANSPARENCY THERE
WILL BE A GREAT DEAL OF
TRANSPARENCY AND THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR DEPARTMENT
IT'S ONE OF OUR CORE VALUES IT'S
IN OUR STRATEGIC PLAN.
I THINK BY THE NATURE OF HOW
THIS PROCESS WILL WORK WITH
BROAD STAKEHOLDER.
ENGAGEMENT IT LENDS ITSELF TO
ALLOWING US.
TO CONTINUE TO INCREASE OUR
VISIBILITY OF THE WORK THAT WE
ARE INVOLVED IN OF THE BENEFITS
OF THAT WORK AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE ENGAGE WITH.
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN IT
BACK OVER TO DIRECTOR BOTTOM SO
HERE ARE OUR THOUGHTS ON THE
QUESTIONS --
STAFF ASKS ON PAGE.
FOURTEEN LET ME JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
I UNDERSTAND IT'S A HOLD OPEN
ITEM I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION.
I AGREE WITH THE LA --
REPORT THE THIS EXPENDITURES
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE PROPOSITION.
PROP SIXTY EIGHT ACTUALLY SETS
ASIDE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THIS ENDEAVOR SO
WHY SEVENTY MILLION AND NOT
SEVENTY ONE OR SIXTY NINE I
THINK SEVENTY IS A BEST
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT RELATED TO
THE SCALE HERE'S THE SCALE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HABITAT
RESTORATION INSTREAM FLOW
IMPROVEMENTS.
FROM BASICALLY MERCED. TO THE
DELTA.
THE TRIBUTARY OF THE TO WOLLEMI
AND POTENTIALLY.
THE STATE DOES STANISLAUS IN THE
MERCED RIVER'S.
THE DELTA PROPER.
ALL OF THE SACRAMENTO FROM HERE
ALMOST UP TO READING.
AND THE TRIBUTARIES OF THE YUBA.
THE AMERICAN RIVER THE FEATHER
RIVER THE MCCALL IN THE RIVER --
I DON'T THINK I'VE LEFT ANY OUT.
SO THE SCALE IS A MESS.
AND IT MATCHES THE NEED.
WHERE DIRE SITUATION WITH MANY
OF OUR HIGHLY MIGRATORY FISH
SPECIES WE NEED TO GET INTO THE
LANDSCAPE?
AND TURN DARK YESTERDAY ONE
FLOODPLAIN CONNECTION REMOVING
FISH BARRIER --
PROBLEMS HE'S PUTTING GRAVEL AND
CLEANING GRAVEL WE NEED TO BE
DOING THAT YESTERDAY.
SO WE THOUGHT ABOUT OUR
MANAGEMENT OF OUR EXISTING
RESTORATION PROGRAMS AND
CONCLUDED SEVENTY MILLION WAS A
BEST PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT
AMOUNT.
GIVEN THE BROADER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION SET ASIDE IMPROPER.
SIXTY EIGHT HOW WILL WE GO ABOUT
SELECTING IN PRIORITIZING THE
USE OF THOSE FUNDS.
WE EXPECT. TO BE SUBMITTING TO
THE STATE WATER BOARD OVER TIME.
A SERIES OF DESCRIPTIVE
PROPOSALS ABOUT POTENTIAL
PROJECTS FOR INVESTMENT.
OUR DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN
RUNNING FOR MANY YEARS
RESTORATION GRANTING PROGRAMS
THAT ALLOW OUR SCIENTIST WORKING
WITH EXTERNAL PARTIES. TO
PRIVATIZE THE HIGHS RETURNS ON
INVESTMENT --
I WOULD IMAGINE RESOURCE AGENCY
WHICH IS THE BENEFICIARY OF THE
FUNDS IN THE PROPOSITION WOULD
BE CONSULTING WITH THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS.
AND THE COALITION OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS.
MOSTLY THE IDEA IS USING
EXISTING FUNDING SOURCES SO IF
YOU LOOK AT PROP SIXTY EIGHT I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
REALIZE IT'S POTENTIALLY.
FEASIBLE TO USE PROPOSITION ONE
FUNDS.
REMAINING PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
FUNDS WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD FUNDS TO ALIGN WITH THIS
GLOBAL ENDEAVOR TO MAKE THIS
LANDSCAPE SCALE CHANGE IN THE
SACRAMENTO IN THE SAN JOAQUIN.
I'M JUST LOOKING AT THE
QUESTIONS AND I'LL SAY I THINK.
THAT COVERS MANY OF THEM I WOULD
IMAGINE THE FUNDS.
I KNOW THE FUNDS WILL BE SPENT
CONSISTENT WITH THE GUIDANCE
THAT YOU FIND IN THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE.
AS WELL AS SECTION SEVEN NINE
SEVEN THREE TWO AND SEVEN NINE
SEVEN THREE SIX OF THE WATER
CODE.
WHICH PRECISELY DEFINE THE TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES THAT ARE QUALIFIED
IS ELIGIBLE FOR INVESTMENT.
ALSO I THINK TELLS YOU THESE
FUNDS CAN'T BE SPENT ON OTHER
THINGS LIKE CONVEYANCE PROJECTS
IN THE DELTA.
IN REQUIRE ANNUAL REPORTING BY
SECRETARY CROWFOOT BACK TO YOU
ABOUT THE USE OF FUNDS.
HERE'S MY CONCLUSION.
CAN YOU GIVE US SOME IDEA OF THE
TOTAL COSTS IF YOU HAD IF WE HAD
THE OPEN CHECKBOOK AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS BOND PROVIDES
TWO HUNDRED MILLION WHAT ARE THE
UNDER THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
WHAT IS THE POTENTIAL.
FOR APPLICATIONS OR COOPERATION
THAT AND AND THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE THE RESOURCES THAT HAVE TO
BE SPENT SO WE I GUESS.
I'M GET APPLES AND APPLES HERE
YES [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
ENDEAVOR [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
CONTINUING SO SOME OF THE
NUMBERS ARE SUBJECT TO
REFINEMENT.
AS WE GO THROUGH THE DIALOGUE
WITH THE COALITION AND OF COURSE
ENGAGE WITH YOU.
BUT AS A GENERAL MATTER --
ONE OF THE PRIME FEATURES OF A
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT THAT'S
REALLY ATTRACTIVE TO ME.
IS THE WATER USERS INVOLVED ARE
PROPOSING TO CHARGE THEMSELVES.
IN GENERATE AS I UNDERSTAND IT
ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
FROM THEIR OWN CHARGES FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE HABITAT
RESTORATION INVESTMENT.
THE INCREASE IN STREAM FLOW AND
NEW SCIENTIFIC PROGRAMS TO
MONITOR ALL THIS.
SO OVER HALF A BILLION DOLLARS.
A IS WHAT WE'VE SUGGESTED ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
FROM THAT SELF CHARGE.
COMBINED WITH WE'VE.
FIGURED OUT THE POTENTIAL OF
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
MILLION PUBLIC FUNDS THAT
ALREADY EXIST.
WHICH COULD BE BROUGHT TO BEAR
AND IF I MATHIS IS RIGHT THAT'S
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE ONE BILLION.
AS A TOTAL EFFORT.
ACROSS ALL THAT GEOGRAPHY.
WE TO INCLUDING THIS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THAT'S PROOF CORRECT AND
THE SEVENTY PART OF WHAT GOD.
SO HERE'S MY CONCLUDING REMARKS
ANIMAL POTS FOR QUESTIONS.
I'VE BEEN DOING.
THIS WORK IN THE WEST MY ENTIRE
CAREER --
FIRST IN THE NONPROFIT SPACE.
AND NOW --
THE GREAT HONOR OF SERVING IN
THIS BILL.
I'VE NEVER RUN ACROSS MORE
DIFFICULT [inaudible]
PROJECT.
THINK ABOUT THE CHARACTERS FROM
READING TO MERCED IN.
ALL OF OUR IMPORTANT
STAKEHOLDERS --
THERE'S A LOT OF LEGITIMATE
CONCERN ABOUT THIS ENDEAVOR YOU
MAY HEAR PEOPLE CRITICIZE IT YOU
MAY.
HEAR PEOPLE SAY WERE DOUBLE
COUNTING PROJECTS OR THIS IS ALL
SMOKE AND MIRRORS.
I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT'S HAPPENED
IN THE NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION
IS SECRETARY CROWFOOT.
AND SECRETARY BLUMENFELD A KELLY
PA HAVE REALLY INSTRUCTED THE
TWO DIRECTORS. TO MAKE THIS
DISCUSSION FULLY TRANSPARENT. TO
DO IT IN A WAY THAT'S LAYING OUT
WHAT WE'RE UP.
TO GOING FROM THE STATE WATER
BOARD INTEGRATING STATE WATER
BOARD INVOLVEMENT AND MAKING
SURE EVERYONE HAS A CHANCE TO
UNDERSTAND.
AND OFFER CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM.
REALLY IMPORTANT MILESTONE LAST
FRIDAY FORTY FOUR INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING SOME OF OUR KEY
REGIONAL AND NATIONAL
CONSERVATION GROUPS.
AND WATER USERS SIGNED A JOINT
LETTER SAYING THERE'S STILL MUCH
MORE WORK TO DO.
NONE OF THIS IS FINAL.
BUT WE'RE WILLING TO KEEP AT IT
BECAUSE THIS IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA.
BUT ON THE DECEMBER TWELFTH
MEETING THAT THEY LEFT IT OPEN
THAT TO ADD MORE THINGS CORRECT --
COLLEAGUES CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THAT YOUR
TO JUST REAL QUICK LITTLE DEEPER --
THIS CINEMA COUNTY SPENDING TEN
TO TWELVE MILLION A MILE IN
TRACK BECAUSE JEOPARDY INTO
ANOTHER WOULD BE DEBRIS IN
DEEPER WATER.
HABITAT EXEDRA.
AND THAT'S JUST IN THAT SMALL
CREEK.
WITH THE COLD WATER SOURCE.
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE SO.
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY TWO ALL IN
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
THAT'S THE BUDGET WE PRESENTED
IN TABLE FIVE INTO SUBMISSION WE
MADE TO THE WATER BOARD LAST
FRIDAY OKAY.
AND THEN TALK ABOUT.
THE NEED.
FOR BECAUSE YOU STILL NEED THE
THAT COLD WATER CORRECT TWO CAN
YOU JUST.
WALK US THROUGH THAT IS WELL
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE.
IF YOU PUT IN THE WOODY DEBRIS
THE GRAVEL THE DEEPER WATER
HABITAT --
AUSTRIAN HABITAT CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH THAT JUST YES.
SO.
I THINK THERE'S A COMPARISON
THAT'S IMPORTANT HERE.
AND IS A CONSTRUCTIVE.
ONE IF YOU WERE TO JUST THINK
ABOUT THIS CHALLENGE FROM THE
AUTHORITIES AT THE STATE WATER
BOARD [inaudible]
IT.
REALLY IS FOCUSED ON HOW TO
PRODUCE STREAM FLOW.
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT DOES NOT HAVE THE ABILITY AS
I UNDERSTAND IT TOO ALSO COMPEL
HABITAT RESTORATION.
THE FIXING OF THE LAND.
THE IDEA OF THE THEORY BEHIND
THE SETTLEMENTS IS.
YOU CAN INTEGRATE THE TWO YOU
CAN COMBINE VAST HABITAT
RESTORATION WITH IMPROVE STREAM
FLOWS.
AND THE INTEGRATION.
THROUGH A VOLUNTARY EFFORT.
COULD PRODUCE BETTER RESULTS SO
WHAT YOU SEE IN THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS ARE ALSO FLOW
COMMITMENTS.
FLOW COMMITMENTS FROM THE SENIOR
WATER USERS IN THE TO WOLLEMI.
IN THE LOWER SAN JOAQUIN RIVER.
IN THE FEATHERED THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES IN THE
AMERICAN THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION ON THE UNITED STATES
FRONT --
VERY OLD SENIOR WATER RIGHT
USERS IN THE SACRAMENTO SYSTEM
EAST BAY MUD IN ALL THEIR
VARIOUS DISTRICTS IN THEM
CALLING ME --
OF VARIETY OF WATER USERS IN THE
AMERICAN.
OFFERING THEIR COMMITMENTS ON
THE WAYS IN WHICH THEY WOULD
MANAGE THEIR RESERVOIRS.
DIRECTLY FALLOW LAND.
AND RETURN THAT WATER OTHERWISE
USE FOR PRODUCTION INTO THE
RIVER.
SO THE SETTLEMENTS ALSO INCLUDE
A SERIES OF COMMITMENTS FOR
IMPROVING STREAM FLOW AND
ACHIEVING TEMPERATURE OBJECTIVES
LIFECYCLE NEEDS FOR SAM.
IS IT ENOUGH.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO FIGURE OUT THIS COMING YEAR.
AS WERE IN FRONT OF THE STATE
WATER BOARD WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SCIENTIFIC SUFFICIENCY --
THOSE KINDS OF MEASURES.
I MET MY LAST QUICK QUESTION TO
YOU YOU BELIEVE.
DOING THE HABITAT ENHANCEMENT.
YOU'LL BE ABLE.
THEY HAVE A DECREASED INCREASE
OF WATER.
I AND ACCOMPLISH.
THE SAME GOALS.
I WOULDN'T.
PUT THOSE WORDS IN MY MOUTH.
I MEAN THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING I
THINK.
THAT THERE'S VALUE AND
CONSIDERING THE INTEGRATION OF
FLOW AND NON FLOW.
MEASURES AS A GLOBAL PACKAGE.
THEN I THINK.
WE WILL NEED TO ANALYZE THAT
TRANSPARENTLY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE WATER BOARD IN
COMPARISON TO IF WE WERE JUST
REGULATING THE FLOW ONLY ASPECT.
AND THAT'S WHAT I EXPECT WILL
HAPPEN IN THE COMING WEEKS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANKS TO CARE FOR CASH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU --
GREATER BOTTOM.
IT'S HARD YOU KNOW YES THIS YEAH.
WE WE GET THAT --
APPRECIATE THE CREATIVITY I I
GUESS MY QUESTIONS MORE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE --
STRUCTURE SIXTY EIGHT AND TIMING
ON THESE VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS CAN YOU JUST WEIGH IN
ON THAT HOW YOU'RE THINKING OF
WHAT CAME INTO THE WALL --
WHAT GUIDANCE BEFORE WHAT IS IT
JUNE LAST YEAR SUBSEQUENT?
AND HOW THAT SORT OF LINES UP
WITH.
YOUR ABILITY TO EXECUTE ON
DIFFERENT POTS WITHIN --
SIXTY EIGHT QUESTION
[inaudible]
SO.
THERE WAS A LOT OF ACTIVITY LAST
YEAR -- YOU
MAY BE REFERRING TO THE
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE AND PROP
SIXTY EIGHT THAT ALSO HAS A DATE
MILESTONE.
COURSE RELATIVE TO THAT STATUTE.
DATE MILESTONE THERE'S ALSO
LANGUAGE AND PROP SIXTY EIGHT
THAT REVERSE THE FUNDS
EFFECTIVELY. TO THE AGENCY. TO
THAT ALLOW THE AGENCY TO USE THE
FUNDS FOR THE VERY SAME PURPOSES.
TO FIND IN THE WATER CODE OR
OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE THE RIVER
PARKWAY PROGRAM.
THEN IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR --
MIDDLE OF THE MONTH.
A FRAMEWORK WAS PRESENTED IN
FROM THE STATE WATER BOARD ABOUT
THIS ENDEAVOR.
AGAIN NOT A COMPLETE WORK.
AND THEN IN THE SHORT MONTHS OF
JANUARY FEBRUARY AND TWO
SECRETARIES AND A RENEWED
INTEREST AND AN OPENING UP OF
THE DIALOGUE FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
WE'VE JUST MADE ANOTHER
SUBMISSION TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD LAST FRIDAY MARCH FIRST I
THINK THAT WAS LAST FRIDAY.
OUR NEXT MILESTONE LAID OUT IS
TO BE BACK IN FRONT OF THE WATER
BOARD BEGINNING OF THIS JUNE.
WITH THE FINAL DETAILS SORTED
OUT -- AND I
THINK THAT'LL BE ANOTHER
IMPORTANT MOMENT OF CLARITY.
OF COURSE THIS BUDGET DISCUSSION
WILL RUN THROUGH THAT PERIOD
RIGHT.
AND IN MY PERSONAL VIEW SEVENTY
MILLION IS A FAIR DOWN PAYMENT
ON NO REGRETS.
WE NEED.
TO FIX THIS LANDSCAPE WE NEED TO
GO INVEST IN THESE PROJECTS --
END.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN MY VIEW
HISTORICALLY?
WE'VE RELIED ON CONGRESSIONAL
APPROPRIATIONS A WE'VE RELIED ON
PROMISES TO DO THIS THAT OR THE
OTHER.
THERE BEEN LONG LAUNDRY LIST OF
THINGS WE NEED TO DO.
THE LIST OF JUST BEEN SITTING
THERE.
AND NOW WE'RE WORKING TO
ASSEMBLE THE VERY PRIME
LANDOWNERS.
AND WATER USERS AND FORCED THE
CONVERSATION INTO A COMMITMENT
TO DO THINGS AND TO FIND TIME
TERM.
WHAT I'M NOT HEARING YOU SAY IS
WE INTEND THIS SOMEHOW I MEAN
THIS IS GOING BACK TO THE WATER
POURED IN OTHER WORDS WE STILL
HAVE THAT?
THAT CHECK AND THAT COMPARISON
AROUND.
YEAH THIS APPROACH VERSUS WHAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING.
YES NOT WHEN CERTAIN NOT PRE
DECIDING THAT HERE YOU'RE SAYING
REGARDLESS OF HOW THAT THAT
SHAKES OUT [inaudible]
THAT
THIS REVERTED POT AS HE PUT IT --
IS IS SORT OF NO REGRETS SAID OF
INVESTMENTS THAT THING SO.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS WORKS
ONLY IF.
THE EVENTUAL FINAL PACKAGE --
FITS WITHIN THE BOARD'S
REGULATORY PURVIEW.
AND MAKES SENSE FOR THEM IN
THEIR WATER QUALITY PLAN
OBJECTIVES.
ALRIGHT WELL I OUT WILL GO GOOD
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU IN JUST
LOOK AT THE THE REVERSION ISSUE
WE WATCH ON STABLE FOOTING IF
THIS IS THE GROUND WE'RE GONNA
BE PURSUING.
BUT WE'RE LEAVING THIS --
OPEN RIGHT THIS IS JUST A
DISCUSSION AT ALL DISCUSSION ARE
LEAVING EVERYTHING UP AND CUT
MYSELF.
THE SAILORS ON FROM THE LA L.
YEAHIT JUST TOOK A FEW POINTS
ON THIS --
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY BIG
PARITY WHAT OUR USERS AND AND
WATER PRIORITIES.
IT ALL OF THESE DISCUSSIONS AND
DECISIONS HAVE BEEN HAPPENING
OUTSIDE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PURVIEW THROUGH THE REGULATORY
PROCESS AND THIS VOLUNTARY
PROCESS SO.
THROUGH THESE APPROPRIATIONS IS
REALLY ONE OF THE AREA.
PRIME WAYS YOU ALL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO WEIGH IN AND ENSURE
THAT --
THESE IMPORTANT POLICY DECISIONS
ARE ARE.
BEING CITED AND AND BEING
PURSUED IN A WAY THAT YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH AND THAT THESE
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
IN A WAY YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH
FOR PUBLIC BENEFIT --
SO.
JUST MAKING THAT POINT THAT THE
KIND OF THIS THIS IS YOUR ENTREE
INTO INTO THESE DISCUSSIONS --
THE TIMING IS IS DIFFICULT BUT
THIS IS THIS IS AB KIND OF IN
THE FLUX RIGHT NOW JUST JUST
FRIDAY AS THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED
A LOT OF ADDITIONAL DETAIL CAME
FORTH SO --
BEFORE YOU MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
BUDGET.
I THINK I THINK YOU WILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION BEFORE
THAT YOU NEED TO MAKE A DECISION
SO YOU MAY REQUEST THAT AND WANT
TO KNOW HOW THINGS ARE PURSUING
YOU MAY WANT TO KNOW EXACTLY HOW
THE SEVENTY MILLION WOULD BE
SPENT IF THERE IS A LIST OF
SPECIFIC NO.
REGRETS PROJECTS YOU MAY WANT TO
SEE THAT BEFORE YOU MAKE THE
APPROPRIATION OR AT LEAST
UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT THE
DEFINITIVE CRITERIA THAT WILL BE
USED FOR DECIDING THOSE --
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY EVEN IN THIS
PER FOR YEARS TO APPROPRIATE FOR
THESE TYPE OF THINGS.
WHEN WE HAVE WE DO HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF HAVING THE WATER
BOARD UP NEXT SO [inaudible]
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY.
SECRETARY ANY FINAL THOUGHTS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU --
WILL.
LEAVE THIS MATTER OPEN --
ON THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT AND
NOW CONTINUE WITH DIRECTOR
BOTTOM ON THE OTHER.
OTHER OTHER THAN FIVE BE IS THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY BUT
OKAY.
THAT OF THE AGENCIES REQUESTING
TWENTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT EIGHT
MILLION AND ONE POSITION FOR THE
TRAILS AND GREEN WAYS PROGRAM.
IN THIS NEW COMPETITIVE PROGRAM --
WILL MAKE GREAT GRANTS FOR NON
MOTORIZED TRAIL PROJECTS TO
PROMOTE NEW.
OR ALTERNATIVE ACCESS TO PARKS
WATERWAYS OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL
PURSUITS AND FORESTED OR OTHER
NATURAL ENVIRONMENTS --
PROJECTS WILL BE ENCOURAGED TO
PROMOTE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
AND TO CONNECT CALIFORNIANS WITH
NATURE.
AGENCY WILL WORK IN COOPERATION
WITH STATE PARKS TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROGRAM IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RECREATIONAL
TRAILS ACT.
IN UP 225% OF THE FUNDS CAN BE
SET ASIDE FOR PROJECTS THAT
DEMONSTRATE INNOVATION.
AND PROVIDE OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES
TO DISADVANTAGED YOUTH --
DRAFT GUIDELINES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS WILL BE RELEASED IN MID
APRIL AND WE WILL HOLD THREE
PUBLIC MEETINGS IN MAY FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
THE FINAL GUIDELINES AND
SOLICITATION.
HELLO MISS EHLERS JUSTICE MAKING
THE POINT THAT THIS ISN'T A NEW
PROGRAM THAT THE STATE IS
RUNNING SO --
MAKING SURE YOU'RE FEELING
COMFORTABLE WITH DETAIL OF
EXACTLY HOW THE FUNDS WILL BE
SPENT IN PRIORITIZED.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA KEEP THIS
MATTER OPEN.
SEEMS LIKE EVERYBODY LOVES GREEN
WAYS IN TRAIL SELF.
LET'S.
DO OUR BEST LET'S GO ON TO ITEM.
FIVE C. WHICH IS FIVE C. IS ALSO
AGENCY --
MULTI BENEFITS STORM WATER
PROJECTS AGENCY IS REQUESTING
NINETY TWO POINT NINE NINE
MILLION AND THREE POSITIONS TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM.
THIS COMPETITIVE PROGRAM WILL
FUND A MULTI BENEFIT PROJECTS IN
URBANIZED AREAS --
TO DRESS FLOODING.
PROJECTS CAN INCLUDE THINGS LIKE --
BUT AREN'T LIMITED TO STORMWATER
CAPTURE AND REUSE RESTORATION OF
URBAN WATERSHEDS.
INCREASING PERMEABLE SERVICES --
TO HELP REDUCE FLOODING.
AGENCY WILL BE USING THE
EXPERTISE TO D. W. ARE IN THE
WATER BOARD ON THIS PROGRAM AND
TO HELP WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
THE PROGRAM DRAFT GUIDELINES
WILL BE IN MID JUNE AND WE WILL
HOLD THREE PUBLIC MEETINGS IN
JULY --
THERE'S A TWENTY FIVE MINUTES
PERCENT MATCH THAT'S REQUIRED
FOR THIS PROGRAM AND LET'S HEAR
FROM A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
I YEAH I THINK WE HAVE THE SAME
QUESTION THAT SENATOR STERN
RAISE ABOUT THIS HOW DOES THIS
STORM WATER PROJECT.
PROGRAM FIT IN WITH THE WATER
BOARD STORM WATER PROGRAM FIT IN
WITH THE TO BE OUR STORM WATER
PROGRAM SO IT'S ENCOURAGING TO
HEAR THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AT
IS WORKING TOGETHER AND THAT --
AND THAT ROOM AGENCIES BRINGING
THEM THIS NEW PROGRAM AT
RESOURCES AGENCIES SO THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE BOND BUT I
THINK TO THE DEGREE WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING IN CONCERT TOGETHER SO
WE DON'T END UP --
KIND OF DOUBLE FUNDING PROJECTS
OR WORKING AT CROSS PURPOSES AND
I PRESUME THAT RESOURCES I MEAN
THIS IS A DIFFERENT PROGRAM BUT
THE WHOLE SOLICITATION PROJECT
ON STORM WATER AND AND A
GRANDSON WE CAN PROBABLY GIVE
OUT NINETY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IN GRANTS.
RIGHT JUST.
THE AMOUNT A THAT AMOUNT OF
DEMAND OUT THERE IS INCREDIBLE.
WE FIND SOME OF THE PROJECTS
LIKE THIS UNDER URBAN GREENING
AND WE HAD.
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
GIVE OUT AND WE GOT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN APPLICATIONS.
SO THERE'S DEFINITELY A DEMAND
OUT THERE FOR THIS TYPE OF
PROJECT.
COLLEAGUES WILL KEEP THIS MATTER
OPEN.
CONTINUE OUR GOOD WORK.
A LET'S MOVE ON TO THE S. GMA.
FOR THIS ONE WILL HAVE A TERRON --
REVS YOU NEED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
THIS IS TWENTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
POSITIONS AND A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS REQUESTING.
GOOD MORNING.
THE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
TAREN RABBIT ZENI I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL INITIATIVES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE LEAD OF
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE COMMITTEE HAS PROVIDED THE
DEPARTMENT WAS SEVERAL QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THIS ITEM WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO IS PROVIDE A LITTLE --
CONTEXT AND THEN TRY TO HIT ON
THOSE --
ANSWERS AND ALL IN ONE NARRATIVE
I'LL TRY TO KEEP THIS BRIE
THOUGH TOO I KNOW THERE'S A LOT
ON THE AGENDA TODAY [inaudible]
I'M.
WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT --
IS A RECOGNITION THAT THE
PASSAGE OF THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WAS. TOO MANY OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA WATER LINE OVER
CENTURY.
THE DEPARTMENT IS ONE OF SEVERAL
ENTITIES INVOLVED IN SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS ACT --
THE CENTRAL TENET OF SIGMA IS IN
FACT TO KEEP LOCAL A TO KEEP
AUTHORITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
SO THE DEPARTMENT HAS A DUAL THE
TORY ROLE AND A LOCAL ASSISTANCE
ROLE I AND I WILL BE HAPPY TO GO
INTO FURTHER EXPLANATION OF
THOSE ROLES HERE TODAY --
STATE INTERVENTION COMES INTO
PLAY THROUGH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WITH
WHOM WE NEED TO COORDINATE --
IN TRYING TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO THE LOCALS AS THEY'RE PULLING
TOGETHER THEIR REQUIREMENTS --
AS WE ADAPT TO CLIMATE CHANGE IN
CLIMATE CHANGE WAS DISCUSSED
HERE TODAY --
THE IMPROVEMENT AND SUSTAINABLE
MANAGEMENT OF THE STATE'S
GROUNDWATER --
RESOURCES WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL RESILIENCY
SO SIGMA IS TRULY A MASSIVE
SHIFT IT'S A CULTURE SHIFT.
IT'S ALSO A CHANGE MANAGEMENT
SHIFT SO --
THIS IS NOT ONLY A HEAVY LIFT
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES BUT THE STATE
IS DOING ITS BEST TO RIDE ALONG
WITH THEM AND TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT THAT'S NECESSARY TO SEE
THIS SHIFT --
BE SUCCESSFUL --
I WAS MENTIONING THAT WE HAVE
DUAL ROLES --
IN -- IN
THIS.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
ACT -- THERE
ARE -- WITH
REGULATION OF STABLE MANAGEMENT.
THE HIGH AND MEDIUM PRIORITY
BASED SINCE OUR RESPONSIBLE FOR
MEETING VERY AGGRESSIVE
DEADLINES WITHIN THE ACT ITSELF.
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO FORM
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES AND DEVELOP GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS BY JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOR
THE TWENTY ONE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASINS.
AND FOR V. I. REMAINING OVER A
HUNDRED BASINS THERE ARE --
THAT ARE HIGH IN MEDIUM THAT
DEADLINE IS JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO THE
FORMATION OF GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES. FOR
THESE ENTITIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
PULLING TOGETHER THESE PLANS IN
THAT TIME FRAME.
THERE WAS A JUNE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DEADLINE AND THE
LOCALS WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
MEETING WHAT WAS THE FIRST STATE
INTERVENTION MILESTONE.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES WERE FORMED AND NOT --
DOES COVER A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE BASINS.
THE STATE HAS OVER FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN BASIN SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT ACT AS APPLIED
TO ALL OF THOSE BASINS.
BUT IT REALLY IS THESE OVER
HUNDRED BASINS THAT QUALIFY AS
HIGHER MEDIUM THAT HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MEET.
THE PLANNING DEADLINES AND SO
THOSE ARE THE FOCUS OF A LOT OF
WHAT WE'LL BE DISCUSSING HERE
YOU YOUR ATTENTION --
TO FOR A MENTIONING THAT THIS IS
A CHANGE MANAGEMENT ONCE THOSE
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES.
CAME TO FRUITION --
PART OF THEIR AT LOCAL PLANNING
IS DETERMINING HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO APPROACH PLAN DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEY ALTHOUGH --
WE HAVE A LOTOF GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES AND A
PARTICULAR NUMBER OF BASINS.
MORE PLANS CAN BE PROVIDED FOR
ONE BASIN FOR EXAMPLE --
YOU HAVE --
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DIFFERENT
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES JUST IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ALONE AND THERE ARE
FIFTEEN BASINS FOR THAT AREA --
THOSE GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES ARE
PLANNING TO DO MULTIPLE PLANS
FOR EACH OF THOSE BASINS SO AS
THEY'RE MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION WE THE DEPARTMENT
HAVE TO REMAIN SOMEWHAT NIMBLE
AND FLEXIBLE --
TO BE PREPARED TO RECEIVE THAT
ON SLIDE OF PLANS SO WE HAVE --
LEARNED.
RECENTLY THAT THE CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BASINS --
WILL DELIVER TO THE DEPARTMENT
UPWARDS OF OVER FORTY PLANS BY
THE JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
DEADLINE OF TWENTY TWENTY AND WE
AS A OF THE DEPARTMENT ARE
RESPONSIBLE UNDER THE STATUTE TO
REVIEW THOSE PLANS IN A TWO YEAR
TIME PERIOD.
IN ADDITION --
AGAIN WITH THE OVER --
HUNDRED BASINS SKEWS ME OVER THE
HUNDRED BASINS HIGH MEDIUM
BASINS THAT HAVE TO MEET THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DEADLINE WE
COULD E RECEIVING PLANS AT ANY
POINT FROM TWENTY TWENTY TWO ON
POSSIBLY EVEN AS EARLY AS
SOMETIME MID THIS YEAR.
HI SO WE EXPECT TO RECEIVE
UPWARDS OF COMING THREE YEARS.
NOW THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN ABLE
TO MEET ALL OF ITS STATUTORY
DELIVERABLES TO DATE A LOT OF
THAT IS DUE TO THE STAGGERED
TIME FRAME FOR THOSE
DELIVERABLES.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE PLAN
REVIEW WHICH IS A VERY CRITICAL
CRITICAL COMPONENT FORCING THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
IT WILL BE ESSENTIAL THAT WE
HAVE THE WORK FORCE AVAILABLE TO
REVIEW ALL OF THOSE PLANS IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
BUT AS I MENTIONED WE ALSO HAVE
A VERY ROBUST LOCAL ASSISTANCE
ROLL THIS IS A PART OF THE SIGMA.
EFFORT THIS WAS WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAD INTENDED AND IT
IS A COMMITMENT ON THE PART OF
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE
ASSISTANCE NOT ONLY THROUGH.
PROVIDING DATA SETS AND TOOLS
BUT ALSO FUNDING I IN GRANT
FUNDING SO THIS IS AGAIN WHERE
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT COMES
INTO PLAY.
SO OUR OUR CONCERN AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND TRY TO MANAGE THE
NEW DEVELOPMENTS OF THIS VERY
VERY NEW MASSIVE PROGRAM.
IS TO ENSURE THAT WHILE WE ARE
MANAGING OUR REGULATORY ROLE IN
DOING THAT EVALUATION WE ARE NOT
SACRIFICING THE ASSISTANCE ROLE
AS WELL.
SO BECAUSE THERE'S CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BASINS AND WORKING
AT A DIFFERENT TIME FRAME.
IN A VERY LARGE NUMBER OF OTHER
BASINS THAT ARE WORKING WITH
THEIR TIME FRAME.
THE ASSISTANCE IN THE REGULATION
ALL HAVE TO HAPPEN
SIMULTANEOUSLY OR CONCURRENTLY
AND THEREFORE WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S NO ONE POOL FROM
ONE SIDE. TO THE OTHER IN TERMS
OF OF THOSE DELIVERABLES --
SO WITH THE REQUESTED TIONS ARE
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS THE
STAFF'S STAFF SHORTAGE --
VISIT AGAIN IS TO MEET ALL OF
THOSE REQUIREMENTS BUT LET ME
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THOSE
THOSE ROLES THAT WE HAVE AND WHO
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
IS I THINK THERE'S NINE FOR THIS
EXPECTED GROWTH BUT THERE'S
NINETEEN FOR OUR OTHER STAFF
POSITIONS I GUESS.
I WOULD I WANT YOU TO CONTINUE
BUT IF WE HAVE IT'S A DUMB
QUESTIONS I LIKE ASK CONSENT IF
WE HAVE A HUNDRED BASIS.
AND WE AND WE'VE WE'VE GOT
SIGMAN WORSE WE WE REQUIRE
PEOPLE TO PUT TOGETHER --
THESE GROUND WATER AGENCIES WHY
DIDN'T WE JUST GET A HUNDRED
AGENCIES BECAUSE IF IF WE WANTED
TO HAVE A COORDINATED EFFORT I I
SEE THAT THERE'S THERE'S
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A
CRAZY WORLD OUT THERE IN THE
WORLD OF WATER BUT IF WE WE GOT
THE WATERSHEDS.
YOU KNOW WHEN OUR GRANDPA PAAS
SET UP THE WATER AGENCY THEY
JUST SORT OF SAID THIS IS MY
THIS IS AS FAR AS I CAN SEE IN
THIS IS WHAT I'M GONNA DO
[inaudible]
WAS THE WAS THE R. H. YOUR
RESOURCE AGENCY.
HELPING WERE COORDINATING
BECAUSE WE GET GIVE SIX SPOTS
LAST YEAR WHEN THEY CAME UP WITH
THIS CAN WE HAVE PEOPLE LOOK AT
HERE'S THE WATERSHED HERE'S THE
BASE AND WE'RE ALL HERE ON ONE
BASIN.
OF OVER AS WITHDRAWING FROM IT
AND YOU WERE --
A GROUND WATER AGENCY THAT WAS
ONE THAT WAS A COORDINATED MADE
UP FOR THESE PROGRAMS OR WE
COULD HAVE --
DEJA VU ALL OVER AGAIN WOULD
HAVING DIFFERENT FIGHTS NOW
WITHIN THE GROUNDWATER AGENCY
OVER -- THE
ATTACHED COMMUNICATIONS BASED ON
WHAT PEOPLE THINK IS THERE.
ARE PRIMARY --
CHALLENGE.
HE CAN HELP ME OUT WITH THAT
BECAUSE IT WAS BUGGING ME.
ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION AND I WILL DO
MY BEST TO HAVE A VERY SUCCINCT
ANSWER FOR YOU BUT IT IS A
COMPLEX QUESTION --
WITH THE WITH AN ELABORATE
ANSWERS SO SAYS --
AS BEST I CAN.
GOING BACK TO THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION GOING BACK TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
OF COURSE THERE WERE A LOT OF
INTERESTS NOT ONLY WAS ON THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH INVOLVED THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH WAS INVOLVED
BUT LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WATER AGENCY COMMUNITIES FOR
EXAMPLE.
THIS IS THE MAIN TENANT OF SIGMA
OF KEEPING GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IS WHERE WITH THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE GEOLOGY OF THOSE BASINS.
THE LOCAL AUTHORITY IS --
WAS SUPPORTED BY SIGNUP BECAUSE
OF THAT COMPLEXITY THE LOCALS
KNOW IT BEST.
BUT AS WE KNOW WATER ISSUES
HISTORICALLY HAVE BEEN QUITE
CONTENTIOUS AND DIVERSIFY BUT SO
IN ORDER FOR THE LOCALS TO KEEP.
THEIR AUTHORITY UNDER SIGMA WITH
THIS MAIN POLICY SHIFT FOR
COMING FROM THE STATE.
THAT WE NEED TO SUSTAINABLY
MANAGED THE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
GROUND WATER BASINS IN THE STATE.
IT IS REALLY PUT ON THE LOCALS.
I IF THEY WANT TO MAINTAIN NOT
AUTHORITY THEY NEED TO COME
TOGETHER AND DETERMINE HOW TO
GOVERN THEMSELVES.
NOW UNDER SIGMA AND THROUGH THE
REGULATIONS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
DID PASS --
IN MAY OF TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE --
GUIDEPOSTS FOR A THE NEED FOR
COORDINATION AGREEMENTS.
AND WORKING AT THAT LOCAL LEVEL
EACH PLAN DOES HAVE TO WORK WITH
FEE.
DECENT BASINS AND AND CONNECTING
PLANS SO THERE IS A COORDINATION
COMPONENT THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO SIGMA.
IN THIS IS FOR HAVING NEW HIRES
IF THEY COULD --
REALLY WORK WITH THE VARIOUS
AGENCIES TO HAVE ONE COORDINATED
PLAN IT MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
IMPLEMENTATION.
DATES BASED ON WHEN THE LOCAL --
PORTION OF IT IS IS --
IS APPROVED BUT WOULD LIKE TO
SEE RATHER THAN MAKING YOU KNOW
TWELVE GAZILLION PLANS COME UP
IS THAT DIFFERENT RESOURCE
AGENTS YOU KNOW.
THAT GAME STATE SIT DOWN BEFORE
AT THE AT THE BEGINNING AND
LISTS THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
COORDINATOR PLAN BECAUSE YOU'RE
ALL HERE ON THE SAME BASIS.
I KNOW THAT'S OF
OVERSIMPLIFICATION WELL AND I I
I THINK IT DOES SOUND LIKE AN AN
EXCELLENT IDEA --
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S ROLE IN
THIS -- WE
ARE REALLY SUBJECT --
TO WHAT WERE THE REGULATIONS
THAT WERE CREATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT APPROVED BY THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION.
OF COURSE IN LINE MEN WITH THE
WITH THE STATUTORY REGULATIONS.
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY TO HAVE
MULTIPLE BROWN WATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES PER
BASIN AND THEY ARE ALLOWED TO DO
MULTIPLE PLANS FOR THAT BASIN SO.
UNLESS THERE REALLY IS A SHIFT
IN THAT LEGISLATION I THINK WE
ARE -- IN
ORDER TO REACH WHAT YOU ARE
SUGGESTING WE CAN HAVE CONTINUED
SUPPORT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THROUGH OUR REGIONAL OFFICES
TRYING TO HELP.
THESE ENTITIES STREAMLINED THEIR
DELIVERABLES BUT AGAIN THIS IS
REALLY A UPON THEM THE LOCALS TO
DO THIS THEMSELVES AND ONE OF
THE REASONS AGAIN WHY WERE HERE
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
IS THAT WE ARE LEARNING.
THAT -- AN
EFFORT TO HAVE SIMPLY ONE GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY PLAN PUT
TOGETHER BY MULTIPLE GSA'S SOME
OF THOSE ARE BEGINNING TO
CRUMBLE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
DESPITE.
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT THEM WITH
FACILITATORS FOR EXAMPLE THE
DEPARTMENT IS SPENT OVER TWO AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FACILITATION SUPPORT SERVICES
IN THOSE REGIONAL AREAS IN THOSE
BASINS --
BUT WE ARE LEARNING THAT WE ARE
EXPECTING MORE PLANS COMING IN
AND AS A RESULT HAVE TO BE ABLE.
TO CONTINUE THE ASSISTANCE WELL
BEING ABLE TO REVIEW THEM.
JOHN I'M.
YOU CAN IMAGINE IF YOU HAVE A
FEELING SYSTEM BECAUSE YOU VOTE
FOR TAPPED THE WATER AND WE WANT
YOU TO GET IN SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN AND YOU'RE UNABLE TO COME
TOGETHER WITH YOUR YOUR
NEIGHBORS ON HOW THAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
MY PATIENCE IS BEING IT BEING
CHALLENGED YOU KNOW BECAUSE IF
YOU'VE ALREADY FOR IF YOU FAIL
THE SYSTEM AND WE DON'T DO
ENOUGH ON CONSOLIDATION WE DON'T
DO ENOUGH ABOUT.
ABOUT LOOKING USING THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY PERCEPTION OF OUR
PERSPECTIVE OF OF HOW WE'RE ALL
WORKING TOGETHER BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT THESE LEGACY.
AGENCIES THAT NEVER WORK PUT IN
THE BASIN PLAN THEY'RE GETTING
THAT.
USE UP OUR STAFF BUT PLEASE
CONTINUE WITH.
YOUR ROOM YOUR PREPARED REMARKS.
WELL THANK YOU --
SUIT JUST TO ELABORATE ON THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF ADDITIONAL
STAFFING TO HELP US --
POSTER THAT THE EVALUATION ROLE
OF THE PLANS THAT WE ANTICIPATE
COMING IN --
WE WILL HAVE TO EVALUATE AND
PREPARE ASSESSMENT OF EACH OF
THE GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS AS MENTIONED WITHIN A TWO
YEAR.
TIME FRAME WE ALSO A DO REQUIRE
THAT --
SUBMITTALS --
HAVE ALTERNATIVE PLANS SO HE'S
BEING --
ANNUAL REPORTS TO THOSE PLANS SO
ONCE THE PLANS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT.
ANNUAL.
REPORTS ARE REQUIRED TO THE
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS SO ALL OF THIS COMES IN
NOT ONLY IS THERE AGAIN THAT
REGULATORY EVALUATION OF THE
FIRST PLAN.
BUT THE ANNUAL REPORTING WORKING
WITH THE LOCALS WORKING WITH
THOSE SUBMITTING AGENCIES AND
THEN THERE EVALUATION AT A FIVE
YEAR FOR FIVE YEAR UPDATES AND
THIS IS A TWENTY YEAR PLANNING
HORIZON.
THE EXPECTATION THROUGH CIGNA
WAS TO REACH THE SCENE ABILITY
WITHIN A TWENTY YEAR TIME FRAME
SO THAT'S TWENTY FORTY FOR THE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR THE
HIGH AND MEDIUM --
BASINS.
I'M ADDITIONALLY DUE TO THE
REGULATORY NATURE THESE
ACTIVITIES MUST BE DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND AGAIN AS I SAID WE DO NOT
WANT TO SACRIFICE ANY OF OUR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS --
AND SO WE WILL CONTINUE
SUPPORTING OUR TECHNICAL
PLANNING AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AS REQUIRED.
A WITHOUT THE NINE NEW POSITIONS
THAT WE ARE ASKING AGAIN THERE
WILL BE IMPACTS TO THOSE EFFORTS --
SO I IT IS ALSO A DISH I AM VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE A CHOIR HIDE
TECHNICAL STAFF NOW THERE IS A
LOT OF TRAINING THAT IS REQUIRED --
AND THEREFORE --
THE SOONER OF COURSE THAT WE CAN
GET THAT STAFF THE BETTER --
WE WILL THERE WILL BE QUITE A
BIT TO DO SO HITTING THE GROUND
RUNNING --
MAYBE A LITTLE CHALLENGING SO WE
DO NEED TO BUILD UP SOME
TRAINING CAPACITY.
HOW WILL YOU PRIORITIZE THESE
GRANT PROGRAMS I MEAN YOU'VE GOT
IT ALL? TWO HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
GROUNDWATER --
AGENCIES IT'S JUST BEEN FORM
THEY'RE ALL GOING TO COME IN
IT'S ONLY A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS RIGHT IF THAT'S THAT.
THAT -- IN
THERE'S GOT WE'VE GOT THE
CRITICALLY --
THE PLEADED AREAS FIRST AS THE
OTHERS AND SOME.
I WOULD IMAGINE ALL THESE
AGENCIES HAVE A DIFFERENT LEVEL
OF EXPERTISE IN ELSE SOMETIMES
WE REWARD THE FIRST ONE THAT
COMES IN THE DOOR FIRST IS THE
THE ONE THAT CAN'T GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER.
IS THE ONE WE REALLY WOULD HAVE
TO NEED A COORDINATED SO HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU ANTICIPATE
PRIORITIZING.
THEY GET THE GRANT SEND THE
CRITERIA.
SO ONE THING AND THAT IS A
COMMITMENT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF COURSE TO SEE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY PLANS IS OF
COURSE OF A FOCUS ON THE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS.
A WE WE DO RECOGNIZE WITHOUT IT
TO MEET THESE AGGRESSIVE
DEADLINES IN THERE.
FOR THE STATE IS TAKING ON THAT
RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP THEM
ALONG.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A STRONG
FOCUS AND COMMITMENT --
TO SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WITHIN WITHIN THESE
GRANT PROGRAMS --
UNDER THE IMPLEMENTATION GRANT --
PROGRAM THE REQUEST THAT WE'RE
MAKING HERE TODAY.
IMPLEMENTATION UNDER SICK MAMA
IS REQUIRED UPON THE MIDDLE OF
THE GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN SO --
THE SUBMITTING AGENCIES DO NOT
HAVE TIME TO SIT AND WAIT TO SEE
IF WE APPROVE IT OR NOT.
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
STARTING TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
PROJECTS IN ACTIONS THAT WILL
HELP BRING THEIR BASINS INTO --
SUSTAINABILITY SO THEY HAVE
THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES WE NEED
TO HELP SHEPHERD THAT ALONG
THROUGH THESE THAT THESE THE
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT PROGRAM SO
WE HAVE --
BEN PROVIDING GRANT FUNDING FOR
PLANNING.
AND IF I CAN JUST PROVIDE A
LITTLE A BACKGROUND PROPOSITION
ONE WE WERE ABLE TO RELEASE OVER
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS --
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION WENT TO
IN MAY OF TWO IN THEN A TEAM WE
RELEASED EIGHTY FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. TO SEVENTY
EIGHT APPLICANTS OVER SIXTEEN
MILLION OF THOSE WENT TO
SEVERELY SAYS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES --
ADDITIONALLY WE ANTICIPATE
THROUGH PROP SIXTY EIGHT FUNDS
TO CONTINUE THE PLANNING GRANT
PROGRAM WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
REQUEST OF APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT.
BUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PLANS THAT ARE COMING TO US IN
THE BEGINNING OF JANUARY IS JUST
AS IMPORTANT.
DEALERS THEY ALEJO'S I THINK WE
WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE EXACTLY
YOUR QUESTION THIS IS CLEARLY AN
INCREDIBLY HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
STATE AND DIFFICULT FOR LOCALS
THEY REALLY NEED STATE SUPPORT
AND FUNDING.
TO DO THESE PROJECTS AND THEN
IMPLEMENT SO HOW HOW WILL
FUNDING BE IMPLEMENTED SINCE
THIS AT EXCUSE ME HOW WILL
FUNDING BE PRIORITIZED SINCE
THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM WITH.
THAT PRESUMABLY A LOT MORE NEED
AND DEMAND THAN THERE IS FUNDING
SO I THINK THAT PRIME.
PRIME TARGET FOR CONTINUED
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
ANYTHING SERVICE SECTOR.
THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AND LOOK FOR CHART
DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU --
LET'S GO DO IT.
ISSUE FIVE HE THIS IS --
STORM WATER MUDSLIDES AND FLASH
FLOODS.
FLASH FLOOD PROTECTION.
A FUNDING LEVEL MORE FLASH
FLOODS YES.
MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAMES ARE CO COME THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT
AND DAM SAFETY WITH TE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES --
I THINK THE GENDER DOES A PRETTY
GOOD JOB OF LAYING OUT AT LEAST --
AT THE LEVEL OF DETAIL WHAT
WE'RE PLANNING ON DOING BUT AT A
HIGH LEVEL.
THE REQUESTED --
FUNDS WILL BE USED TO BOLSTER
THE DEPARTMENTS FLOODPLAIN
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM FIVE POINT
THREE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
STATE OPERATIONS.
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR LOCAL SYSTEMS.
LAST YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED TWO MILLION PROGRAM.
IT BUILDS ON EXISTING DEPARTMENT
OF PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE LOCAL
LEVY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM COASTAL
FLOODING PROGRAM IN PREVIOUS
STUDIES CONDUCTED IN LOUISVILLE
FAN AREAS JUST TO NAME A FEW.
IT IS IN THE DEPARTMENT WILL
EXPAND ITS ROLE IN POST FIRE
WATERSHED ASSESSMENTS TO SUPPORT
LOCAL AGENCIES IN PLANNING FOR
MITIGATING FLOODED A BRIEF FLOWS.
THIS BOLSTERED PROGRAM SEEKS TO
MODERNIZE DEPARTMENTS WILL PLAY
MANAGER PROGRAM. TO READ TO
INCREASE FLOOD AWARENESS AND
REDUCE CHRIS FROM THE UPPER
WATERSHEDS THROUGH THE DAMS AND
INTO THE FOUR PLATES.
WHERE DO THIS BY PROVIDING DATA
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND OTHER
TOOLS TO ENSURE THAT STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES?
HAVE THE INFORMATION AND THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO INFORM
RESIDENTS AND POLICYMAKERS ABOUT
THE REGION'S RIVER FLOOD RISK
AND FLOOD MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
WE'RE GONNA PROVE THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
REGULATORY DAM SAFETY PROGRAMS
AND THE DOWNSTREAM OPERATIONAL
FLOOD RISK MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
THE BILL ON OUR EXISTING PRODUCT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH STATE FEDERAL
AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO INCREASE
COORDINATION ALIGNMENT AND
ACTIVITY.
M. OPERATE AND MAINTAIN DIRECT
AND REMOTE WEATHER MONITORING
NETWORKS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WE HOPE TO YOU KNOW BY
DOING THIS WILL VANCE THE
ALIGNMENT OF ACTIVITIES TO SERVE --
PUBLIC SAFETY THREE BROADER
WATERSHED PERSPECTIVE.
LET'S REALLY ALL I HAVE I MEAN
THERE'S THIS LITTLE BIT OF
INFORMATION IN THE AGENDA AS
WELL ABOUT SPECIFICALLY WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO WITH THE GRANT
FUNDING.
BANDAGES.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO REDUCE FLOODING AND
CLIMATE CHANGE THE CLIMATE
CHANGE RISKS RATHER IS PROBABLY.
HELP YOU OUT WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE MONEY AND SAYS I KNOW THIS
IS PROP SIXTY FUND BUT IT LOOKS
LIKE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE THE
SIZE OF THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
THAT WE HAVE HERE.
IN AS THE CHANGE IT LOOKS LIKE A
LITTLE DROP IN THE BUCKET.
BUT THAT'S IT HELLO MOST OF THE
FLOOD FUNDING THAT THE STATE
SPENDS IS ON THE CENTRAL VALLEY
STATE PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL
BECAUSE WE HAVE PARTICULAR
RESPONSIBILITY AND LIABILITY IN
THOSE AREAS THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT.
IS OUTSIDE OF THAT BIT ACTUALLY
FOCUSES ON OTHER AREAS OF THE
STATE AND AS SUCH I THINK WE'LL
HAVE A LOT OF INTEREST FROM AT
CONSTITUENTS AROUND THE STATE
BECAUSE OF THEIR IS LIMITED FUND
STATE FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
OTHER AREAS OUTSIDE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO --
AS A RESULT THE DETAILS OF
EXACTLY HOW THIS FUNDING WILL BE
SPENT PRIORITIZED ARE PRETTY
IMPORTANT AND NOT A TON PROVIDED
AS AS CONSISTENT WITH EARLIER
COMMENTS ABOUT PROP SIXTY I KNOW
I DID THE GOVERNOR'S --
GOVERNOR BROWN'S CLIMATE.
CHANGE CONFERENCE LAST SEPTEMBER
I ATTENDED THAT RESILIENCY BY
DESIGN A BAY AREA GROUP THAT HAD
SEVEN OR EIGHT DIFFERENT
PROJECTS NO LIFTING.
HIGHWAY THIRTY SEVEN SO THAT THE
AREA CAN FLOOD OVER ALAMEDA
CREEK REALIGNMENT I MEAN IT WAS
YOU KNOW. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
THIS FROM BILLION HERE FIFTY
MILLION HERE WAS THERE THE THIS
IS SEED MONEY.
REALLY SEED MONEY QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT.
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO URBAN
STREAMS RESTORATION PROGRAMS
ANOTHER.
OVER SUBSCRIBER BOB [inaudible]
PROGRAM.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
CHRISTOPHER TURN NOW --
DEBBIE DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
FOR INTEGRATED WATERSHED
MANAGEMENT A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
THIS MORNING.
AND THE TALK WITH YOU ABOUT OUR
OUR BUDGET NEEDS.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE URBAN
STREAMS RESTORATION PROGRAM
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FOR THE
PROGRAM --
IN BRIEF HAS DELIVERED AROUND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
SUCCESSFULLY TO OVER THREE
HUNDRED PROJECTS.
AND GETTING A LITTLE BIT BACK TO
SOME OF THE THE COMING BASICALLY
SENATOR STERN.
AND YOU MISTER CHAIR --
HOT ALL THESE PROGRAMS FIT
TOGETHER IF YOU THINK ABOUT --
OVER THIRTY YEAR OLD PROGRAM
IT'S BEEN FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ON THREE HUNDRED PROJECTS YOU
GET KIND OF THE POINT OF THIS
PARTICULAR ONE AND A LITTLE BIT
TO THE PUZZLE OF HOW THEY FIT
TOGETHER.
THIS PROJECT WITH THIS PROGRAM
RATHER IS REALLY FOCUSED ON
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED WITH --
WITH PARKS PROJECTS WITH ACCESS
TO THEIR WATER WAYS WITH
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES WITH
HABITAT RESTORATION AGAIN FOCUS
IN THESE URBAN AREAS AND WHEN A
PARTICULAR FOCUSES OF THIS
PROGRAM IS REFLECTED IN THIS
BUDGET REQUEST.
IS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THESE
ARE SOME OF THE HARDEST FOUGHT
MOST IMPORTANT DOLLARS WHICH
ACTUALLY GETS BACK TO YOUR
PREVIOUS COMMENTS IF I CAN.
CAN ALSO REFERENCE THOSE MISTER
CHAIR.
AND THAT IS WHAT REALLY IS THE
ROLE OF THE STATE IN ALL OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE HAVING
WHEN THE RELATIVE DOLLAR AMOUNT
THAT WE INFUSE.
IS [inaudible]
PLEASE TRADITIONALLY.
VERY SMALL COMPARED TO WHAT
LOCAL AGENCIES PUT INTO THESE
EFFORTS WHETHER IT'S GROUNDWATER
GROUNDWATER WHETHER IT'S STORM
WATER WHETHER IT'S FLOODING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY ETCETERA.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE MAKE
THE BEST USE OUT OF THE LIMITED
STATE FUNDS WE HAVE TO MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE NOT HAPPEN.
BUT FOR THE PRESENCE OF THESE
BOND DOLLARS WHAT IS THAT
ADDITIONAL VALUE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE AND THAT'S THE KIND OF
THING I SEE THIS PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR HELPING TO PROVIDE
ITS THIS THESE LOCAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NOT JUST
FOR THE NOT JUST FOR THE
PROJECTS THEMSELVES BUT ALSO TO
HELP.
THEM BUILD LOCAL CAPACITY OF
LOCAL LOCAL TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
ARE YOU LEVERAGE --
THE EXPERTISE THAT IGNORE THAT --
RESIDES HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT --
PROGRAM IS ALL ABOUT IT'S REALLY
FILLING THOSE CRITICAL GAPS AM
IN HOPES OF BEING ABLE TO
LEVERAGE THESE OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES BY THE STATE OR LOCAL --
ON SIMILAR EFFORTS SO WITHOUT A
LEAVE IT THERE AND I HAVE --
THE SOME STAFF FROM THE
DEPARTMENT MARK MANDATORY HERE
IF THERE'S ANY MORE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROGRAM
THANK YOU WITH US SOME OF THE
SCIENCE BECAUSE YOU KNOW SOME OF
THESE URBAN STREAMS OF FOR LACK
OF BETTER CHARACTER.
RECESSION HAVE JUST BEEN
NEGLECTED IN A THIRD STAGE AND
JUST BEEN ECLECTIC AND TRYING TO
RESTORE THE HEALTH OF THEM I
MEAN YOU WE WILL OBVIOUSLY ONE
HAVE.
THAT THE PEOPLE OF GOD GOOD AND
BAD BUT THE YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
SILT ACCUMULATION --
MANAGEMENT HAVE WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE DAY.
CUTTING EDGE TECHNICAL OR
SCIENTIFIC.
CHANGES OR WILL ANY OF THOSE
IDEAS BE IMPLEMENTED WITH THESE
WITH THESE PROPOSALS MEAN I
GUESS YOU HAVEN'T HAD THE THE
THE GRANT PROPOSALS BUT ARE WE
LEARNING TO MANAGER STREAMS.
BETTER OR WE JUST SORT OF DOING
THINGS THE OLD FASHION WAY THAT
CAUSES THE NEED IS SO
OVERWHELMING I GUESS THREE
QUESTION I'M GOING TO SAY YES.
AND THEN PASS IT OFF.
GOOD MORNING --
MARK MANDATORY DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES --
WITH YOUR LEARNED A LOT OVER.
THIRTY FOUR YEARS WITH THE
PROGRAM --
AND A LOT OF WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
IS GOING BACK TO SIMPLICITY
OPENING UP.
STREAMS WHERE WE CAN --
AND AND BALANCING THAT WITH
REDUCING --
OF RISK OF FLOOD SAMPLE --
A REALLY GOOD PROJECT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE ARE GIVING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
TO IS A PROJECT IN SOUTH
SACRAMENTO RIGHT NOW MORRISON
CREEK WHERE --
IT'S A CULVERT IZED --
CREEK AND IT AT ITS ADJACENT TO
A LOT OF REALLY STRATEGIC ASSETS
COMMUNITY CENTER.
SCHOOL --
ANOTHER MIDDLE SCHOOL AND THAT
PROJECT OPENING UP ACCESS TO THE
STREAM IS THAT REALLY A BIG
VISION OF THE PROGRAM.
AND IT IN LINE WITH PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT IT TO THE
DISADVANTAGE --
COMMUNITY AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY SO --
WE'VE INVESTED THREE YEARS OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THAT
PROGRAM.
FROM OUR URBAN STREAMS PROGRAM
TO THAT --
PROJECT AND HAVING THAT
COMMUNITY GIVE US A VISION OF
WHAT THEY SEE IS AND URBAN
STREAMS PROJECT IS.
IS WONDERFUL TO PAVE THE WAY --
FOR SIXTY EIGHT WE HAVE TO GIVE
OUT AT A MINIMUM OF 20% AND THE
PROGRAM TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
SO -- WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT AND THE YEARS OF
OPENING UP AND MAKING THINGS
MORE SIMPLE GETTING ACCESS --
TO THESE --
GREEN AND WATER FEATURES IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THEN YOU'RE
CONNECTED TO SO MANY OTHER
ASSETS EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SCHOOLS. FOR THE OLD
THINKING WAS THAT YOU JUST PUT A
CALL FOR DâN LAY SOME SMACK Là
AND THEN YOU YOU GET THE FLOOD
PROTECTION AND AND AND NOBODY'S
IN HARM'S WAY AND AND THE
SCIENCES THAT WE'RE LEARNING
THAT.
THE BY OPENING UP THE STREAMS
YOU CAN A YOU HAVE THAT THE
NATURAL --
THE WATER TABLE CAN ABSORB
WHATEVER AS FLASH FLOODING WILL
COMMAND BUT THAT THE AND THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE BED AND THE
SIDE BANKS CAN BE DONE IN SUCH A
WAY EITHER AT THAT SPOT EARLIER
ON YOU LOOK AT A WHOLE.
HEALTH THE RIVER.
CORRECT YEAH THAT THAT'S A LOT
OF WHAT THE PROGRAM'S LEARNED
AND APPLIED OVER THE YEARS IS IS
JUST THAT IS.
AND THEN YOU'RE LIMITED ON SPACE
THESE ARE TIGHT URBAN SPACES AND
YOU KNOW AGAIN WITH THE THEME OF
SIXTY EIGHT IS IS LET'S GET MORE
INCLUSIVE LET'S BRING MORE
PEOPLE. TO SEE THIS GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR PROGRAM --
WHAT WITH THE MODEST AMOUNT --
PROP SIXTY EIGHT AS TEN MILLION
DOLLAR.
WE'VE WE'VE ALREADY WHERE WE'RE
SPENDING A A SMALL PROCREATION
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS YEAR AND AS MATTER FACT AS
WE SPEAK THERE IS A PUBLIC
WORKSHOP IN AND GLENDALE.
ON THE PROGRAM AND THE GRANT SO --
WHY HAVE STAFF IT DOWN THERE
TODAY AND AND?
THE PUBLIC INTERACTING WITH THEM
IN ASKING ABOUT THE GUIDELINES
THE GUIDELINES ARE OUT --
SO WHERE DECIDED YET THAT BONUS
OF HAVING --
A SCHOOL THERE BECAUSE THEN THE
YOU CAN --
YEAH THAT JUST THAT JUST TO GET
SOME KIDS OUT TO THAT THE CREEK
AND COLLECT WATER AND GO BACK
AND AND DO WHATEVER THEY WANT
DOES.
EXACTLY.
OKAY YOU CAN HANDLE THE
CURRICULUM AROUND THAT.
KALLIO SAME COMMENTS AS THE
PREVIOUS ITEM THIS IS ONE OF THE
FEW FLOOD MANAGEMENT PROJECT AB
PROGRAMS THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO --
CLEARLY THEY'LL BE A LOT OF
DEMANDS A PRIORITIZATION IS
IMPORTANT THE GENIUS OF PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT IT IS A STATE WIDE
PROGRAM BY THE WAY SO OKAY
CENTER STERN.
THANKS JUST BRIEFLY THE CAN YOU
ALL -- WAY
IN A LITTLE MORE JUST.
CRITERIAS ARE WHICH IS THE
GENERAL SHAPE OF THE GUIDELINES
WILL.
WHAT WHAT WHAT MAKES A?
WELL ONE PROJECT MORE
SPECIFICALLY.
I I APPRECIATE THE THE COMMUNITY
OUT REACH EDUCATION SORT OF
PARTICIPATION COMPONENTS BECAUSE
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LEAST
LIKELY. TO BE ON YOUR RADAR
THOSE THAT NEED HELP THE MOST
OFTENTIMES LIKE HOW DO YOU FIND
OUT WHO DOESN'T HAVE CAPACITY IN.
OF ADDED GREAT QUESTION YEAH --
WE WE HAVE SOME TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO US FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE A A
AT A DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITY
MAPPING TOOL LET D. W. R. HAS
INVESTED IN --
SO WE CAN USE THAT AND ANYBODY
CAN ACTUALLY YOU CAN PICK UP
YOUR PHONE NOW AND GOOGLE DAC
MAPPING TOOL T. W. R. AND YOU
CAN GO TO THAT TOOL AND SEE
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND WHERE THEY
ARE -- THAT
WITHIN THE GUIDELINES --
WE'VE TAKEN PROP SIXTY EIGHT AND
HIGHLIGHTED CERTAIN THINGS THAT
ARE IN THERE WE WANT TO HIT.
AS HIGH SCORING PROJECT FOR
EXAMPLE COMMUNITY ACCESS AS PART
OF THAT --
AND DISADVANTAGE GET COMMUNITY
THE SO YOU'RE YOU'RE SCORING
HIGH ON THOSE --
AND WE GENERALLY IN THE IN THE
WE GENERALLY GET PROBABLY ABOUT
TWICE AS MUCH AS REQUEST FOR
FUNDS SO WITH TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OUT IN OUR LASSITUDE
SOLICITATION AND WE WERE FUNDING
THIRTEEN PROJECTS FROM THAT
MONEY BUT WE HAD PROBABLY ABOUT
TWENTY SIX PROJECTS THAT I HAD
SUBMITTED SO.
WE HAD A LOT OF DEMAND BUT GOING
AGAIN GOING BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION.
WE WE HAVE ALL OF THE POINTS OF
SIXTY EIGHT THAT WE WANT TO HIT.
SO YOU'RE GONNA SCORE HIGH AND
AND SO WHEN THAT THOSE DOLLARS
GO OUT THE DOOR FOR THEN.
THE NOT THE THE THE IN A CULVERT
MANAGEMENT OR NOT THREE CAPITAL
SIDE BUT ON THOSE SORT OF
OPERATIONAL SIDE OF THINGS THE
PROGRAMS I WHAT WHAT IS THAT
LOOK LIKE THEY'RE LIKE.
IN IN YOU THE WHAT WHERE YOU
SUCCEED IN THE PAST NERVES OF
WAS GOOD EDUCATION LOOK LIKE
WHAT IS A GOOD OUT REACH PROGRAM
LOOK LIKE I MEAN.
WERE YOU LOOKING FOR FROM YOUR
ALLEN'S OF EVALUATING THE
EFFICACY OF PAST EXPENDITURES IN
THIS PROGRAM I MEAN HOW.
HOW YOU DEFINE SUCCESS AND HOW
DO WE DEFINE SUCCESS --
WE YOUR YOU'VE DONE ALL OF YOUR
TASKS IN YOUR GRANT AGREEMENT
AND YOUR THE COMMUNITY HAS --
BEEN COMMITTED --
TO THE SOME OF THE NAM THAT
INVOLVE WITH AS WELL BECAUSE
BECAUSE YOU JUST DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE THE PROJECT AND EVERYBODY
FORGETS ABOUT IT YOU WANTED AS A
A CENTERPIECE OF A NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND AND THE GREATER COMMUNITY SO
SO THAT WE SEE A SUCCESS AND AND
SOMETIMES IT DOES SOMETIMES --
A OTHER DEVELOPMENT --
UPSTREAM PERHAPS HAS CAUSED THE
PROBLEM THE PROJECT TO FAIL AND
EVEN THOUGH ALL THE TASKS IN THE
GRANT AGREEMENT WE'RE DONE. FOR
EXAMPLE STABILIZING A CREEK --
ADDING SOME VEGETATION MAY BE A
FLOOD EVENT HAS WIPE THAT OUT
BUT IT'S IT'S OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES AND
PARTNERS.
OVER TIME AND AND STAFF GOING
OUT AND PHOTOGRAPHING IN
DOCUMENTING THE WHAT WAS ASK FOR
THEM TO DO IN THE AGREEMENT AND
WE ARE PER CURRENTLY PRODUCING A
WE CALLED IT A THIRTY YEAR
REPORT NOW 234- YEAR APART.
SO WE WILL HAVE THAT.
GIVES ME --
WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR WE WE HOPE
TO DO THAT SO WE WILL HAVE A LOT
OF THOSE LESSONS LEARNED BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT'S
WHAT.
YOU ALL WANT TO NOW AND AND WE
WANT TO IMPART TO ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS IS WATER THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED.
OKAY.
BUT EVEN IF THERE'S A DRAFTER
ANYTHING TO LOOK AT THE FOR YEAH.
IT ALL GETS FINANCING TO HELP
INFORM US AS WE LEAN IN FURTHER
HERE.
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THAT MATTER.
AND LET'S MOVE ON TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE [inaudible]
WE'VE GOT.
A PROPOSED TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
A FIFTY MILLION [inaudible]
OR FORTY EIGHT POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION ANNOUNCED PENDANTS HOW
YOUR COUNTY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI AGAIN MY NAME'S CHUCK BONHAM
ON THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE --
THIS ITEM WHICH I BELIEVE IS
IDENTIFIED AS ISSUE FIVE G. --
PROPOSES WITHIN THE PROP SIXTY A
PROPOSAL OF AGENCY TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DEPARTMENT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
PROPOSITION IS YOU KNOW
ALLOCATES FIFTY MILLION OVERTIME
SO ONE FIFTH.
LET ME GIVE YOU THE QUICK
BACKGROUND.
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN OUR DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
AS OF JANUARY NINETEENTH THIS
YEAR WE'VE COMPLETED TO WONDER
PROJECTS.
AND WE'RE ABOUT 90% COMPLETE OF
THAT PRIOR APPROPRIATION.
SO THIS REQUEST FOR TEN MILLION
WILL SYNC UP TO THAT.
OUR DEPARTMENT OWNS AND MANAGES
ABOUT A MILLION ACRES WHICH PUTS
US WITHIN PUNCHING WEIGHT OF
PARKS AS TO SIZE.
AND ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
PROPERTIES.
WHAT WE'VE DONE SINCE THE TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT
IS HER FIRST EVER INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST?
AND ALSO GO DO A VAST AMOUNT OF
TESTING OF ALL OUR FACILITIES.
SO THE WAY WERE PRIORITIZING
THIS TEN MILLION DOLLARS IS
DIRECTLY ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AT OUR FACILITIES FOR
EMPLOYEES --
WATER QUALITY WELLS
INFRASTRUCTURE THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS.
AND I'LL STOP THERE.
I HAVE SOME GENERAL COMMENTS
ABOUT THE COLLECTION OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROPOSALS BEFORE
THAT ARE SAFE FOR THE NEXT ITEM.
ON THIS I'LL JUST SAY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DID SUBMIT A LIST OF
SPECIFIC PROJECTS FOR EXACTLY
HOW THEY WOULD SPEND THE TEN
MILLION BEFORE YOU SO THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL INFORMATION TO HELP
EVALUATE.
HOW THE FUNDING WILL BE SPENT?
THERE WAS A LITTLE MATH PROBLEM
IT SEEMS ACTED REQUESTS AND THE
END OF THE MISSING MONEY IS THE
STATE BOND ADMINISTRATION --
THAT COMES OFF THE TOP OF EVERY --
KITCHEN OKAY.
VERY GOOD COLLEAGUES ON THE ON
ISSUE FIVE G..
WILL HOLD IT THANK YOU FOR THE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION MOVING ON
TO OTHER DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
[inaudible]
GLOBALLY. SEVEN THIS REQUEST.
THE PROPOSAL REQUEST FORTY FIVE
MILLION FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
FOR FOUR DIFFERENT PARTS
DEPARTMENTS --
THIRTY FOUR MILLION FOR STATE
PARKS SIX MILLION FOR CAL FIRE
THREE MILLION FOR EXPO PARK AND
ONE MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS --
EACH DEPARTMENT IS PRIORITIZE IN
THE PROJECTS FOR THESE FUNDS
BASED ON THE MOST IMMEDIATE
HEALTH AND SAFETY NEEDS AND ON
OPERATIONAL NEEDS.
WE DID ASK SOME QUESTIONS
PREVIOUSLY --
PALEO.
YES AB SO GLOBAL COMMENTS ABOUT
AROUND THIS PROPOSAL AS WELL AS
THE PROP SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING FOR
BOTH PARKS AND AB VISION
WILDLIFE ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
CERTAINLY WE THINK MAINTAINING
AND TAKING CARE OF OUR STATE
FACILITIES AND ASSETS SHOULD BE
A VERY HIGH PRIORITY.
WE JUST HAVE THREE KIND OF
CONCERNS AND COMMENTS OVER
ARCHING OVER THESE FIRST HOW
WILL THIS MANY BE PRIORITIZED
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS THAT FOR
EXAMPLE FISH AND WILDLIFE HAVE
PRODUCED LISTS OF EXACTLY HOW
THEY WOULD SPEND THE PROPOSED
FUNDING BUT OTHERS HAVEN'T FOR
EXAMPLE PARKS --
SUBMITTED A LIST OF ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS TWO HUNDRED
PAGES AND AT THE MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR YOU ALL TO WILL BE
SPENT AND PRIORITIZE THIRTY THAT
WORK FOR PARKS --
YEAH COMBINED WITH THEM THE PUB
SIXTY EIGHT IT'S FORTY FIVE AND
THE SECOND OVER ARCHING COMMENT
IS -- THE
WRITING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING IS A SHORT TERM SOLUTION
TO AN UNDERLYING PROBLEM SO WHAT
ARE THE ONGOING MAINTENANCE.
PRACTICES AT EACH OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS AND EXPENDITURES ARE
WE BEING THE IF WE ADDRESS THIS
BACKLOG WILL THE PROBLEM BE
SOLVED OR WILL IT JUST CONTINUED
TO GROUSE SO.
THERE WAS FUNDING IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AND BUDGET YOU'RE FOR SOME
DEPARTMENTS FOR MAINTENANCE
COMBAT CONSERVATION CORPS CAL
FIRE AND PARKS BUT NOT FOR FISH
AND WILDLIFE EXPOSITION PARK OR
THE TAHOE CONSERVANCY SO.
HOW ARE WE MAKING SURE WE'RE NOT --
JUST CONTINUING TO THROW MONEY
INTO A GROWING PROBLEM.
AND THEN THE THIRD OVER ARCHING
COMMENT IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT PROPOSE
A WAY TO TRACK THE OUTCOMES FROM
THIS FUNDING RIGHT NOW HOW WILL
THE FUNDING BE SPENT --
WILL THEY AT WHAT PROJECTS WILL
BE UNDERTAKEN AND SO AS NOTED IN
YOUR AGENDA WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTING TWO PIECES OF
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
TO HELP YOU GET AT SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION [inaudible]
FINANCE.
CAN YOU HEAR ALISON HERE AT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE ANY INFORMATION TO
ENSURE THAT THESE SIDE IN THIS --
INVESTMENT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
IS SUCCESSFUL IN ACHIEVING
DESIRED OUTCOMES WE WOULD NOTE.
THIS INFORMATION CAN BE
AVAILABLE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR MANY OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS AS OPPOSED TO
PROVIDING AT A BROADER --
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS HAVE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE IN THINKING THAT
THAT MAY BE AS INFORMATIVE AS
WELL IT TO BE ASSIGNED GOAL THE
SAME GOAL WITHOUT IMPOSING A A
BROADER REQUIREMENT FOR ALL
DEPARTMENTS.
I GUESS THE OTHER THE THE LARGER
QUESTION MAYBE THE SECRETARIES
IS ARE WE JUST CHASING OUR TAILS
HERE WITH THE WITH THE FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE
OF JUST WITH THE PARKS --
OR IN.
IN ON I PART OF THE MONEY I'M
SURE YOU'RE HAPPY BUT THAT THE
LARGER DEPARTMENT NEED.
SURE I WOULD ALL SAY IN AN
ALTERNATE OVER TO I AM TO MY
COLLEAGUES BEHIND ME AS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS ON
GOING MAINTENANCE NEEDS.
A PART OF SORT OF THE ISSUE
DEFERRED MADE AND SAYS THAT YOU
HAVE SORT OF ONGOING MAINTENANCE
NEEDS THAT AREN'T ADDRESSED THAT
BAND SORT OF BECOME DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS OVER TIME AND
SO WE ARE MAKING TARGETED
INVESTMENTS I BELIEVE.
MY COLLEAGUE ADDRESS IT FROM THE
ALLEY --
ADDRESS --
SORT OF SPOKE TO SOME OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND SO WE ARE TRYING
TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO SORT OF
BALANCE.
THAT SERVE ON GOING NEEDS --
WITH SOME OF THESE ONE TIME
INVESTMENT FRACAS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO MY RIGHT AND THE
GREAT.
NORTHWEST OF CALIFORNIA HAS SAID
THIS IS BEEN --
HAVE VISUAL NEGLECT FOR SOME OF%
THE THE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
IN AS WE LEARNED WITH --
THE GAS. FIVE TAX THAT SOME OF
THE ROADS GET TO THE POINT WHERE
YOU HAVE TO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT GOES FOR SO LONG THAT IT'S
NOT.
IT'S NOT JUST THE ROOF THAT HAS
TO BE REPAIRED IT'S A MAJOR
SERIOUS RECONSTRUCTION AND WE
THE LEGISLATURE MEAN INPUTS IT'S
DO WE KEEP MORE MONEY IN THE
BANK OR DO WE DO WE MAKE THESE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS IS THIS.
IS THIS --
LIST GROSS SOLARZ SO LARGE AND
WE YOU KNOW.
WE KNOW WE HAVE A TIGHT --
PURSE DOWNSTAIRS AND FINANCED
WE'D LIKE TO HAVE THE INPUT ON
ON WITH THESE ARE.
DO I NEED TO HAVE COLOR CODE
THINGS ON THE AND WHAT ARE THE
IF WE DON'T SPEND MONEY THIS
YEAR WE'RE GONNA SPEND TEN TIMES
THE MONEY YOU KNOW --
COMING UP BECAUSE WE'VE JUST
BEEN THE GOAL --
THE ROOF IF THAT'S IF THAT'S
WHAT THE QUESTION IS AND AND
WHAT.
THE SAYS AND HELP US AT THAT
WITH THAT MAKING AS DECISIONS.
SORRY JUST TO CLARIFY THAT THE
FORTY FIVE MILLION IN THE
INFORMATION THAT'S PROVIDED
ISN'T HELPFUL IN DOING SO WHAT
WAS JUST SUSPICIOUS.
DROP IN THE BUCKET RIGHT I MEAN
WE WE AND I DON'T HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF IS THIS. FORTY
FIVE FOUR FOUR A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WITH A SUPER CRITICAL
ALL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT
THAT WE'RE GOOD IT'S GOING TO BE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IF YOU
DON'T SPEND THE MONEY THIS YEAR
RIGHT.
VERSES OF A HODGE PODGE OF OF
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF A A
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS JUST NOT.
IS MY COLLEAGUES WILL SAY NOT
GRANULAR ENOUGH FAITH CLUB PUT
IT ONE MORE COMMENT AND THEN
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO THE FOLKS
BEHIND ME.
IT'S EITHER THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION REALLY IS TARGETED TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MOST
CRITICAL NEEDS IN IN THE
IMMEDIATE AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CAN GET ON THE GROUND
AND SO.
THEY CAN AT ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS CAN SPEAK
INDIVIDUALLY TO WHAT THAT
APPROACH LOOKS LIKE BUT IN TERMS
OF THE AMOUNT AND THE THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE THE INTENT
WAS TO ADDRESS.
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY CRITICAL
NEED PROJECTS THAT PRESENT
SIGNIFICANT SORT OF FIRE AND
LIFE SAFETY CONCERNS AND OTHER
THINGS SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN TO
MY COLLEAGUES BEHIND IF THEY
HAVE ANYTHING TO ASK.
ANOTHER CHANCE BRIAN DO WE AS A
PARKS AGAIN --
GOOD AFTERNOON --
TWO ISSUES HERE ONE IS THE THE
GROWTH OF THE THIS DONE.
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG --
LAST COUPLE YEARS HAVE BEEN
SPENT SOME STRUCTURAL BUDGET
FIXES THAT ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO HIRE ADDITIONAL MAINTENANCE
STAFF THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND SO WITH THOSE FOLKS IN THE
FIELD --
MAINTAINING THE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS THE THE
THETHE THE GROWTH OF THE THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
DECLINE OR HOPEFULLY STOP --
AND THEN AS FAR AS THE THE THE
PRIORITY OF THE THAT THE
PROJECTS TO THE THE PROJECT
FUNDING FROM THE THE AMOUNT
PROVIDED.
OUR FOR THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
PROJECTS. FOR FOR DEPARTMENT AND
A KIND OF IT X..
DESCRIBE THE PROCESS IS REALLY
REALLY ROB BROADLY AND WE STARTS
BY WORKING WITH DIRECTLY WITH
THE DISTRICT STAFF WHO ARE IN
THE FIELD.
WHO -- ARE
IN THE PARKS THE BEST AND THEY
COME UP WITH --
LIST OF PROJECTS THAT THEY
BELIEVE ARE THEIR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES AND THEY ALSO RANKED
AS PROJECTS.
THOSE THOSE PROJECTS FROM ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE ARE
SOCIALIZED INTERNET IN A
DATABASE AND WE WERE PROJECTS
SELECTION.
WITHIN STATE PARKS AND WE LOOK
AT THE HIGHEST PARTY PROJECTS
THEY WERE KIND OF PASSED FOR
FROM THE TO THE DISTRICTS.
AND WE THEN RANK THOSE --
THOSE THOSE PROJECTS BASED ON ON
THOSE CRITERIA SUCH AS HEALTH
AND SAFETY WHICH IS WITH IT VERY
HEAVILY AND SUCH THINGS AS RUB
REVENUE AN OPERATIONAL SAVINGS
THAT YOU HAD TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER.
SO MAYBE ABOUT PROJECT THAT IT
IS --
RESULTED IN COSTLY ONGOING
MAINTENANCE COSTS OR OTHER COSTS
OF STAFF CLASS.
BY DOING THE PROJECT WE CAN WE
CAN ALSO AVOID --
THOSE COSTS AND IMPROVE
OPERATIONS.
SO WHEN YOU SEE CRITICAL --
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ART.
THERE ARE SOME FACILITIES THAT
ARE SIMPLY CLOSED.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THERE IT'S
RAINING THE RAIN'S COMING IN
THERE THERE AND SAFE WITHIN
WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
IS.
AND THEN --
SOME THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
BE.
RAINY SEASON SO FAR EFFORT IF WE
DON'T DO ANYTHING IS IT CAN YOU
GIVE ME AN IDEA EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO BRING SOME OF THESE.
FACILITIES BACK INTO USE BECAUSE
OF THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SAID
MADE THEM UNINHABITABLE AROUND
AND USEFUL. FOR THE FOR THE
RIVER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FACILITIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
IN USE BUT HAVE HAVE.
EITHER I REACH THE THE
PREMATURELY REACHED THEIR END OF
THEIR LIFE OR NEED TO BE --
RESTORED --
UPGRADED BECAUSE OF A LACK OF ON
GOING RECRUITING MAIN AND SO --
IT COULD BE WATER SYSTEMS AND
AND YOU KNOW BRIDGES TRAILS IS
LIKE THAT THAT HAVE BEEN
MAINTAIN MAINTAIN PROPERLY AND
THE THE CONDITION HAS A GREAT IS
SUCH THAT WE NEED TO COME IN NOW
AND DO A MUCH LARGER INVESTMENT
IN JUST A ROUTINE MAINTENANCE.
DOWN NO I AM OKAY.
SENATE MCGUIRE MAKE IT QUICK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
FORWARD IN APPRECIATE THE WORK
AND FOCUS ON THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
SO.
MY QUESTION IS IS IT AN HOW WE
EAT IN THIS CRITICAL PROJECTS.
AT OF THE BILLION ONE PROXIMATE
OR BILLION DOLLARS DIFFERENT
MEANS THE STATE PARK THAT.
HAS.
HOW MUCH THAT IS THE CRITICAL?
YOU JUST MENTIONED.
SO.
THE THE THE WHAT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION WHAT WE WE DID IS WE WE
WE WENT THROUGH THE LIST AND AND
TOOK -- THE
HIGHEST PARTY PROJECT FOR THE
PLANES THAT WERE THOSE ROUGHLY
LIKE FOR SIX HUNDRED MILLION
WHERE THE THOSE OF THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY.
PUT FORWARD AND THEN WE THEN --
SCREEN FOR MORE TO FIND THE ONES
THAT WOULD WITHIN THAT POT WITH
THE ABSOLUTE MOST CRITICAL.
THERE'S A LOT OF PROJECTS IN
THERE THAT ARE THAT ARE THAT ARE
CRITICAL --
NECESSARY PROJECTS BUT WE WE WE
TARGETED THE MONEY FOR TO THOSE
THAT ARE MOST CRITICAL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO IS THERE.
IN IS THERE A PLAN ON SO WHAT
I'M HEARING AND I DON'T PUT
WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH.
OUT OF THE BILLION.
TO HALF A CRITICAL ESSENTIAL
WERE OBVIOUS REASON APPROXIMATE
NUMBERS WAS CRITICAL THE MOST
CRITICAL THANK YOU EVERYTHING'S
CRITICAL --
MOST CRITICAL IN YOU HAVE A PLAN
A PROJECT PLAN IN HOUSE.
FIND WHEN THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED WHAT I'M TRYING TO BE
A TO GET AT IS.
IS A FIVE YEAR PLAN TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
IS IT A DECADE AND THAT'S THE
SEAS WE START TACKLING.
THE GREATER DISCUSSION AND STATE
PARKS IS.
IS THIS WHAT I AT AT SIX SEVEN
MILLION HOW LONG SINGING TAKE
YOU TO BE A TO GET THOSE FIXED.
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL IS --
TO FOR YOUR PLAN TO ADDRESS --
ABOUT ALMOST FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF THE HIGHEST
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
THAT'S CLEARLY NOT GOING --
TO ELIMINATE THE THE BACKLOG
COMPLETELY WE WILL NEED --
TO MAKE FUTURE EFFORTS IN
PLANNING DECISIONS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S NECESSARY.
TO ADDRESS THE RIVER THE BALANCE
OF THOSE OF THOSE PROJECTS.
HEY IN WHILE WE HAVE ENHANCE
REVENUE THAT FINALLY STARTING TO
COME IN.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE AND AND
AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS
INTO THE DEPARTMENTS MATH I
THINK THE CHALLENGE THAT WE AVE
IS THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF OLD
FACILITIES.
THAT HAVE BEEN NEGLECTED
PROBABLY FOR A DECADE OR TWO AND
THE LONGER WE WAIT TO BE ABLE TO
GET.
TO THOSE PROJECTS THAT MAY NOT
BE IMMEDIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
THE MORE IT'S GOING TO COST
TAXPAYERS THAT'S WHY I I'D LOVE
TO BE ABLE.
TO WIN THROUGH THE CHAIR
OBVIOUSLY WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SEE OUT OF THOSE MOST CRITICAL
PROJECTS SEE IF YOU'RE SAYING
IT'S SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
MOST CRITICAL.
OR PARAPHRASING HERE RIGHT --
SPEND DOWN.
THE REASON WHY I WANT TO SAY
THAT IS I SEE THAT IS.
DO WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE END.
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT.
I DO BETTER BY DOWN THAT COST.
NOT EXPECTING AN ANSWER HERE
TODAY SIR AND I BUT I'M VERY
VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR FOCUS ON
THIS BUT WOULD LOVE.
TO WHEN WE HAVE THIS.
IF WE CAN GET INTO A DEEPER DIVE
CHAIR.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND THE DANCE
BETWEEN THE BOND MONEY AND THE
GENERAL FUND MONEY AND HANDS ON
WHAT'S BEEN WHAT'S BEFORE IS
BECAUSE WE AND AND SB ONE SO WE
HAVE DIFFERENT POTS.
THAT'S THE WAY WE WORK HERE AND
IS THE FORTY FIVE MILLION THAT
SAID THAT'S HERE FOR THE GENERAL
FUND IS THAT AN AUGMENTATION.
TO COMPLETE THE BUDGET TO GET
THE WORK DONE IS THIS SEPARATE
WORKHOW HOW DO HOW DID SIX
SIXTY EIGHT ONE AND AND THIS
GENERAL FUND MONEY SMOOTH IT OUT
FOR ME.
SO WHEN YOU.
GOOD THERE ARE PROCESS WE WE END
UP WITH A LIST OF PROJECTS IN
PRIORITY ORDER --
THE THIRTY FOUR MILLION ONE TIME
INVESTMENT.
ALLOWS US TO GET DEEPER INTO
THAT LIST THAN WE OTHERWISE
WOULD WITH JUST A PROP SIXTY
EIGHT MONEY.
OKAY BUT COMPLEMENTARY.
VETERANS AND ADVOCACY EACH
DIFFERENT PROJECT COULD YOU LOOK
AT IT BECAUSE OF BE.
HELPFUL BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT THAT THE
GIGANTIC PICTURE.
JUST LOOK AT IT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INPUT LET'S GO TO VARIOUS BOND
APPROPRIATIONS L. [inaudible]
HELLO --
WITH IT THERE IS A MOTION.
I FORGOT A CAT THAT EVERY.
AND THIS.
ONE WE HAVE OKAY THERE SAID
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS THAT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REPORT ON
THE PROJECTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S ALTMAN AND TOOK
WITH THE FUNDS APPROVED I THINK.
PROVIDED IN IT PARTNERS REPORT
ON THE SIZE OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOGS WITH WHICH
WE HEARD SOME.
I THINK AND IDENTIFY THE REASONS
FOR THE INCREASE OF THE BACKLOG.
WHEN WE COME OUT WITH THAT
BEFORE MAKING A MOTION SIR IS
THAT --
MISTER CHAIR.
WHEN WE DO THE DEEPER DRIVER
STATE PARKS WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THEM PRESENT?
HOME ON ON THOSE MOST CRITICAL
PROJECTS --
AND WHAT THAT --
ANNUAL PLAY LOOKS LIKE OVER THE
NEXT DECADE SO THAT WE CAN BE
BETTER INFORMED ON TAKING DOWN
THAT.
MASSIVE BACKLOG VERY GOOD.
I DON'T WITHOUT ON THE
COMMISSION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY CASKEY HI.
JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
OPENING [inaudible]
STERN.
WE'LL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I CAN GET BACK TO YOU.
NOW LET'S USED TO MOVE THE ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN A SIMILAR SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR --
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
PROCESS WE COMBINED ALL THE
ECHNICAL --
PROPOSALS LIKE RE APPROPRIATIONS
EXTENSIONS OF LIQUIDATIONS
RIVERS INS --
AN OLDER BOND REQUESTS AND THOSE
ARE ALL IN ONE BC PEER --
NINETEEN TWENTY WE HAVE HEARD
THE LA THOSE COMMENTS.
ABOUT NOT HAVING ENOUGH DETAIL
AND WHEN NEW POSITIONS ARE NEW
FUNDING AND BY AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCING WERE
MEETING NEXT WEEK TO PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION.
LA ON YES THE SAME COMMENT THAT
WHILE MANY OF THESE PROPOSALS
CONTAINED WITHIN THIS PACKAGE
ARE.
TECHNICAL SOME ARE NOT AND WE
THINK OU NEED ADDITIONAL DETAIL
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE DECISIONS
ABOUT THOUGH SO AB HAPPY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY ON THIS ISSUE.
IF WE NEED TO PULL AMOUNT WILL
PULL OUT ALL RIGHT FROM.
MEMBERS.
THIS WILL GET IT.
HOLD ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD NOW GET A MOVE TO THE
FISH AND WILDLIFE I'M GONNA
BRING BACK.
FROM MY PREVIOUS --
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND THAT.
RHODEN OF UNUSUAL SIZE BUT
BEFORE WE BRING FISH AND
WILDLIFE CAM WE HAD A PREVIOUS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAD OF
ROLL CALL VOTE CAN WE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JUST ON THE RIVER.
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
MORNING.
ALL RIGHT THAT MATTERS TO PROVE
THOSE MATTERS ARE PROOF FIVE
ZERO WILL CLOSE TO ROLL
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
GREAT.
BACK AGAIN --
MY NAME'S CHUCK BOTTOM ON THE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
I THINK THE NEXT WOULD BE IN
YOUR AGENDA ISSUE FOURTEEN YES
WHICH IS RADIO REPLACEMENT SHORT
STORY --
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT WE HAVE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT DIVISION --
WITHIN THAT LAW ENFORCED
DIVISION WE HAVE WARDENS OR
WILDLIFE OFFICERS.
THE GOOD NEWS.
A WE HAVE THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION AS HIGHEST IT'S EVER
BEEN -- FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX I BELIEVE.
AND OVER THREE HUNDRED SWORN
WILDLIFE OFFICERS OUT IN THE
FIELD.
THEIR JOB DESCRIPTION IS
INCREDIBLE.
THEY OPERATE IN REMOTE PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA THEIR JOB IS TO
PROTECT OUR FISH WILDLIFE AND
PLANTS.
THEY'RE OFTEN MILES AWAY FROM
BACK UP.
AND THEY HAVE HAND HELD RADIOS
AND THEY HAVE VEHICLE BASED
RADIOS.
THE BCP IN FRONT OF YOU IS A
REQUEST OF ONE POINT SIX TUNE.
NINE MILLION IN GENERAL FUND PER
YEAR FOR THREE YEARS.
THE BEGIN TO REPLACE THOSE WHY
DO WE NEED TO REPLACE THEM
[inaudible]
THEIR OLD.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NO LONGER
AVAILABLE FOR PURCHASE BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN DISCONTINUED.
AND MAKE A PARTS REALLY TOUGH.
IN.
OF PARTICULAR NOTE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN ARE
WILDLIFE OFFICERS HAVE ASSISTED
IN OVER TWENTY FIVE OF THE LARGE
WALL AND FIRES ANOTHER NATURAL
DISASTER RESPONSES.
AND OUR CURRENT TECHNOLOGY OF
THESE RADIOS DOESN'T ALLOW US TO
COMMUNICATE BETWEEN ALL THE
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
UPDATING WILL ALLOW US TO GET
THAT BENEFIT AS WELL.
BELIAU WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL IT
IS PART OF A LARGER COORDINATED
EFFORT ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT
AND DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO GET
THEM AT AND FEDERAL AGENCIES AS
WELL GET THEM ABLE TO TALK TO
EACH OTHER SO.
THAT MAKES SENSE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS ON RADIOS [inaudible]
CENTER MONNING.
THE PLAN IS A THREE YEAR.
TRANSITION THE UPGRADE.
HOW QUICKLY CAN YOU GET IN THE
FIRST YEAR CAN YOU GET?
SOME OF YEAR [inaudible]
VEHICLES IN.
SWORN OFFICERS CONNECTED.
THE NEXT SEASON OF WHILE FAIR
VENCER ORDERS IS IT TAKES THREE
YEARS TO GET THE HOME.
I DON'T BELIEVE WILL TAKE ALL
THREE YEARS IF THE WHOLE SYSTEM
BUT LET ME GET BACK TO YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE ON WHAT WE CAN DO.
IN A PHASED APPROACH WE'RE
LOOKING AT PROBABLY SIX HUNDRED
VEHICLE MOUNTED RADIOS ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED HANDHELD WE'VE GOT A
SUITE OF LARGE PATROL VESSELS IN
THE OCEAN WHICH ARE ALSO SUBJECT
TO THIS.
BUT I COULD COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AT YOUR PLEASURE WITH
THE ACTUAL BUILD OUT OVER THAT
TIME NO I THINK I THINK HIS
QUESTION THIS IS THIS IS IF YOU.
GIVE THE PERSON.
OR THE THE THE THE UNIT THE
RADIO ARE THEY THEY'RE
AUTOMATICALLY CONNECTED WITH THE
BIGGER.
DISASTER RELIEF --
COMMUNICATIONS OR DOES IT TAKE
HE IT DOESN'T UNTIL THE LAST
PERSON GETS THE LAST RADIO THEN
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN IT ALL
COMES TOGETHER TIME IS THAT.
WELL YEAH I THINK HE KIND OF
ADDRESS THAT BIT THE SO YOU
DESCRIBE THE DIFFERENT THERE'S
RULES THERE'S PORTABLE ONES
THERE'S ONE SON --
WATERCRAFT --
IS THERE WAITED SEQUENCES SO.
YOU GET OFFICERS EVEN WITH THEIR
PORTABLE.
HAND HELD COMMUNICATIONS EVEN IF
THE VEHICLE HASN'T YET BEEN AMID
LET ME LOOK INTO THAT IN GREAT
QUESTION.
AS TO THE BROADER FIRST RESPOND
OR NETWORK MY AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS CALIFORNIA
OPTED INTO THAT INTO --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE WOULD
BE GLAD WORK CHECKING WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND MAKING
SURE WE PROVIDE --
ANY INFORMATION TO YOU ABOUT
THAT BROADER EFFORT YEAH IN THIS
MAY BE TANGENTIAL BUT THERE'S
BEEN SOME RECENT NEWS REPORTS OF
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
CHANGING RADIO EQUIPMENT SO IT'S
ENCRYPTED.
SO PEOPLE WAS SCANNERS.
INCLUDING MEDIA CAN INTERCEPT DO
YOU KNOW IF.
THIS NEXT GENERATION IS
ENCRYPTED COMMUNICATION AND
DON'T WITHOUT CHECKING BILLION
WILL TAKE THAT AS A TO DO JUST
CURIOUS I'LL TAKE THAT AS A
MOTION CENTER MINING TO PROVE
THIS BUDGET REQUEST WITH THAT
CLARIFICATION.
SO MOVED OKAY --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MONEY THAT.
STERN.
LEAVE THAT MATTER OPEN THE
SEVENTH --
APPROPRIATE LET SOME.
LET'S REVISIT RODENTS.
RIGHT RIGHT NOT.
YOU STOLE MY THUNDER EARLIER
BEGINNING A HEARING --
SO THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
FROM OUR DEPARTMENT --
ASKS FOR ONE POINT NINE FOUR
NINE MILLION IN GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME. TEN POSITIONS PERMANENT.
AND ONE POINT SIX TWO FOUR
MILLION ONGOING WHY.
WE HAVE RODENTS OF UNUSUAL SIZE
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THERE IS AN ANIMAL'S CALLED
NUTRIA -- IT
IS NATIVE TO SOUTH AMERICA IT IS
NOT NATIVE TO CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ABOUT THIS BIG.
AND THERE DISTINCT
CHARACTERISTIC IS THEY CHEW UP
HABITAT.
THEY BURROW --
AND THE RISKS --
FROM THIS --
ACTIVITY ARE IMMENSE TO
CALIFORNIA.
WHY DOES THIS MATTER WELL WE
THOUGHT THEY WEREN'T IN THE
STATE ANYMORE AND BACK IN MARCH
OF -- TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE GOT A
REPORT AND CONFIRM THE NUTRIENT
MERCED COUNTY.
SINCE THEN WE FOUND THEM ALSO IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY TO ALL OF ME
COUNTY FRESNO COUNTY SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY.
AND MARIPOSA COUNTY.
THE GROWTH RATE OF THESE ANIMALS
IS A STARK INCREASE FROM THE
MOMENT OF DETECTION SOME OF OUR
POPULATION MODEL SUGGEST WITHIN
FIVE YEARS.
AGO FROM A COUPLE OF ANIMALS TO
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND AND THEY DIG INTO
LEVEES IMAGINE A LEVY COLLAPSING
BECAUSE A BURROWING THEY EAT
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THEY CHIU UP WETLAND HABITAT
RESTORATION.
THEY'RE ON THE DOORSTEP OF THE
DELTA.
SO IN.
SPRING OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
OUR DEPARTMENT CREATED AN
INCIDENT COMMAND EMERGENCY
SITUATION HI.
RE DIRECTED AT LEAST FORTY STAFF
AND OUR OWN INTERNAL FUNDING TO
BEGIN TO DEAL WITH THIS WE'VE
SINCE GONE OUT AND FOUND
COLLABORATIVE FUNDING.
FROM THE DELTA CONSERVANCY THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES BUT WE GOT TO DO
MORE.
THIS ISN'T A RADIC ATION PROGRAM --
THIS WILL ALLOW US TO CATCH THE
PROBLEM BEFORE IT COMES ON
CURABLE.
AND HERE IS WHERE I DON'T WANT
US TO BE.
SO THIS HAPPENED IN THE
CHESAPEAKE BAY.
A CONCERTED MULTI STATE FEDERAL
LOCAL [inaudible]
EFFORT.
OVER FIFTEEN YEARS.
REMOVED ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
NUTRIA.
AND ARGUABLY SAVED A BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE
RESTORATION OF THAT ECOSYSTEM.
COMPARED TO LOUISIANA NO OFFENSE
LOUISIANA.
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO CATCH THE
PROBLEM AT THE BEGINNING NOW.
WHAT THEY DO EACH YEAR IS PAY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR BOUNTIES?
JUST TO KEEP THE POPULATION AT
SOME STATIC LEVEL.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE AERIAL
PHOTOGRAPHY OF THE BY YOU YOU
CAN VISIBLY SEE THE HABITAT
THEY'VE LOST.
BECAUSE OF THE NUTRIENT
DESTRUCTION I WANTED TO BE MORE
LIKE THE CHESAPEAKE ENDEAVOR
LESS LIKE THE LOUISIANA
EXPERIMENT.
AND THAT'S THIS PROPOSAL.
WITH THE LA --
LIKE TO WEIGH IN ON THE SIX
HEATING THE FERTILE MA'AM WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL.
PLENTY OF CONCERNS ABOUT THE
NATURE.
CENTER ROOM MONEY.
THE ORIGIN WHERE THEY COME FROM
REGIONALLY SOUTH AMERICA SOUTH
AMERICA.
HOW DID THE ANIMAL GET HERE WE
DON'T KNOW?
SOMEONE BROUGHT IT.
THEY WERE BROUGHT INTO SOME OF
THE UNITED STATES BACK IN THE
THIRTIES OR FORTIES AS FOR
BEARING [inaudible]
COMMERCE --
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED BUILDING A
WALL TO KEEP THEM IN.
I PERSONALLY AM NOT PRO WALL
THANK YOU.
I WILL TAKE THAT AS A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE BUDGET REQUEST --
FOR FISSION --
WILDLIFE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
REQUIRE.
MORNING KNIGHT.
STERN.
WE'LL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN HERE
TWO VOTES --
I GET AHEAD NOW LET'S GO BACK
INTO [inaudible]
ORDER THE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD THIS IS.
PICKING UP BACK ON ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT I BELIEVE.
OKAY THIS ITEM [inaudible]
THIRTEEN AND EVERYBODY --
YES OKAY.
ITEM THIRTEEN CONSIDER.
THIS IS WHAT STATE WATER CONTROL
BOARD ITEM THIRTEEN I'M SORRY I
MISSPOKE [inaudible]
THIS IS.
THE TO CLARIFY THIS THIS BUDGET
REQUEST IS COMBINED FOR BOTH TO
TO BE OUR AND THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AND IT IS.
MAKING WATER CONSERVATION THE
CALIFORNIA WAY OF LIFE.
INDEED.
THERE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTOPHER TRAIL AGAIN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES.
I'M DOING MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD KAMALA INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND HAVE TECHNICAL
STAFF HERE AS WELL TO HELP OUT
WITH ANY QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT
COME UP WITH THIS ITEM --
YOU JUST NAME THE THE THE THE
ISSUE HERE IS HOW TO MAKE
CONSERVATION A CALIFORNIA WAY OF
LIFE AND THAT'S A VERY --
INTENTIONAL WAY I THINK OF OF
FRAMING THIS ISSUE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS --
REALLY BUILDING OFF OF WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE WHICH IS A
PORTFOLIO APPROACH TO BODY
SUFFICIENCY IN CALIFORNIA NOT
PORTFOLIO APPROACH NEED TO MOVE
BEYOND KIND THE BUMPER STICKER
MEANING OF PORTFOLIO INTO.
WHAT'S REALLY NECESSARY TO START
CHANGING THE CULTURE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WATER USE
EFFICIENCY IS HERE TO STAY SO
THAT IT'S DURABLE IT'S REAL IT
DOESN'T GO AWAY WITH WITH CHANGE
COULD NEVER MINISTRATIONS OR
TURN OVER IN THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT THAT IT REALLY BECOMES
SOMETHING THAT IS --
A BEDROCK OF HOW CALIFORNIA --
DOES ITS BUSINESS AND AND AND
AND HOW WE LIVE OUR LIVES.
AND SO THERE ARE SEVERAL PIECES
AND AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AND
HOW THAT COMES TOGETHER ONE IS
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS WHETHER
THEY COME FROM.
A LOCAL AGENCIES THEMSELVES ARE
FROM THE STATE.
THERE'S TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE AT THE STATE
AND ALSO THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IT'S REALLY USEFUL FOR WATER USE
EFFICIENCY -
THERE'S ALSO THINGS LIKE PUBLIC
EDUCATION VERY IMPORTANT THAT
CULTURAL ASPECT OF IMPROVING
WORRIES EFFICIENCY BEEN BEFORE
YOU WE'VE BEEN HERE BEFORE YOU
IN THE PAST ASKING FOR FUNDS FOR
THE SAVE OUR WATER CAMPAIGN IT'S
BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
AND REALLY LEVERAGING LOCAL
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND EFFORT AND
THERE'S IS FOURTH COMPONENT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY.
AND THAT IS THE POLICY SIDE OF
IT AND LAST YEAR AS WE'RE ALL
FAMILIAR LEGISLATURE PASSED IN
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SB SIX OR
SIX BY CENTER HERTZBERG.
AND ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY SOME WOMEN FOR FRIEDMAN
AND BECOME A MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
AND AND WHERE IMPLEMENTING THESE
THESE TWO PIECES OF
COMPLEMENTARY LEGISLATION --
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
I'M VERY PLEASED TO SAY THAT AND
I HAVE ONE COPY TO LEAVE YOU
TODAY AND WE CAN CERTAINLY COME
BACK WITH MORE IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED.
A COPY OF THIS DOCUMENT.
THAT IS A A PRODUCT OF A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN OUR
TWO STATE AGENCIES IN VERY
CLEARLY ARTICULATING FOR
OURSELVES VERY IMPORTANT YOU
LOOK AT INTER AGENCY AND HAVE CO
IMPLEMENTATION OF POLICY.
I'M FOR THE PUBLIC IT'S A ROAD
MAP OF OUR PLAN FOR IMPLEMENTING
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
AND WHICH THEN OF COURSE GETS TO
THE BUDGET NEEDS --
WERE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY WITH
MY MODEST REQUESTS FOR BOTH OF
OUR DEPARTMENTS --
IN HELPING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
AND HAPPY TO WALK YOU THROUGH
SOME OF THOSE PIECES --
BUT INTEREST OF TIME YOU DON'T.
KEEP MY COMMENTS THERE TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
WATER BOARD AND THEN SEE IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER CHAIR AND AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS EILEEN
SO BACK I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR F THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AND MY COLLEAGUE JUST SAID I
THINK WE HAVE COMPLEMENTARY --
PROPOSALS HERE TO IMPLEMENT --
THE REQUIREMENTS SET OUT IN THE
RECENTLY PASSED LEGISLATION --
THE WATER BOARD IS LOOKING --
FOR FOR NEW POSITIONS AND SOME
CONTRACT FUNDS MOSTLY TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE URBAN
WATER CONSERVATION MEASURES THAT
WERE SET OUT AND IN THE STATUTES
AND WE LOOK AT LOOK FORWARD TO
AND TAKING SOME OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED WE LEARNED.
THAT WE GAINED DURING THE
DROUGHT AND SOME OF MANDATORY
EMERGENCY MEASURES AND AND MOVE
THOSE FORWARD IN A WITH A MORE
ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS OF
FIGURING OUT LONG TERM.
AND LONG TERM STRATEGIES FOR OUR
REGULATORY PROGRAMS --
TO IMPLEMENT THOSE --
BEFORE WE WE GET BACK INTO THAT
TIME KIND OF DROUGHT SITUATION.
HELLO.
I WOULD RECOMMEND APPROVAL OF
THIS PROPOSAL WE THINK IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEGISLATION
THERE IS A LOT THAT THESE TWO
DEPARTMENTS NEED TO DO LAID OUT
IN THE IN THE LEGISLATION OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS WHICH
IS REFLECTED IN THE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES.
WE DO HIGHLIGHT AND IN OUR
BUDGET REPORT IN THEIR INCLUDED
ON PAGE THIRTY FIVE OF YOUR
AGENDA SOME OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS
WE THINK WILL BE IMPORTANT TO BE
ASKING OVER THE COMING MONTHS
AND YEARS.
BOTH KIND OF ON THE PROCESS SIDE
ARE THEY HITTING THOSE DEADLINES
ARE WE IMPLEMENTING AT THE PACE
WE INTENDED TO TERM OBJECTIVES
DOES THIS LEAD.
TO LESS WATER USE AND GREATER
WATER EFFICIENCY OVER TIME SO WE
WON'T KNOW THAT TODAY WE WON'T
KNOW THAT NEXT YEAR BUT AS THE
STANDARDS GET IN PLACE ARE WE
SEEING SO BOTH NEAR TERM AND
LONGER TERM OVERSIGHT.
AND HOW DO THESE CONSERVATION --
CHANGES WE MAKE HOW DO PEOPLE
REACT NOW THAT WE HAVE A
DILUTION OF RAIN RIGHT YOU KNOW
I THE IS IS THIS SOMETHING IS TO
SET.
YOU KNOW PHONY ACTING THAT
PEOPLE SAY OH YELP PRETEND I
WON'T I WON'T WATER MY LAWN NOW
BUT NOW THAT THE RAINS HAVE COME
IN THE LINES COME BACK AND IT
LOOKS NICE.
IN OVER THE SUMMER TIME DID THEY
SAY WILL WILL JUST TURN BACK
HONOR WE GET LET THEM GO BROWN
AGAIN LIKE THEY LIKE TO HILLS.
CENTER MONNING OF QUESTION.
OKAY I AM WE DO YOU.
HAVE.
IT'S AT REQUEST IS APPROVED AS A
AS BUDGET.
OKAY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE CASTING HI.
JONES MCGUIRE MONNING
[inaudible]
STERN.
OKAY WE'LL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN
[inaudible]
RUNNING LATE --
NOW WHERE AM I AT DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES.
THERE IS HALF.
IS THE COMBINED.
THIS WILL BE SENT [inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT MR COULD YOU CLARIFY WHICH
ITEM ON DECEMBER ON SAME THINK I
THINK I MIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE. EIGHT THROUGH TWELVE AS
WERE GOING I CHECK I DID THE
COMBINED ONE FIRST BUT I ONLY.
CALLED UP THE WATER RESOURCE FOR
THE NOT THE DEPARTMENT --
YEAH.
THE STATE WATER RESEARCH PART
LET'S GO ONE EIGHT THIS IS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD.
PROTECTION --
BOARD PERMITTING AND ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH SUPPORT OKAY TURNED UP
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR WHAT CASKEY
AND MEMBERS OF THAT COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS LESLIE GALLAGHER I'M
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE-CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
BOARD.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAD AND I DO YOU HAVE ABOUT A
TWO MINUTE TO GIVE YOU SOME
CONTEXT AND RESPOND TO THOSE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AND THE WALLS
GOING TO COME UP AGAIN SO --
YOU MIGHT WANT TO STAY FOR THAT
[inaudible]
SENATOR MINING. FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS THE BOARD HAS BEEN
CHARGED WITH OVERSEEING THE
STATE PLAN OF FLOOD CONTROL
FACILITIES.
BUT THIS IS KIND OF A UNIQUE
SITUATION AND I WANTED TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF CONTACTS.
IN THE MATTER OF FEDERAL FLOOD
PROJECTS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THE BOARD IS THE NON FEDERAL
SPONSOR IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS. FOR THE
PAST TEN YEARS THROUGH A
MEMORANDUM OF AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE BOARD THE DEPARTMENT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS OBTAINED THE
STATE'S SHARE OF FUNDING AND EW
OUR STAFF WORK AS PROJECT
MANAGERS ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD.
FOR YOUR LARGE SCALE
IMPROVEMENTS.
THE BOARD ALSO HAS A REGULATORY
ROLE THE BOARD MANAGES THE LOCAL
MAINTAINING AGENCIES PERFORMING
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE ON
THE FACILITIES AND MANAGES THE
ENCROACHMENTS AROUND THE STATE
PLAN OF FLOOD CONTROL AND THAT
IS OUR REGULATORY --
REQUEST THAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY.
IN THE BIPARTISAN BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CONGRESS
PROVIDED SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS TO
TO BE SPENT ON THEIR PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED FLOOD PROTECTION
PROJECTS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THIS FUNDING AMOUNTED TO ABOUT
EIGHTEEN TIMES THE NORMAL
FUNDING THAT'S GIVEN TO THE ARMY
CORPS FOR THESE PROJECTS.
THE STATE IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZE
THE NEED TO CLEAR THE DECKS SO
THAT THESE ARMY CORPS PROJECTS
COULD BE BUILT IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
THE BOARD MADE SURE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PROJECT CAN
PROCEED IN AN EXPEDITED SCHEDULE
BY REMOVING THE ENCROACHMENTS
THAT EXIST BEFORE CONSTRUCTION
CAN BE COMPLETED.
MORE RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN
SPECULATION THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
EMERGENCY DECLARATION OF THE
BORDER WALL FUNDING COULD IMPACT
THE ARMY CORPS AND THIS PROJECT
AND THAT'S WHAT YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ABOUT I AM
SPECIFICALLY IF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING DOESN'T MATERIALIZE
WHAT'LL HAPPEN WITH THESE
PROJECTS.
AND I THINK IT'S UNWISE TO
SPECULATE.
I KNOW IT'S NOT CURRENTLY ON THE
LIST BUT I CAN TELL YOU WHAT WE
HAVE DONE --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE IN THE
BEST POSITION TO MAINTAIN AND
MANAGE THESE FUNDS --
WE DO HAVE A SIGN PROJECT
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT THAT THE
BOARD EXPEDITED ON IT SCHEDULED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD BE AS
READY AS SHOVEL READY AS
POSSIBLE --
ALL THE PARTIES ALSO WHICH IS
THE STATE THE FEDERAL AND THE
LOCAL FUNDING WHICH IS SAFE
GATHERED AT THAT CRIMINAL AREA
FLOOD CONTROL AGENCY.
WE DO HAVE ADEQUATE WORK PLAN
MANY ALREADY SET ASIDE FOR
DESIGN AND DESIGN IS ON GOING.
SO PRACTICALLY EVEN IF THESE
FUNDS WERE DIVERTED --
THE SPECIFIC POSITION QUESTING
TODAY MAY GO AND FILLED FOR SOME
PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT THE GREATER RISK IS IF WE
DON'T HAVE THIS IN PLACE THEN WE
DO GO FORWARD WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE PLANNING --
FOR THAT WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
MEET THAT --
VERY TIGHT CONSTRUCTION TIMELINE
THAT CAME ALONG WITH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING OR THE THE
BIPARTISAN BUDGET ACT FUNDING.
SO THE QUOTE THE REQUEST HERE IS
FOR STAFFING AND REIMBURSABLE
AUTHORITY SO THERE IS NO GENERAL
FUND ATTACHED AT THIS TIME. FOR
THE SACRAMENTO RIVER EAST LEVY
PROJECT.
THE SAFETY BOARD HAS AGREED TO
THE FUNDING OUTLINED IN THIS
BUDGET REQUEST AND WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF FOLLOW STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND APPROVE THIS
REQUEST IS BUDGETED.
I COULD TAKE ANY OTHER SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
NO CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
ALL.
WHEN CASKEY HI [inaudible]
JONES REQUIRE [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHECK --
I OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON SANDY
MASUR CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND I WILL BE TAKING
UP THIS A PARTICULAR AGENDA ITEM
AND THE NEXT.
SO STARTING WITH THIS ONE THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE GROUNDWATER
ELEVATION MONITORING PROGRAM HAS
GEM.
IS THE FIRST DATABASE CREATED TO
COLLECT GROUND WATER ELEVATION
DATA STATE WIDE SO IT COLLECTS
FOR ALL FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN ALLUVIAL BASINS SO
IT'S THE FIRST OF ITS KIND.
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS
REQUESTING TWO POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWO MILLION DOLLARS
THEREAFTER FOR MAINTENANCE OF
WELL OF THE VACATION AND WHILE
DRILLING DATA.
THE CAST HIM SYSTEM IS USED FOR
MONITORING ENTITIES TO MEET
MANDATED GROUNDWATER ELEVATION
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
THE FUNDING WILL ALSO SUPPORT T.
W. R. STAFF TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
ENTITIES AND GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES ARE
GSA'S.
AS THEY MODIFY CAL JIM HAS JIM
INFORMATION AND MONITORING PLANS
TO ACCOMMODATE THE SIGMA
REQUIREMENTS WHICH WE HEARD
QUITE A BIT ABOUT A LITTLE
EARLIER IN THE AGENDA.
THIS FUNDING WILL ALSO SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT
AND ENHANCE THE ONLINE WELL
COMPLETION REPORTING SYSTEM
WHICH GIVES.
WHICH GIVES US A COMPLETE
INVENTORY OF WELLS.
THAT ARE IT WITHIN THE STATE AND
NEW WELLS AS THEY COME ON LINE.
AND THAT ALSO SUPPORTS
GROUNDWATER EFFORTS SO WITH THAT
THAT IS OUR PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS.
YEAH WE THINK THIS WILL HELP
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE PICTURE OF OUR
GROUNDWATER RESOURCES MAKES
SENSE NO CONCERNS [inaudible]
ALL.
MY CASKET HI JONES MCGUIRE
MORNING.
STERN.
YEAH MATTER OF GREAT OKAY THANK
YOU SO PARA STAMMER MEDIATION.
DAM AND RESERVOIR OR AS YOU
MENTIONED LOCATED IN SAN JUAN
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY.
AND THE SERVICE A TERMINAL
RESERVOIR FOR THE STATE WATER
PROJECT.
THE LAKE PERRIS STATE RECREATION
AREA IS A POPULAR AND HIGHLY
VISITED RECREATIONAL FACILITY
WITH OVER ONE MILLION VISITORS
ANNUALLY.
IT PROVIDES BOATING SWIMMING AND
OTHER WATER BASED RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE REGION.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
IDENTIFIED POTENTIAL SEISMIC
SAFETY RISKS IN ONE SECTION OF
THE FOUNDATION OF PARIS DAM.
IN IN OCTOBER OF THAT SAME YEAR
WE MOVED AHEAD WITH EARLY PHASES
OF THE REPAIRS.
THE SEISMIC RETROFIT AND
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE DAM ITSELF
WAS COMPLETED IN MARCH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND THE TOTAL PROJECT
COST IS AROUND TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION.
THESE RICH THE NATIONAL PHASE
REPAIRS.
WERE --
INSTITUTED TO CORRECT CONCERNS
WITH THE FOUNDATION AND PROVIDED
STABILIZATION TO THE DOWNSTREAM
FACE OF THE DAM.
INSTALLATION OF A SYSTEM OF
RELIEF WELLS TO ADDRESS SEEPAGE
ISSUES.
AND OTHER ANCILLARY IMPROVEMENTS.
THERE TO PROJECT ELEMENTS THAT
STILL REMAIN TO BE COMPLETED THE
PARIS DAM OUTLET TOWER
IMPROVEMENTS PROJECT.
IN THE PARIS DAM OUR MERCHANT
SEE RELIEF FACILITY PROJECT.
THESE TWO PROJECTS WILL FURTHER
ADDRESS SEISMIC ISSUES RELATING
TO THE RESERVOIRS ABILITY TO
MAKE RELEASES.
PROPOSITION EIGHTY FOUR THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER WATER QUALITY AND
SUPPLY.
FLOOD CONTROL RIVER AND COASTAL
PROTECTION BOND ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX INCLUDED FIFTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY
FOR RECREATION AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE ENHANCEMENT COSTS AS
THEY RELATE TO STATE WATER
PROJECT FACILITIES.
THIS PROTECT PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY REQUEST FIVE MILLION OF
THOSE FUNDS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BENEFITS OF THE OVERALL SEISMIC
REMEDIATION PROJECTS.
PROVIDED.
THAT THEY PROVIDE TO THE
RECREATION AND FISH AND WILDLIFE
ENHANCEMENT COMPONENTS OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT.
THESE DOLLARS --
PER THE PROPERTY --
FOR GUIDELINES AND REQUIREMENTS
AND RESTRICTIONS OR RESTRICTED
FOR THE USE OF SORRY A
RESTRICTED FOR THE USAGE OF
PROPOSED OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
ARE CONSISTENT WITH PAST
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS.
RELATED --
TO RECREATION AND FOR THISPARTICULAR FACILITY HANDS.
OTHERS SO WITH THAT I THINK THAT
IS THE PROPOSAL TODAY BEFORE YOU
AND AGAIN HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THE SAILORS HELLO YEAH
YEAH SO THIS IS PART OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT AS YOU KNOW
USUALLY IT'S THE STATE WATER
PROJECT CONTRACT USERS WHO PAY
FOR THE FACILITIES AT BUT IN.
SOME FACILITIES WHEN THERE IS A
RECREATION AND FISH AND WILDLIFE
BENEFIT IT HAS APPROPRIATE AND
AND TRADITION. FOR THE STATE TO
PAY A SHARE AS WELL SO THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS BASED ON
THE ESTABLISHED COST SHARE
BETWEEN THE STATE AND PROJECT
BASED ON PRIOR --
ACTIVE SO WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
[inaudible]
RED.
SO MOVE LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
WE CAN ASKING HI JONES MCGUIRE
MONNING [inaudible]
STERN.
LEAVE THAT MATTER OPEN.
LET'S GO TO OUR FLOOD
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS STATEWIDE
THIS IS ITEM.
ELEVEN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AGAIN CHRIS TRAIL DEPARTMENT
WATER RESOURCES.
SO CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD
PROTECTION.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED SB FIVE WAS BY
THEN SENATOR --
MACHADO AND OF THE MANY FLOOD
RELATED THINGS THAT REQUIRED
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT BUT
RESOURCES TO DEVELOP AND CENTER
BY FLOOD PROTECTION BOARD TO
ADOPT.
A KIND OF US INTO A MASTER PLAN
FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT AND
INVESTMENT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY --
THAT THE FIRST ITERATION THAT
PLAN WAS DEVELOPED AND ADOPTED
IN TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE SECOND M.
ITERATION WAS DEVELOPED AND
ADOPTED BY THE BY THE FLOOD
BOARD.
AND THERE ARE OTHER OUR LOTS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS OF LOTS AND LOTS
OF IMPORTANT PIECES AS PART OF
THAT PLAN --
BUT A COUPLE I WANT TO POINT OUT
TO YOU TODAY BECAUSE THE SYSTEM
OF FLOOD PROTECTION FACILITIES
THAT THE STATE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR AND THE LOCAL AGENCIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
NEEDS A LOT OF HELP NEEDS TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE NEXT --
SEVERAL DECADES --
TO REALLY GET IT TO WHERE --
IT NEEDS TO BE EVEN TODAY BUT
CERTAINLY LOOKING AHEAD ADDED
CLIMATE CHANGE ORLD WITH A SEA
LEVEL RISE IMPACTS AND CHANGING
IN ONE HYDROLOGY IMPACTS --
THE SECOND THING I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THAT WAS A MAJOR FOCUS
AND IF AND IN PARTICULAR IS
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CENTER BY FLOOD
PROTECTION PLAN.
DOCUMENT UPDATE WAS.
THE FACT THAT AS WE DO THESE
FLOOD PROJECTS WE ALSO SHOULD BE
CAN BE.
MUST BE.
ALSO PURSUING IMPROVEMENTS TO
FISH AND WILDLIFE HABITAT ALONG
THE WAY.
TURNS OUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
JUST LIKE THERE ARE ACROSS THE
STATE BUT IN BUT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN PARTICULAR IT'S
CERTAINLY OUR FOCUS TODAY THERE
A LOT OF LEGACY IMPACTS WHETHER
SOME GOLD MINING.
DREDGING --
LEVYING ARMS BASIC ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S BEEN
NECESSARY OVER THE COURSE OF THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA AND DOES
ECONOMIC ACTIONS OF BECAUSE A
LOT OF DEGRADATION TO THE
ECOSYSTEMS IN THE VALLEY.
AND TURNS OUT THAT A LOT OF WHAT
WE CAN DO FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT
IMPROVEMENT TO REDUCE RISK TO
LIVES IN ECONOMY.
ALSO CAN BE DONE IN A WAY THAT
BENEFITS FISH AND WILDLIFE'S ARE
TURNING BACK THE CLOCK IN THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT TH TO
BUDGET ITEMS THAT ARE BEFORE YOU
HEAR BOTH ONE RUN NOW AND AND
COMING NEXT REALLY.
REALLY GET AT AND THAT IS HOW
CAN WE PRIORITIZE INVESTMENT IN
PROJECTS USING WHAT PROPOSITION
ONE IN PROPOSITION --
SIXTY EIGHT TO GET OUTCOMES THAT
BOTH REDUCE THE RISK TO HUMAN
LIFE.
AND TO OUR ECONOMY IS ABOUT THE
SAME TIME DOING THOSE PROJECTS
IN WAYS THAT IMPROVE THE
ENVIRONMENT --
TURNS OUT THAT MORE AND MORE
OPPORTUNITY ARE --
ARE OUT THERE ARE BEING
DEVELOPED ARE SUPPORTED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES BY US BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT USED
TO BUDGET PROPOSALS ARE ALL
ABOUT IT'S PROVIDING THAT STATE --
OF VALUE IF YOU WILL AND
INVESTMENT IN THOSE PROJECTS A
VERY EXCITING THEY RANGE IN
SCALE FROM HUGE LEVY SETBACKS
MORTAL MILES LONG LIKE IN THE
YOLO BYPASS WHICH IS CURRENTLY
UNDER WATER AS IT SHOULD BE
RIGHT NOW --
DOING ITS JOB AS A FLOOD CONTROL
PROTECTION PROTECTION --
FACILITY FOR THIS REGION --
TO SMALLER PROJECTS SO FIXING
CULVERTS FIXING GATES FIXING
YEARS THAT --
THAT SERVE A CRITICAL FLOOD
PROTECTION ROLE BUT ALSO MAYBE
HAVE A HAVE HAVE CAUSED A
CONFLICT WITH WHAT FISHERIES
SPECIES --
OVER THE YEARS AND DESERVE TO BE
ADDRESSED AGAIN GETTING THOSE
TWO PUBLIC VALUES OF FLOOD
MANAGEMENT AND HABITAT
RESTORATION AND WITH A SINGLE
PROJECT THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
AND HAPPY TO ASK YOUR ANSWER
RATHER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
I'LL MAKE COMMENTS ABOUT ISSUE
ELEVEN AND TWELVE TOGETHER WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS THE
USES SEEM CONSISTENTWITH THE
BOND LANGUAGE AS WELL AS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
PLAN.
WILL KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO INCLUDE AND
SCHEDULE OUT EACH OF THESE
PROJECTS IN BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
WITH THE AMOUNTS OF THAT IF THEY
WERE CHANGES THEY WOULD COME
BACK TO YOU THROUGH THE GEL BC
PROCESS WHICH IS HELPFUL
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT WE'VE.
AB MASS FOR AND IN YOUR SO
THAT'S HELPFUL TO YOU KNOW I WAS
GOING TO OPEN UP THE PUBLIC.
HEARING FOR ALL THE MATTERS WE
WANT WE AS I EVER I AM ALWAYS
CHANGING WHY DON'T I OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING JUST ON THE ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN AND AND I'LL CALL
ON THIS NUMBER TWELVE WE HAVE
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT.
THEN I'LL HAVE ANOTHER PUBLIC
HEARING FOR ALL THE OTHER
MATTERS BEFORE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN LIKE TO HAVE
A COMMENT ON ANOTHER ITEM AND
ALL WEEK TO THE REAL AND THE
HEARING FOR THAT FOR THAT --
VERY NIELSEN WITH THE GOLDEN
GATE SAME ASSOCIATION I'M HERE
TO TALK ABOUT NUMBER --
ELEVEN OF MISTER JANELLE JUST OF
SUMMARIZE BRIEFLY WHAT THE STATE
WATER BOARD I'M SORRY FOR WHAT
THE STATE --
OF SAID REALLY FLOOD CONTROL
PROTECTION PLAN ADOPTED A COUPLE
YEARS AGO IT'S A A A A
DRAMATICALLY NEW DIRECTION FOR
FLOOD PROTECTION THAT FOCUSES ON
INVESTMENTS.
IN OF IN ALL FLOOD BY PASSES AND
FLOOD SAID BEFORE IT AND AND
FLOODPLAIN EXPANSION PROJECT
VERY MUCH LIKE OF THE THE ALL OF
THE OLD BYPASS PROJECT THAT
MISTER CHANNEL JUST MENTIONED.
LET'S PROJECTS ARE NOT ONLY THE
MOST EFFECTIVE FLOOD MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES THEY'RE ALSO CRITICAL
FOR HABITAT RESTORATION AND
ESPECIALLY RESTORATION FOR SAM
THAT'S WHY SALMON FISHERMEN ARE
ACTIVELY SUPPORTING THESE.
FLOOD RESTORATION PROJECTS THEY
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE AND THEY ALL
THEY PROVIDE THE FOOD AND
HABITAT THE NECESSARY FOR SAM
POPULATIONS TO RECOVER.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
HAS GONE THROUGH A
REORGANIZATION TO ALIGN
THEMSELVES BETTER AROUND ALL
AROUND THIS ISSUE O REALLY
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE THIS.
I THINK WITH THIS BUDGET REQUEST
YOU'RE REALLY SAYING THAT WE'RE
SEEING PROGRESS NOW ON A A HOST
OF OF PROJECTS --
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE DAY MEMBERS OF IN THIS
REQUEST OF THOSE PROJECTS ARE
READY FOR CONSTRUCTION --
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST OF THOSE IS
ACTUALLY NOT BEFORE YOU TODAY
THAT IS OF THE PROPOSED NOTCH IN
THE FREMONT WE'RE ON THE YOLO
BYPASS THAT'S PART OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT'S BUDGET WHICH FOR
ODD REASONS AS WE ALL KNOW IS
NOT BEFORE YOU TODAY --
BUT I JUST WANT TO TO COME HERE
AND GIVE THE DEPARTMENT CREDIT
FOR RE ALIGNING THEMSELVES TO
PUSH THESE PROJECTS --
SUPPORT THE PROJECT BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND WE OOK FORWARD --
TO BEING FOR YOU AGAIN WHEN
WE'RE READY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH --
EVEN LARGER CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THANK YOU WE'RE THE
PLAN IS TO HOLD THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM BUT WE HAVE.
OTHER THINGS [inaudible]
NEXT COMMENT.
MR CARE MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF WATER
SUPPLIERS IN SACRAMENTO VALLEY
WE SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROPOSED ALLOCATION LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF
AND TAKE UP THIS ITEM AND FUTURE
DATE THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT.
OKAY OUT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THIS ITEM THAT'S GOOD LET'S
FINISH UP ON ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
WHICH IS THE FLOOD RISK
REDUCTION.
I ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU WANTED
ADD.
REALLY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ELSE
THAT IS JUST CAN'T MOSTLY --
IN ISSUE OF SCALE THE PREVIOUS
ITEM WAS REALLY LOOKING AT THESE
LARGER SCALE PROJECTS AND THESE
ARE THEMATICALLY VERY SIMILAR
SAME OBJECTIVES JUST GENERALLY
SMALLER IN SCALE.
OKAY LA L..
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
OKAY I WILL.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE MATTER SO --
WILL KEEP IT THERE WILL COME
BACK.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN THE
PUBLIC HEARING FOR ANY MATTER
THAT'S COME BEFORE.
US THAT WE'VE HELD [inaudible]
OR OTHERWISE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND THE
PROBLEM WITH WITH THIS.
COMPUTE AFTER HIM GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER MONNING --
THAT'S ALL ALSO ON BEHALF OF
WATER REUSE CALIFORNIA JUST
WANTED TO SUPPORT --
YOU DIDN'T TALK ABOUT IT IN THE
HEARING BUT THERE IS FUNDING AND
PROP SIXTY EIGHT FOR WATER
RECYCLING.
WEHAVE A LONG EXHAUSTED THE
FUNDING FROM PROP ONE THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS LIST OF OF WATER
RECYCLING PROJECTS THAT ARE
WAITING FOR MORE FUNDING.
THIS IS A GREAT DROP IN THE
BUCKET.
TO GET IN SOME OF THOSE PROJECTS
OFF THE LIST SO THANK YOU AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MATTER WHEN IT COMES BACK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND AND AND
CENTER MONNING OF ALL BEARING
ALSO AGAIN WITH THE GOLDEN GATE
SEVEN ASSOCIATION ALL ITEM FIVE
A IS THE ITEM YOU HAD EARLIER ON
YOUR AGENDA TO DISCUSS VOLUNTARY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS.
ARE AND OF MY ORGANIZATION
BELIEVES THE VOLUNTARY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS COULD BE
VERY HELPFUL IN.
HELPING COMPLY WITH STATE WATER
BOARD REQUIREMENTS AND RESTORING
HABITAT THE PROBLEM IS THE
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT PACKAGE
THIS BEFORE YOU BEFORE THE STATE
WATER BOARD RIGHT NOW SUBMITTED.
SIX DAYS AGO IS DRAMATICALLY
INADEQUATE --
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE REQUIREMENTS
POINT DOES NOT --
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF
PROP SIXTY EIGHT OF THE AS OF AS
MR BONHAM OUTLINED.
THAT PROPOSAL IS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE WATER AND HABITAT TO
HELP RESTORE THE BAY DELTA IN A
COLLABORATIVE WAY THAT'S A
THAT'S A A LAUDABLE IDEA.
THE PROBLEM IS MUCH OF THE
HABITAT PROPOSED --
IS HABITAT THAT'S ALREADY
COMMITTED TO AND IN SOME CASES
LITERALLY ALREADY CONSTRUCTED ON
SO MUCH OF THE HABITAT PROPOSED
TO BE BLUNT IS NOT REAL.
ALL AND ON THE WATER SIDE.
THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION HAS MODELED THIS
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
AND THEIR MODELING SO THIS IS
THE BUREAU'S MODELING HOW THIS
VSA WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED.
SHOWS THAT THIS THE THE THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD NOT INCREASE
PROTECTIONS IN THE BAY DELTA IT
WOULD ACTUALLY DRAMATICALLY
WEAKENED PROTECTIONS IN THE BAY
DELTA BECAUSE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATIONS IN THE MIDDLE OF
ROLL BACKS. FOR THESE
PROTECTIONS NOW UNFORTUNATELY
THE VOLUNTARY SOME AGREEMENT.
APPEARS NOT TO PRECLUDE THAT
ROLL BACK SO IT IT ACTUALLY SETS
UP THE POSSIBILITY HAT OF THAT
SOME WATER AGENCIES WOULD
CONTRIBUTE MORE WATER THE BAY
DELTA.
BUT THE BUREAU OF RECLAMATION
WOULD GRAB THAT WATER AND THEN
ADDITIONAL WATER.
IN THE NORMAL CONDITIONS IN THE
DELTA WOULD ACTUALLY WORSEN
[inaudible]
THAT'S NOT.
ALL CONSISTENT WITH PROP SIXTY
EIGHT ON AGAIN WE DO BELIEVE
THAT VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS HAVE A PLACE WITH
THEIR DRAMATICALLY AN ADEQUATE --
WE'VE JUST COMPLETED AN ANALYSIS
THIS OF THIS OF PACKAGE IT'S NOT
REALLY AN AGREEMENT YET.
ON WILL SUBMIT THAT AND WITH A
LETTER -- TO
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE WE'RE GLAD
YOU'RE HOLDING A LOT OF WORK
LEFT TO BE DONE TO TURN THIS
INTO A CREDIBLE PACKAGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IS THE CHAIR AND SENATOR MINING
IS ELEMENT THAT IS WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY JUST QUICK TO
POINT SINCE AS THE AFTERNOON
ALREADY.
IN REGARDS TO FIVE A AND
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
WE JUST WANTED TO THANK DIRECTOR --
BONHAM AS WELL AS DIRECTOR IN
THE MID FOR THEIR ONGOING WORK
ON THE ISSUE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
A CORE NEEDING EFFORTS GOING
FORWARD AS WELL AS FIVE D. IT'S
ALREADY KIND OF BEEN SAID BY THE
LA -- AS
WELL AS AN STAFF COMMENTS WERE
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE FOR
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS RELATED TO
SIGNAL BUT WE JUST FEEL THERE'S
A LACK OF SPECIFICITY SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO LEARNING ADDITIONAL
DETAILS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS%
AFTER NUMBER THANK YOU TO
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL I'M ON
FIVE A LIKE TO LIKE MY COMMENTS
WITH MISTER NELSON ENERGY SEIZE
OPPOSED TO THE SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLAR.
BUDGET REQUEST FOR VOLUNTARY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS PRIMARILY
BECAUSE IT'S PREMATURE TO
APPROVE FUNDING FOR V. ESSAYS
THAT ARE STILL AWAITING ANALYSIS
AND APPROVAL BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD THE WATER BOARD WILL BE
CONSIDERING VIA SAY THAT'S AN
ALTERNATIVE IN ITS UPDATE TO THE
BAY QUALITY.
THE BAY DELTA WATER QUALITY
CONTROL PLAN OUT NO LEGALLY
BINDING AGREEMENTS HAVE BEEN
EXECUTED OR APPROVED AT THIS
TIME AT THE VERY LEAST IT'S
GOING TO TAKE THE REST OF THE
YEAR.
MORE LIKELY IN TEN TWENTY TWENTY
BEFORE THIS IS COMPLETE SO WE
THINK IT'S PREMATURE --
FOR THE MORE WE BELIEVE THAT A
CREDIBLE SCIENTIFIC OF
EVALUATION OF THE AGREEMENTS
THAT WERE NEGOTIATED UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION WILL
SHOW THAT THEY ARE INADEQUATE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH.
OF THE BAY DELTA TO PROTECT
HEALTHY SALMON RUNS IN THE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS THAT DEPEND ON
OUR NEED OF SALMON RUNS SO THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THE ITEM OPEN
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED DISCUSSION AROUND THIS.
REALLY QUICKLY ON ITEM --
THIRTEEN ENTITIES HE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE JOINT REQUESTS BY
THE W. ARE THE WATER BOARD TO
FUND THE WATER EFFICIENCY BILLS
THAT WERE.
SIGNED INTO LAW LAST YEAR --
WE WERE CAN CONSERVATION WAY OF
LIFE BILLS --
THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL TO
TRANSFORMATIONAL WAY TO MANAGER
STATES WATER SUPPLIES TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY IN THE FACE OF
LONGER AND MORE PERSISTENT
ROUTES SO WHERE IT REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE THIS MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS BRAND
DAWSON ON THE OFFICE YOUR CALL
CALIFORNIA WE WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE GUYS
ITEM FIVE A WITH IN OUR DC --
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THE VSA
AGREEMENTS OR ARE ENFORCEABLE
LET ALONE THEY LACKS SUBSTANCE
AND PROCESS OF THE PROCESS WAS
NOT THE MOST TRANSPARENT
INTERVIEW --
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ARE NOT FROM THOSE VSA
AGREEMENTS PREMATURELY --
AND WITH REGARDS TO WHAT JEFF
YOU DIRECTOR MR CENTER SO IF YOU
ARE IN THE BEST POSITION TO
WEIGH IN ON THE VSA AGREEMENTS
TO FUNDING.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT YOU CAN DO
THAT BY HOLDING OPEN AND FINDING
OUT MORE SCIENTIFIC DATA BEFORE
YOU DO SO SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
ON BEHALF OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT CITY'S WATER SUPPLIERS
RURAL COMMUNITIES COUNTIES AND
LOCAL LANDOWNERS IN THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS FIRST
ARE PRECIADO CHIN TO THE AGENCY
SECRETARIES THE DEPARTMENTS IN
THE DIRECTORS
[inaudible]
THIS
BUT
IT'S A LOT [inaudible]
IT. FOR IT
[inaudible]
THIS NEW SIR
DESCRIPTION.
THE CONCERNS YOU'RE DOING AND I
THINK A MEDICAL A LONG WAYS TO
ADDRESSING SOME [inaudible]
SEARCH [inaudible]
AS WELL [inaudible]
WHAT
[inaudible]
THAT'S AND THAT THEY COULD ALSO
USE I AM BENEFIT GREATLY FROM
EVEN SMALL AMOUNTS OF FUNDING
SOME SOME REALLY WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT AS AS AN ISSUE
THERE -- AND
THEN FINALLY --
ON BEHALF OF AUTO IN CALIFORNIA
THE TRANSPLANT --
SKEWS ME THE NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY WANNA MAKE COMMENTS
ABOUT.
WHAT YOU CHAIR WHILE RAISING
ABOUT THE NEED TO NOT JUST
RELYING ON PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT AND AND THIS ISSUE
OF SUPPLANTING PROP SIXTY EIGHT
FORD FOR WHAT OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE BEEN GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS --
IN IN NEEDS TO BE KEPT IN MIND
WE HEARD EARLY ON WHEN THE WHEN
THE PROPOSAL WAS FIRST PUT OUT
IN JANUARY BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
THAT -- AND
WHAT SOME OF THOSE THINGS ARE
ALREADY HANDLED IN PROP SIXTY
EIGHT THAT'S WHY WE MAYBE
DECREASE THE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION THAT OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE BEEN THERE OR DID
YOUR AFTER WHATEVER THE OTHERS
AND SPECIAL FUND WOULD HAVE BEEN.
WE SIMPLY DISAGREE WITH THAT
APPROACH THE EIGHT TO SUPPLANT
EXISTING INVESTMENTS WE
INTERPRET THAT AS IT NEEDING TO
BE ADDITIVE --
SO REALLY WANTING TO ENCOURAGE
THAT.
IN ALONG THAT SAME VEIN TWO
YEARS AGO THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS --
THERE WAS AN ACCOUNT ESTABLISHED
THE NATURAL RESOURCES
PRESERVATION AND PARKS
PRESERVATION FUND --
WHICH STARTED THAT CONVERSATION
ABOUT YOU KNOW WANTING TO DO PAY
AS YOU GO APPROACH IS TO THE
FUNDING THESE KINDS OF THINGS.
AND W'RE TALKING ABOUT THE THE
VERY SAME KINDS OF THINGS
WHETHER THAT'S AS SENATOR
MCGUIRE RAISED THE ISSUE THE
COAST COMMISSION STAFFING LEVELS --
TO ENSURE THAT THERE THE READY
IN AND ABLE TO AN TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES OF CLIMATE RESILIENCE
IN THE FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THE LEVEL RISE IT CETERA --
OR THE COSTA CONSERVANCY TO
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAMS THEY HAVE BEEN DOING --
OR STATE PARKS YOU KNOW THE
ADDITIONAL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING GAP NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED OF ANGELINE AND THEN
THIS MIGHT BE.
THE THE BEGINNING OF THAT
CONVERSATION AND THIS YEAR WE
KNOW THAT WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
CONTEMPLATE.
TURNED TO BE PUTTING TOWARDS
THESE --
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES --
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR FOR DFW --
AS WE KNOW SIGMA IS FEEL LIKE.
A DFW NEEDS TO BE AT THE TABLE
TO BE ABLE TO ANALYZE AND
PROVIDE.
INPUT ON ALL THESE --
GSA THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED THE
TO INCLUDE DFW LAND --
WHETHER THEY BE WILDLIFE
PRESERVES ETCETERA --
AND CURRENTLY THE ONLY HAVE ONE
P. ONE FOR THAT SO WANTING TO
SEE YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS BE MADE AVAILABLE.
FOR THROUGH NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY FOR ALL THE DEPARTMENTS
ARE IMPLEMENTING AMAZING
PROGRAMS TO TO ENSURE THAT OUR
OUR STATE CONTINUES TO BE
RESILIENT --
AND THEN THAT'S A LEAVE IT AT
THAT FOR NOW BUT LOVE TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AND
AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE A COMMON.
THANK YOU CONNECTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF AUDUBON AND AS SCHOOL --
OUR COMMENTS ARE PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON THE LOWER COST
COASTAL ACCOMMODATION FUNDING
THAT'S REFERENCED IN --
THE AGENDAS BACKGROUND.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH COASTAL CONSERVANCY IN
TRACKING THEIR DEVELOPMENT OF
THE ASSESSMENT THAT WAS REQUIRED
BY EIGHTY TWO FIFTY AND WHILE
THAT ASSESSMENT WASN'T PREPARED
IN TIME FOR THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
IT IS GOING TO BE RELEASED SOON
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE AN
APPROPRIATION FOR THE LOWER
COSTS COASTAL COMBINATION
PROCESS PROGRAM.
I'M.
IN THIS IN THE BRIGHT BUDGET
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN INSURE IT --
COASTAL ACCESS AND THAT WE DON'T
DELAYED THE PROGRAM BY ANOTHER
YEAR.
CURRENTLY THAT.
ZERO GOOD AFTERNOON REYES
THOMPSON THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR OPENING UP THAT
MIGHT FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE
END OF THE HEARING I THINK I
MISSED THAT WHEN I WALKED IN --
BUT HAVING SAID THAT I JUST WANT
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE'S --
BCP FOR OFFENDING FOR I'VE
NUTRIA AA.
AT RATIFICATION SOMETHING THE
METROPOLITAN DOES SUPPORT AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
ROBERT CORPS OF ONE FROM THE
LOCAL GROUP ON BEHALF OF
SPECIFIC OF THE NATION'S.
NUMBER ONE AT RISK OF FLOOD ZONE
WHICH IS PERFECTLY RELEVANT TO A
COMMITTEE THAT MEETS ON THE
FIRST FLOOR.
WERE WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITEMS IT IN TO ASSURE THE THE
COMMITTEE SINCE THE TOOK THE
TROUBLE TO WRITE ALL THOSE
QUESTIONS --
SAFECO WORKS DAILY WITH D. W.
ARE ALL THE FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
WE CAN PROVIDE MORE DETAILED
ANSWERS AS WE PROCEED.
NO ONE HAS THE ANSWERS RIGHT NOW
BUT THANK YOU AND THEN ON BEHALF
OF THE MODESTO IRRIGATION
DISTRICT WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE VSA --
ALLOCATION THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
X..
HI I'M SORRY BEHALF OF THE
COMMITTEE NATURE CONNECTIONS AND
THE FRIENDS OF THE LOS ANGELES
RIVER.
AS WANTED TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE COMMUNITY ACCESS
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD EARLIER
TODAY --
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING WITH --
THE RESOURCES AGENCY ON
IMPLEMENTATION --
AND APPRECIATE HAVING
CONVERSATION GOING ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST PAUL MASONAT
THE CIVIC FOREST TRUST TWO ITEMS
ONE I REALLY APPRECIATE A GOOD
PRINCESS BRIDE REFERENCE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR NUTRIA JOKE.
EARLIER AND ALSO AS WE ARE
LOOKING AT TO THE PROP SIXTY
EIGHT APPROPRIATIONS THINGS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER.
THAT WHEN THE VOTERS APPROVED
THESE ON THAT THAT FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR BOND AND THE LONG TERM
DEBT OBLIGATION COMES WITH THAT
WAS REALLY FOR THESE YOU KNOW.
ADDITIONAL GAINS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WERE NOT BACK FILLING
PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE HISTORICALLY
FUNDED FROM THE GENERAL FUND OR
G. G. R. F. FOR OTHER SOURCES
WITH THIS BORROWED MONEY.
I THINK IS REALLY CAREFUL AND OF
THE WEAPON DOING THIS LONG
ENOUGH TO SEE MANY DIFFICULT
BUDGET SITUATIONS.
WE DON'T HAVE DIFFICULT BUDGET
SITUATIONS THIS YEAR IN THE SAME
WAY THAT WE HAVE IN THE PAST AT
LEAST UNTIL IT MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT.
YOU KNOW USING EXPENSIVE MONEY
TO JUST MAKE DECISIONS EASIER
THANK YOU [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING --
I WILL CONTACT MISTER STERNUM
MISSPOKE WIRES OFFICE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WELCOME CENTER MINING.
BUT CHAO BY ALMOST [inaudible]
ONE ALL RIGHT.
GIVE THESE GUYS A CHANCE TO ADD
ON
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
WE WILL.
OPEN UP THE ROLE AND PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT BUT THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER.
RESOURCES MCGUIRE [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
JONES.
OKAY HOLD THAT MATTER OPEN ON
ISSUE NUMBER NINE ON THE GROUND
WATER ELEVATION MONITORING
PLEASE CALL THE APPS MEMBERS.
JONES MCGUIRE [inaudible]
STERN.
OKAY WITH ME THAT MATTER OPEN
ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
THIRTEEN MAKING WATER.
BREAKING WATER CONSERVATION THE
CALIFORNIA WAY OF LIFE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS CANS
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
HI VERY GOOD THAT'S I AM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN ITEM NUMBER --
FOURTEEN ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
RADIO REPLACEMENTS FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE --
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
STERN.
WE'LL CLOSE THAT MATTER OUT ITS.
PASSES FOR NOTHING --
AND THEN ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN
THE RODENT UP AND USUAL SIZE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
JONES MCGUIRE [inaudible]
STERN.
OKAY.
BOOK WILL CLOSE AT MATTER FOR
LET'S OPEN UP I ISSUE NUMBER SIX
ON THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING FOR VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES STERN I CLOSE THAT MATTER
OUT ITS PASSES FOUR ZERO ON
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT ON PERMITTING
AND FORTUNE FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION PLEASE
CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS.
JONES STERN.
THAT MATTERS APPROVED FOUR ZERO
AND ISSUE QUESTION OF CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE GROUND WATER.
ELEVATION MONITORING PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS JONES STERN.
THAT MATTERS APPROVED FOUR ZERO
AND ISSUE NUMBER TEN PARRIS DAM.
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS JONES STERN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE CITY.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR CALENDAR FOR
TODAY --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE
GERMAN